[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
everything
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
hello good morning and welcome to Big
Ideas live today at this Sky News
special event we are hoping to answer
one really big question who owns the
future well welcome and come on in
because to do that today we have invited
the very best of Business Leaders in
science and technology some of the
biggest thinkers and innovators we've
got the UK atomic energy Authority here
and spot the dog I've got a feeling he
is going to be taking center stage and
steal a lot of the Limelight there he is
more about spot the dog later and of
course we've got our award-winning team
of Sky News journalists on hand as well
well what a week it's been for big Tech
the likes of meta and Twitter could be a
big day for Twitter today with that in
mind we're asking the question what
happens next to Big tech companies we're
also going to be talking about space
space is big business but do we really
need to keep spending sending people up
into space and spending uh for that
matter and plus we're talking about
artificial intelligence should these
huge advances in AI be a concern or
actually should they be celebrated
we're going to be showcasing so much
great technology here today as well at
Big Ideas live all the technology that's
helping us make big leaps forward in
science in sport and in dating and we'll
be considering the question about what
the UK has to do to become a science and
technology superpower so some big
questions there and big questions of
course need big ideas and who better to
get the ball rolling than our Sky News
Science and Technology team
the scientists have done it and they've
used the virus itself to fulfill the
kind of biological Jiu Jitsu to turn the
virus on itself in the form of a vaccine
the first live Omicron variants now
they've got the sample they can grow it
up infect human cells with it in this
laboratory how long will it be until the
physical and digital collide
and the online world
tangible
as this
look no hands speak to the automotive
industry and they'll tell you that the
technology for automated driving is
effectively already here we're in a
Bitcoin boom and this is the frontier
a visible military campaign against
Islamic State was mixed with the more
covert one with cyber spies targeting
the group's ability to use phones and
other devices to communicate
thank you
these British weapons are vital for
Ukraine giving troops the ability to hit
valuable Russian targets at a distance
with precision
and this water is rain that has fallen
on the soil come through the Rock
and as you can see it's been so dry
there really isn't much of it
delaying climate action will simply dial
up the heat
are you feeling that there's still real
Anger from developing nations that
wealthy nations are not doing enough
sure I think
it's understandable
burning cold and emitting a lot of
carbon dioxide but that is on the cusp
of changing when green steel becomes
commercially available in a few years
time it will cost more if you were any
doubt about how significant these new
images are I wish you could be in this
room already just with these first five
images we've seen things we've never
seen before so this is a mock-up of
Columbus which is the European
laboratory on board the space station go
Jeff go Marco poly go Oliver you are
gone for space
[Music]
and today isn't just about talking we
want you to get involved immerse
yourself in what's going on here today
you're watching at home you can get
involved and we've got a live studio
audience with us here throughout the day
plenty of companies showing off uh the
tech that they're using and the
Innovations they have at their dispose
or lots of them dotted around
um anything from a company that's
printing 3D organs for surgeons to
practice on
um to fashion and what 3D printed can do
for fashion we've mentioned spot the dog
like I said much more from him later on
we've also got a Bookshop over there as
well so everybody you hear from in
today's panels the expertise have
published works so you can get signed
copies of their Works throughout the day
today and be part of the conversation we
want to hear from you if you're watching
at home head to Twitter hashtag Big
Ideas live 22 to send us your questions
and for those of you uh sitting here you
might have sat on them but there were QR
codes on your chairs if you scan them
you can send your questions to us for
any of the panels that are running
throughout the day
we're going to begin with the big
picture and now back in 2021 the
government signaled its intent to make
the UK both a science superpower and an
innovation nation and on Thursday the
chancellor Jeremy Hunt in the budget
spoke about this and the encouraging
news was that he is protecting the UK's
research and development budget and also
um doubling down on that pledge to
increase it by 2025 so it got us all
thinking what does the UK actually need
to do to become a Global Science and
Technology superpower well Sky News
Science and Technology editor Tom Clarke
is leading our first panel to discuss
this Tom
thank you very much Sarah Jane and
thanks to all of you for joining us here
and those of us who are joining us
remotely
um I hope it's going to be interesting
we have got a stellar panel here to
explore the question of can the UK
become a science superpower
um on my immediate right my left your
right uh Daniel corski CEO of public uh
former special advisor David Cameron I
understand in on these sorts of issues
and a public is a venture capital firm
uh focused on health and Technology
startups transform Public Services
next we have Smart Walpole former Chief
government science advisor uh so he
knows a fair amount about how
politicians think about science and I'm
hoping he will share some of those
secrets with us before that he was head
of the ukri which is the body that
decides how to distribute our r d budget
to the right kind of scientists in the
right way and last but not least at all
Zoe McDougall from Oxford nanopore now
if you haven't heard of their nanopore
make scalable DNA and RNA sequencing
devices for research by defense water
testing agriculture all sorts of
medicine you name it pretty much before
we delve into this question though I
thought we'd just take a quick listen to
our new Chancellor Jeremy Hunt what he
had to say in his budget speech on
Thursday about the UK's it's Science and
Technology position
I want to combine our technology and
science Brilliance with our formidable
Financial Services to turn Britain into
the world's next Silicon Valley I want
to go further so today I protect our
entire research budget and confirm that
we'll increase Public Funding for r e to
20 billion by 24.25 as part of our
mission to make the United Kingdom a
science superpower
we'll get into the wording of that
statement in a second because it's it's
slightly misleading in my opinion but
we'll discuss that further but I thought
I'd just start by asking all of you guys
starting with you Dad
can the UK become a science superpower
or is it already
I think it's fair to say if we've got to
stick to the language of international
politics that we may not be a superpower
but we're sort of a rising power you
know we've got a lot of the basics right
we've got lots of great companies
nanopoers of course one fantastic
example we've got a big investment
sector that's willing to pour money into
it but the truth is also we haven't
quite done all the things that we need
to do in order to build up our arsenal
we haven't been spending enough on R D
we don't have enough people studying
various stem subjects and frankly
funding isn't really what it is in the
US if you had to compare ourselves so we
can get there but there's still work to
be done and the budget we've seen has
taken some steps forward and a few steps
backwards so we'll see over the next
coming period Well science superpower
well I mean the first thing is it's good
news that that is a government aim it's
really important and it really matters
for the future of the country because
we're going through an industrial
revolution amazing new technologies
amazing new businesses and we've got all
the challenges of climate demographic
change so we need to be
um we're extraordinarily good at
research there's no question about that
do we exploit it most effectively
probably not yet and the money is really
important but also the environment in
which researchers and innovators work
that's really important you know can we
continue to bring the best people from
overseas that's a really important test
so I think you know it's it's all good
news but there is a huge amount to do
yeah I want to get into the money and
those other issues in just a second Zoe
superpower or not
uh we are the center of some of the most
extraordinary science and Innovation and
I think we can talk about Academia but
we can also talk about industrial r d
which is a huge focus in this country
and we are amazing at spin outs and
you've obviously funded many of them but
we're not so good at scale up and the
life sciences industrial strategy that
was published about three years ago said
we the UK should have in the next few
years at least four con four companies
worth 20 billion pounds we're not quite
there yet our scale-up Ambitions really
have to be bigger as a country
now I thought I'd stay with you Zoe
because one area where we I think
certainly during the pandemic we
demonstrated the UK does lead in human
genomics getting information out of our
genes using them for the good of
medicine or Humanity at large your
company makes very clever devices that
do that I thought just by a way of
introducing nanopore and what you do
could you just talk us through what you
make of course
um so we developed we were spun out of
the University of Oxford in 2005 and
over the subsequent years we made a
molecular sensing platform it's really
based on electronics I've got one of our
devices here and while it can look at
lots of molecules proteins DNA our first
application is DNA sequencing and the
magic happens in here we have bespoke
electronics and attached to those basavo
electronics are nanopores on a membrane
we essentially suck DNA through very
small holes and run an ionic current
through those holes and every little
Pico amp and fluctuation in that current
we we analyze it and we translate the
signal into a DNA sequence so a few of
me for all the technical language but
basically what that means is DNA is in
every living thing humans plants animals
pathogens as we know through covid if
you know the DNA sequence you can
understand what the identity of that
organism is you can understand whether
it's healthy disease is it changing so
it's incredibly important information as
you said in the introduction around
Healthcare agriculture food safety all
sorts of amazing real world applications
and it's really the real world
applications that we're interested in
fantastic so those of you watching the
live stream will have got a good look at
that but the audience hasn't so Zoe
would you mind passing it round now as I
understand there's about 400 million
pounds worth of r d in that device so
it's not to leave this room uh you pass
it on mostly it can sequence your DNA so
if you do take it we know who you are we
know who your parents are and we know
who your kids are as well so you're not
you're not going to get away with it
although we only charge a thousand
dollars for a starter pack so to be
honest you can shoplift it that's fine
with us available all good Carphone
Warehouse maybe okay great so you let's
have a look at that um but let's get
stuck into this question of funding the
government has protected the r d budget
Jeremy Hunt there in the comments saying
he'd raised it by 20 billion dollars 20
billion pounds sorry in fact that was
the pre-existing commitment they
maintained science funding but this is
in effect a doubling of where we were
before so are we spending off I thought
I'd start with you Mom
um
well I mean you know what's the right
amount to spend on research and
development we are if you look at it as
a percentage of uh GDP we're still not
in the Forefront so we are perhaps about
2.4 at the moment if you take into
account the recent ons calculations
U.S Germany Korea were at three percent
in 2020. so it's good it's heading in
the right direction but it doesn't put
us by any means amongst the world
leaders
for you how important is that you're a
company that spies of Oxford University
that's showing that seed money that
early r d public spend must be crucial
if we're going to see better companies
better ideas come out of the UK brains
yes it really is and we were spun out of
original ideas at the University of
Oxford actually we have collaborations
with 25 universities all over the world
and many of those are in the UK and we
actually sponsor research and
development in UK universities so that
when those incredibly amazing Blue Sky
ideas come out of the universities we
can then take the onward research and
onward development to make them into
product that then we have to face the
really practical elements of
manufacturing shipping around the world
supporting our customers and all of
those elements are continuing that we
need to focus on all the areas of them
and from your perspective in terms of
the companies they're growing do you get
the sense that we could be doing better
yeah just to add a couple of things to
what Mark has been saying um we're not
doing as well as some of our competitors
um but just to unpack that that's both
on the public sector side of the
spending but it's also a private sector
r d spending isn't as high as some of
our competitors and the other thing to
remember is we have a very concentrated
um expenditure profile so lots of things
are going on in the sort of Golden
Triangle of Oxbridge and London but not
as much outside compared to the much
more decentralized funding that we see
in lots of other countries and then
obviously by definition changes a little
bit the profile of what's coming through
now
um there are lots of great researchers
there are producing lots of great things
but our University sector I would argue
isn't quite as good as comparable
sectors say in the US at supporting
companies to emerge and if we compare
some of our universities say to the mits
and the stanfords I'd argue that we
still have lots to learn to help
companies out
I agree with that but I mean if you look
at University sector it is an
extraordinarily powerful sector actually
you know maybe second in the world to
the US but it's hard to think of
anywhere else that has such an
extraordinary range of universities and
I think I just might not make a comment
about what we just seen from Zoe which
is
there's a real convergence of
Technologies in that box so that's about
biology it's about chemistry it's about
engineering microfluidics all sorts of
Science and Engineering Technologies
gone into that and I think the other
thing to recognize is that when we talk
about science this actually we also need
the Arts the humanities design we need
the whole package and that's really
important I think
so the question that Springs is my mind
is so what's what's I think what's
acknowledged is we have a very powerful
r d engine you know the universities do
very well given we're not funding them
half as well literally half as well as
some other country I think Israel spends
10 of its uh uh um GDP on on Research
but then not necessarily turning into
those companies that are really driving
the economy forward what what needs to
happen to bridge that Gap but a
municipal is actually a very interesting
example if I may because Israel the r d
expenditure is almost all in industry
and of course it's very driven by the
defense sector as well and there's a
really important point in that which is
the customer function really matters and
I think that's one of the challenges in
the UK which is it's all very well
making things but companies will only
come here if they can see a market as
well and so you know I've worked for
many years with and for the NHS the NHS
has got great regulation it's got things
like nice so it's admired as a regulator
but it's been quite slow historically at
incorporating and being a purchaser of
innovative products so just to expand
that what do you need to succeed you
need great people you need money and you
need markets and what Mark is talking
about is one particular Market we're
very proud of the healthcare Market but
you could expand that out to say the
public sector more broadly you know we
spent a lot of money on defense and
Welfare and we have not seen the state
kind of take the role that we've seen in
many other countries the us as well
um as a driver as a as a purchaser a
first effort
um so that's a problem then on people
you know the good news is we have
probably over the last 10 years of of
our burgeoning technology ecosystem you
know developed a mass of some 50 60 70
000 mid level uh people who can really
kind of bring the experience of
fast-growing companies to to that next
generation of firms but it's not enough
and though we have a very generous
immigration system the question is the
extent to which lots of other things
that are going on
um are whether that's making the UK
sufficiently attractive to people it's
it's all fine and well if you as a
researcher can come to this country but
if you're slightly worried whether your
husband
um is going to be able to get a job or
get the right Visa um it may mean that
you'll decide to go somewhere else and
then finally on funding you're quite
right to say that we have a great track
record of of supporting early stage
companies you're making that point and
that we haven't quite been there to
support the latest stage and people tend
to go overseas the US in particular for
that kind of funding Gap but what we're
seeing recently is even early stage
funding has taken a downward turn right
uh so we we mustn't be resting on our
Laurels even for early stage funding
so also in the comments Jeremy Hunt uh
described us as being the world or he
wanted to see us because the world's
next Silicon Valley I mean possibly not
the best analogy to draw given what
we're seeing going on in Silicon Valley
at the moment with Twitter's woes and
meta having to lay off 13 000 people but
I think we get his idea Zoe that's a is
that a cultural question and what do you
see as a business that has managed to
grow successfully in the UK Science and
Technology business what do you say
about the culture it's such an important
point so we have grown we are now a
thousand people we sell in 120 markets
we ipo'd last year in London and we saw
that as sort of Foothills of where we're
going but all the way through we have
faced not only our detractors but
actually our friends as well in many
cases telling us what we can't do and we
keep a list so we've been told we can't
make nanopore sequencing work we can't
make it good we can't manufacture it we
can't sell it especially not in the US
we've been told that we can't raise
money especially not in the US and we
were told that we can't IPO certainly
not in the UK and that we are too small
to be a collaborative partner to
Partners like the NHS now all of those
things are things that we have done but
we've done so often in spite of the help
that we've got so there is a really
cultural expectation we would like to
see a culture the UK where all of those
Ambitions are recognized as completely
normal and we've been very transparent
with all of our stakeholders whether
they are investors or employees or
customers about these long-term
Ambitions but we would like to see more
people just feeling inspired and really
gung-ho about what they want to achieve
so with a cup half full I mean look at
so nanopore is a great example Oxford
nanopore but look at deepmind that is
quite extraordinary you know that is
undoubtedly one of the most Cutting Edge
I'm proud to say they are the Deep owner
represented uh here later today so
because they are doing extraordinary
things we are near a so-called silicon
roundabout here we've got a very strong
satellite industry so I mean there are
areas where we are extraordinarily
strong but I mean I would say both in
the case of Oxford nanopore and Deep
Mind the founders have had a very strong
Vision that they want to stay in the UK
and there will have been a plenty of
voices telling them this is uh that he
should go overboard abroad
it's now part of Google but nevertheless
they are very firmly based at King's
cross next to the Francis Crick
Institute we have uh it raises another
question I think which is the importance
of clusters yeah you know Innovative
companies like to work near other
Innovative companies
and that's really important and with and
we're seeing that around King's cross
we're seeing that to some extent in East
London we're seeing it in other parts of
the country there's a Compound
Semiconductor
to follow up on your important point
about trying to distribute some of this
idea and this knowledge economy across
the UK rather than have it centered
around obstin Cambridge but before we do
just on that cultural question you work
in money you're a venture capitalist I
mean do we have the right attitude in
the UK look I think we have to be
careful not to think that there's only
one way of being a great entrepreneur
and it's uh you know the sort of Elon
Musk way and we all have to be like him
and look like him and say the things
that he does I'm not even sure that's
working particularly well for him but um
so we have to be careful we don't kind
of create a stereotype entrepreneurs
great Founders come in all shapes and
sizes as to scientists and researchers
but I think it is true to say that we
can be a bit and I say this with a with
the accent of a of a of a new Brit
um you know we can be a bit sort of um
self-contained in our in our in our
expression you know oh are you really
sure you're going to do that so we we
definitely need a little bit of a boost
and I do think government plays an
enormously important role in kind of
setting that high bar support those who
want to go far you know casting a light
on those who are who are struggling but
have that big vision and achievement
even at the risk that some of them
aren't going to succeed to the extent
that we hope for
you have to then wrap that cultural
Point down to the sort of realities of
well hang on where are you going to get
the money from where are you going to
get the people from what are you going
to do if you want to list at the very
end and if it's very difficult to list
in the UK or at least not as attractive
as elsewhere then culture is only going
to get you so far at the end of the day
there's got to be some some destination
you're aiming for
if we are trying to sort of drive a new
Industrial Revolution here as it's often
described and
how do we make that more Equitable
across the UK I mean the the government
previous governments as well have looked
at clusters at catapults at places where
we can accelerate and provide
opportunities for companies are those
working could we do it better
I mean the answer is if you look
okay there are areas of great strength
distributed widely across the country
you look across Southern Scotland
there's incredible Quantum Technologies
photonics Technologies yeah Quantum
Quantum Computing and yeah and satellite
industry as well you look in the
Midlands there's the Warwick there's
Advanced manufacturing center there are
real areas of strength um uh renewable
energy Northeast for example so when you
draw the map you do actually see why
they distribute strengths I think the
mistake is to think that you can
suddenly dump as it were a
nanotechnology Institute in any part of
the country what you have to do is build
on strengths and we've got great
universities very widely distributed
they all have enormous areas of strength
and the best universities have areas of
weakness as well so I think the trick is
not as it were just to try and create
something out of the blue because that's
very difficult but to work out where the
areas of strengths are and build up you
know Manchester a great University lots
of strengths it's where
um
I think carbon graphene wouldn't come
out you're right
just examples like that we just have to
build on them wherever they are now
there's it's interesting you mentioned
graphic because as far as my reporting
on this particular area went to film
with a graphene based company they're
trying to use graphene to make
microchips effectively to try and
replace uh the existing semiconductors
with graphene as the conductor
potential makes them a thousand times
more energy efficient potentially a
thousand times more powerful yet the
owner of that company saying I might
have to leave the UK because I've got
nowhere to expand the supply chain isn't
there and there are challenges facing
the growth he's well funded he's got
good money he's got contracts it's can
he grow his business in the UK as his
concern
look um I'll come back to you but just
to pick up on Mark's point which is um
there's a tendency to say what you need
here are clusters and then to approach
that in a very sort of artificial way
but what is really at the heart of a
cluster why does the cluster work
because it's a network it's a network of
people who have some level of
commonality or insight into what each
other are doing and so forth and if you
look at almost anything that's been
successful in this country or anywhere
else over a long period two things tend
to emerge right very strong networks of
stakeholders who manage to work together
across various different organizational
divides and then kind of long-term
commitment to whatever it is that
they're trying to achieve and I think in
this country we can do better on both on
the first we can do better at ensuring
that the right people are connected
across the country if you look at the
way that we support most Innovation we
do it through r d tax credits and r d
tax credits um are both an incredibly
effective means but also quite an
obscure one you don't really know who's
been given an r d tax credit you might
want to collaborate with them can't
quite find that out so there are other
things you can do in order to make it
easier for people the network within or
across geographical clusters and then
there's this long-terminism which we
haven't touched upon the commander of
the 82nd Airborne a very famous U.S uh
military unit once told me that the most
important thing for anything he did was
stick-to-itiveness
intuitiveness and I like that and I
think we need to stick to it of this in
this country if we want to achieve
things right so I want to ask you what
allowed nanopore to grow to a large
company before I do I just wanted to
remind everyone in the audience if you
have questions the QR code on your cards
uh and those of us those of you
following the live stream questions via
Twitter we're hoping it keeps operating
throughout the day but yeah so just
coming back to you
um
you your nanoport managed to grow
how important was the association with
Oxford did you benefit from that
location and did that money come
exclusive from the UK I mean help me
understand the story
well we're headquartered in the UK but
we have a very International Outlook and
actually all of our shareholders are
from from the UK but from Asia from
North America from all over the world
and I think we shouldn't confuse UK
companies selling to UK audience and
having UK investors with companies that
make their home in the UK
um so I think that's one important thing
and then something you said has
stimulated me to think about the power
of community and tearing down barriers
to Innovation so one of our critical
points was when we first released our
product and you've gone around there
somewhere so it's still here so we've
made it I'm still going around okay
sorry so we made a choice we had an
Electronics platform we could have made
a million pound box which is what all
the other people in our sector do and
sold it to the five most important
geneticists in the world and said right
let's do this thing but we didn't we
chose to make a very small accessible
device easy to make easy to ship to
customers in FedEx and we said we want
to make it as accessible as possible see
what you can do with it so we are a
platform but we are just the start of
the Innovation pathway and we have
people in London at geisens and Thomas's
developing amazing workflows on
respiratory metagenomics so basically by
the end of the ward round understanding
what pathogens you have present in a
long sample but you have people in
Sierra Leone doing agricultural work
using genomics so for us we're just the
start of that Innovation pathway and we
cannot do it without not only UK but
Global collaborations and we really do
feel privileged to be part of the
solution with the people who are
developing new uses for our technology
and that's what helps us grow we
co-create as much as possible I think
that brings us squarely on to an
important question in all of this we've
just gone through a bit of an upheaval
when it comes to our relationship with
the rest of the world
um in terms of science funding a lot of
that used to come through the Horizon
program you don't know that that's the
European Union's big Grant scheme that
Britain used to benefit from quite
disproportionately as a as a function of
the amount of money we put in that money
is obviously guaranteed to be uh made up
for by the government but there's a lot
of research relationships as I
understand it there have been damaged by
that we've also got questions about the
movement of people we used to obviously
work quite freely with scientists and
Engineers across Europe uh that's taken
a bit of a hit and I'm also hearing the
trade deals that we were looking to sort
of Step In
there's a few questions around them I
don't want to mention the b word but for
exit what's the impact been on doing
science in the UK but also on our
prospects for continuing to thrive in a
global economy
well I mean if I can start with people
because
one of the things about Oxford is it
trains educates brilliant people if you
look around Cambridge where there's a
very big cluster yeah most of that
cluster isn't actually spin-outs from
the University it's people from the
University and those people have come
from all over the world with a
substantial number who've come from
Europe because there were all the
schemes that enabled people to move
around so the erasma scheme for example
that enabled UK students to go to Europe
and vice versa so people really matter
and I think that that's one of the
reasons that our University sector our
higher education or further education
sector is so important and it's not only
the the the the the the the primary
research innovators it's all the
technical stuff that support the
incredibly sophisticated infrastructure
and you know the evidence is that there
is less Mobility uh to and from Europe
the rest of Europe to the UK
um this really matters ultimately I mean
we have got to part of being a we're
we're in a global market that's the
point the best researchers innovators
will go anywhere in the world and
there's pretty sophisticated and
expensive Market actually so you know
we've got to make sure that we remain an
attractive place for people to come and
work and of course that housing costs
salaries education all of that matters
um and I think that you know the UK has
got to work out its place in the world
but make sure as part of it that we are
really open to talent and there are 10
visas but you at the end of the day it's
a market and we'll see what people do oh
are we less attractive now though I mean
I I think it probably undoubtedly the
case that it has become harder to come
from Europe to the UK but at the same
time a successive governments have have
created an immigration system targeting
you know talented people entrepreneurs
that is probably one of the most um
liberal of anywhere else certainly
compared to our competitors and so we
are also attracting and continue to
attract great talent more globally and
Mark's of course entirely right you
can't rest on that alone and we've got
to tell a story and that story has to do
with lots more than the job that you can
get here but I I'm I'm enormously
optimistic because this is still a great
place to come and build and create a
business we have some great cities some
great universities but people also come
for all sorts of other reasons you know
great football and good culture and you
must forget these people don't just look
for
um the the company they want to work at
right they look at a much bigger picture
so we have every reason to believe that
we can tell a great story I think the
interesting question you haven't touched
on yet is you know the chancellor said
we're in a recession you know what's
that going to to do a lot of the things
that we've talked about has been about
spending money
um well not just by the state but also
by others what happens when a recession
begins cutting budgets and they're sort
of two ways of thinking about that you
can either be worried or you can look at
you know past recessions where almost
every recession has seen the emergence
of some really fantastic companies and
there may be less funding for everything
but that may also mean that there's more
funding for the really exciting more
serious bets and a lot of the sort of
more frivolous things that have been
funded over the years getting a pizza to
you faster or a different colored
t-shirt you know that you can buy
through Tick Tock may get less funding
and probably a good thing too yeah yeah
do you want to uh any I mean any direct
impacts on your business is this
something you're all concerned about or
that question about recession well I
think you guys have covered really all
those Salient points I think the only
thing I could possibly add is the joy
among the uh the tech bio sector when
Twitter and meta started announcing that
they were letting their machine learning
people go gosh I mean I've never seen so
many CEO LinkedIn posts saying come and
work for a place where instead of
checking out a pizza the point that you
were making earlier your machine
learning skills can be put to big data
sets around genomics or around Imaging
or anything else where your your day job
can be really making a difference
um so I think that's a redistribution of
talent that we're actually very excited
about in our sector but I mean so I
think the challenge is just for the uh
politicians to make it absolutely clear
that the UK is a place that people can
come and live work and play if they're
going to be recruited to the very best
companies
personally which is an issue of income
tax but also corporately which is um
which is why it's really pleasing to see
the government hang on to some of the
early stage uh tax incentives that the
previous government introduced we've got
to make it easy for people to put money
into those early stage businesses
it's good you brought us back to the
government because I had another
question about this
um
obviously Jeremy Hunt sounded like many
other chances before him saying I want
to put a high-tech sector or you know
Aerospace or biotechnology at the center
of the UK economy every government wants
to be bullied yet hardly any politicians
are scientists I think I saw a statistic
and I may be getting this wrong I think
it was something less than 15 of cabinet
level politicians have a science degree
compared to about 46 of graduates across
the UK uh on average and that if the
politicians don't get science and the
Civil Service doesn't really get it we
need more talent in politics but what do
you say to that well I mean the short
answer is you can't blame the people who
stand for politics you can only blame
the people that don't stand and I think
one of the real challenges for
scientists engineers technologists is
that you go to university and it's
almost treated as a vocational education
and the idea that you might go into sort
of politics or some kind of public
service is not part of it and so I think
it does go back to education as I say
the only way you'll fix the problem in
politics is to get more scientists
engineers Etc to stand for election if
they won't
um what can you do about it so as I say
it's very hard to blame the existing
politicians they've they've they've
stood but I do think it's a problem that
if you like the if you look at the
future science engineering technology
the Arts design are so intrinsic to it
that we have to make sure that those
people contribute to all walks of life
and so I think it's an educational issue
as much as anything you did your time in
number 10 what was that were you well I
was doing by saying I wonder whether
Mark paid you to sort of ask them
whether everybody else should be like
Mark Waldport um professor of science
but but uh
is that correct but more seriously more
seriously um
it is not just a question of who stands
for office it is also a question of who
engages in the public sphere because you
can influence an effect uh you know the
ship of State in lots of different ways
and the good news is that coming out of
the pandemic I think the whole nation
the whole world knows how important
science is
um you know Mike when you were the chief
scientist uh in government I doubt most
people knew who you were no disrespect
but simply you know you hadn't had the
platform to talk to people in the way
that your successor has had because he
had to go on uh you know TV all the time
in order to Mark had his moments I I
definitely recall but yeah I know I I
think we get what you're at the point is
simply that the people realize the
importance of Science and its role in
public policy making yeah and so you're
right to say we need more people
standing for office but I would argue
that we need something much broader
which is people who understand and know
these subjects need to spend more time
involved in shaping public policy I I
agree with that but again I think if you
look at the American University system
you'll find far more Masters courses
that are devoted to for example helping
scientists and researchers to become
involved in public policy so I think it
does come back to being an educational
Point although I agree with you and the
other point I'd make is actually there
are an enormous number of scientists
engineering Technologies working for
government but they tend to be working
in the back rooms that's the point I
mean the thing I discovered when I
started the government Chief Scientific
Advisor was the enormous number of
people who basically work fairly quietly
at keeping us safe and many of those
people are working in science
engineering and Technology can I just
make one point which is around diversity
which is um it is great that we have so
many people coming into the Sciences at
education but we need more and the truth
is we also need a much more diverse
cohort in all sorts of ways whether
that's ethnic Regional gender or whatnot
and I think we we see some great efforts
to make a difference but I think we we
need to up our gate but if I can comment
on that because one of the things I do
is I chair the Kennedy Memorial trust
which was set up to as Memorial to JFK
after he was assassinated we send about
10 people to have an MIT each year
typically to do the sort of Masters in
public policy public administration the
diversity of that group is now
extraordinary and so the access schemes
to universities it's beginning to work
but you're right I mean this has got to
change but I think it is beginning to
great news I think what we're talking
about is sorry sorry I didn't mean to
interact you I was going to say we're
talking about Talent here
um
could we nurture that Talent better in
the UK I believe compared to some of our
International uh equivalents we do quite
well at training scientists and
engineers in the UK
could we train them better could we
train different types of scientists and
engineers and I think Zoe I'd probably
introduce you in terms of who you're
recruiting where those smart brains are
coming from the type of people you need
and where they're coming from and
whether they're equipped to enter
companies like yours
and we see an enormous shortage of of
stem trained undergraduates but to your
point it's a real lack of diversity our
engineering team is desperate to hire
people with more sort of the team
themselves say look we are mainly you
know fantastic white men we want more
diversity of thought we want more
creativity in our team and actually what
we're starting to do now is try to take
our technology into the school into high
schools into undergraduates into medical
schools and try and bring that sort of
inspiration about science because
talking about sequencing you're not just
talking about biology or talking about
experimental design you'll talk about
engineering you'll talk about data
analysis or talking about communication
you're talking about policy ethics there
are so many ways to bring these skills
earlier so that you are more people
feeling more included by the science
journey through education I completely
agree with you Mark we can get more
people more educated get more kinds of
creativity into that Innovation Journey
if I could just add to that and it goes
a bit to the point I think Mark you were
making earlier which is so much
Innovation is happening on the cusps of
different discipline and we have I think
in the University sector been quite good
at bringing various different
disciplines together we could probably
be better but I think there's a there's
a sort of another element is are we good
enough at allowing scientists to spend a
little bit of time in the pockets of
policy makers and corporates and so on
as part of their scientific education
and in my experience the answer is no
people tend to stay in their silos and
if they collaborate they might do so
with another University department but
they're unlikely to do so with the
corporate or with a government body and
that I think to me is something we ought
to be thinking a bit about I agree with
that completely Daniel I I think that
the financial incentives uh in the
University sector don't make it easy for
people to move around in that way and I
agree with you I think I think it's
another issue in it it's not only Early
Education it's actually people in
postdocs many of whom will not go on to
be research leaders in universities
there isn't I think enough emphasis on
Skilling them for all the the different
opportunities there are and you know
frankly if you are a scientist and you
are inquisitive you know how to ask
experiments you understand statistics
and you you have to be a good
communicator those are the skills for
almost every Walk of Life
we're going to go some questions in just
a minute but before we do I'm going to
throw a curveball at all of you that the
question we're posing oh it's not on the
screen anymore but
the name of this whole uh event is who
owns the future and I thought I'd put
that to it just a quick thought if you
could certainly perhaps starting with
you we've got such a firm opinion on
this so you have challenges across the
world that genomics can answer it's
health challenges it's environmental
challenges food security challenges 30
of the food that is produced goes to
waste because of pathogens and pests in
the world extraordinary and those
problems are experienced by the people
who are not where the Innovation is
happening so we want to make our
technology we want to tear down those
barriers so the people who have the
challenges are the people who are
creating the solutions for those
problems so I guess our answer to that
was we think the future belongs to the
people with the problems to solve so
that they can drive the solving of those
problems thank you I'd give a slightly
different answer which is that I think
it's the youngest people in the room who
own the future and we all in the future
for future Generations and I think
that's one of the big challenges that
we're seeing the challenge at the cop
meeting in Cairo at the moment uh we own
the future of our own species on the
planet and also for the others with
which we share the planet
um and so I think it's why I'm afraid I
keep coming back to the fact that we're
not going to be able to cope that we've
just crossed that gather the eight
billion humans on the planet banjo we're
heading probably 10 billion something
like that you look at the waste we're
producing invisible waste in terms of
carbon emissions visible in terms of the
sort of muck that's contaminating rivers
and the seas around the world uh if we
don't if it is us that owns it and it's
it's the young people who are going to
have the most
um impact
um and and if we care about future
generations and I think that's one of
the challenges that research shows we
care about our children we care about
our grandchildren we can imagine them if
you ask people how much they care about
their grandchildren's grandchildren not
enough yeah so it's our role to skill
those future generations to tackle those
challenges I I would say this because
I'm the Science and Technology editor
but I think it sounds a technology
there's probably the answer to many of
those questions social sciences matter
too and the social sciences that's not
that's everybody and those designers and
the artists too Daniel well I just at
the risk of giving uh the same answer
with slight variation I mean you own the
future in the sense that it has never
been easier than today to define a
problem and build Solutions attract
people to help you money to support you
and and access the architecture you need
to build something whether that's a
software architecture or or more
physical architecture and then access
markets immediately Beyond you or offer
their field it has never been easier
never been easier so the future belongs
to you but the great news is that you
have the the levers at your disposal to
do something about it in a way no
previous generation had as easily
fantastic thanks very much indeed right
so we promised there would be questions
that we're going to go to them right now
we have some minutes for that I've got
one here in the audience
uh
hero uh
uh Hiro are you out there uh there's
your hand fantastic could you just pause
a moment for the microphone to come
towards you and I believe it's got
something to do with brexit which is
perhaps predictable please could you
stand up Sir so uh we can see you and
there's a microphone above your head so
you should we should be able to hear
your question
um
yeah
um
you know we've got greater opportunities
[Music]
thanks very much for that here so if you
didn't make that out there's a question
about brexit has it has it hinder this
or are there post brexit opportunities I
mean certainly the chance to spoke about
that maybe he had to but are there are
there some opportunities that we can
leverage now that we've left the EU
anyone have a crack well speaking of
someone who argued for our stay inside
the EU I'm going to take the position
then I think we can we can focus too
much on the negative aspects here large
parts of what we do particularly in the
technology sector as opposed to the
science sector you know was not
regulated inside the EU single Market
anyway and so a lot of people who are
selling various
um uh cloud-based services in the in the
EU and 2D rather you know have not been
affected it would of course be
um Preposterous to argue that it has had
no impact the ob-r has been pretty clear
that there has been an economic impact
and as a as a result of that that will
influence lots of sectors including ours
but I think that we can be
um too negative about
um the impact and I I see in lots of
sectors that it hasn't been as
disadvantageous as I think a lot of
people feared indeed that I feared
myself so I'm going to be more
optimistic about the situation we find
ourselves in okay I mean I think it's
too early to know to be honest I mean
one of the big challenges is that the UK
has made it clear uh that it wants to
participate in Horizon Europe but
Horizon Europe has actually been held
hostage in Europe to the solution of the
Northern Ireland protocol
um so there's a lot of uncertainty still
I think the other thing is that a lot
has been made about the opportunity of
regulatory Freedom yes and that is true
but
um that regulation and science is often
abused to create trade barriers and so
there's no use regulating something
completely different to the rest of the
world if the rest of the world then says
it went by the product
and I think that's one of the challenges
actually which is the amount of
regulatory Divergence may be limited by
the need to actually sell one's product
into other markets
right I mean it's interesting one of the
the brexit freedom cybers of media aware
of was biotechnology so Gene editing of
course well that's a good example that
was knee regulation that was holding uh
UK Innovation back but as soon as those
products now start to emerge the EU is
very rapidly revising its regulations
because I think they've recognized maybe
the Market's there but actually the
advantage may have slightly vanished but
possibly gave us a bit of a head start
yeah
sorry any thoughts on that I mean I
think it's it's a small world now kovid
showed us that we can all collaborate
with people online on zoom and they can
have a lab in Oxford collaborating with
a lab in Singapore in real time on Zoom
I think you know Europe is incredibly
important to us as a country but it's
not the only region with which we can
collaborate and make new innovation and
and sell products as well so
it's something we just work through put
our tin hats on and make sure we make
the best of the situation fantastic so
I'm going to take a question from
Twitter now this is for from Sir
mattington on Twitter the question is
why does the UK not expand our domestic
ship industry fabrication plants for
example Taiwan leads the way at the
moment and surely it would create jobs
is there a barrier that prevents us from
doing this and we've talked about
Silicon Valley so not chips not for me
but it's an example I think though of a
manufacturing infrastructure of a
history of a certain uh industry
it was in the news recently because the
government decided to protect one of our
few remaining chip manufacturing plants
um yeah is that the sort of thing we
need to be concentrating on
um okay well we are a world leader in
making compound semiconductors which
amongst the most sophisticated and that
that's really all here Mark sorry I can
just detect can you hear mark saying in
the audience you can't carry on sorry to
interrupt so we do have a a a a a a chip
industry and it's a very high-end one I
think the problem is that the cost of a
chip factory is absolutely massive and
so the cost of capital for getting
started here is huge
um I mean the Americans realize there's
an issue because of the great dependency
on Taiwan the chip manufacturer and that
is a one of you know one of the things I
think Ukraine war has made people
suddenly aware of is the huge grow
Global interdependency on uh resources
and governments probably haven't paid
enough attention I mean worldwide to the
security of suppliers and products that
they take for granted you know raw
minerals all the books read way through
but I mean it is a at some level it's a
it's quite a complicated question which
is who is going to provide the
investment to make AK chip factory which
we're talking many billions and perhaps
comes back to your point from earlier
about let's concentrate on our strengths
rather than look for areas in which we
we can't lead in everything on the
country above our way sorry I mean I was
simply going to add um that what we're
seeing now to Mark's point with
governments waking up to the challenge
of the security of Supply
um a really interesting move so in the
US we have the chips act which has
basically stopped dead the Chinese Chips
industry immediately the extent to which
that's actually going to encourage
discourage War over the Taiwan Straits
we don't know but I think it speaks to a
point of
um the need for government to be you
know to have a large long-term coherent
you know plan yes the uh the recent
business secretary is this decision over
over the manufacturing side in Wales you
know is an element but is it part of a
larger coherent strategy of where we
want to play in the chip supply chain I
I'm not so sure I know the answer to
that and so I think if if anything it
isn't just a question where do you want
to play sexually but also where in the
supply chain do you want to play where
does the money come from and what else
are you willing to do you know in order
to attract people or stop other people
hiring you know britons to go overseas
in the way that the Americans have it's
got to come together in a little bit of
a of a piece that involves many
stakeholders we're not quite there and
and of course we're very good at chip
design as well so oh it's uh you we've
got to you know everyone who's got a
phone so we don't necessarily have to
have the manufacturing to benefit from
that party I think that brought a
question is one of resilience yeah in a
world where people had taken it for
granted you could just buy stuff off the
shelves yeah and then when that um huge
tanker got stuck in this year's Canal we
were extraordinarily lucky that there
wasn't a disaster so that had been stuck
there for longer we'd have found all
sorts of Supply problems and I think the
important point to remember on that is
what is the trade-off we're willing to
accept do we want to pay more for things
will we allow things not to be so
instantaneous in order to be more secure
and I don't think we've quite had that
to be yeah great I'm just we've got time
for one more question in the audience
Dino are you out there Dino in the
background there you are oh I love the
shirt fantastic bringing a Hawaiian vibe
to hoxton
um could you stand up so it just it
might help with the audio yes
about education but going back to the
beginning so bizario I was actually
recording a podcast yesterday about
early junior high school education we
talked about joining the dots and arts
and craft and all those sorts of things
have we got an education system fit for
the future
if not what would be your curriculum
what would you add
foreign
the problem with education is that
everyone has strong views because
everyone's either been to school or
knows someone who has been
um and the challenge is that the
education is a super tanker it's quite
difficult to steer and so everyone
always wants to change the curriculum
um I mean I I just think the important
thing is that people get a diversity of
Education I think one of the challenges
for the UK system is that we're one of
the most specialized at an early age
and so I personally I think it's
important that everyone does English and
maths until they leave school at
whatever age
um I think Arts education is incredibly
important
um and it's clearly important that you
know numerous is probably the most
important thing of all in some ways
because you close more doors in terms of
job opportunity if you are innumerate
than almost anything else and the
challenge is to get that throughout
education I think
entrepreneurialism not because I think
everybody's going to be a Founder but
because I think it teaches agency it
tells you you don't just have to go and
do what everybody else did before you
what your parents did what your friends
did you have the power to shape things
and create things and we're very bad at
teaching entrepreneurialism we're very
bad at bringing Founders and
entrepreneurs into schools just to tell
the kids what we're about we're very bad
at saying hey why don't you have a go if
you had to create a business you know
outside the Talk Shop what would you do
um which is very bad at doing that and
and as I say it's not because I think
everybody's going to be an entrepreneur
but it teaches agency and if you want to
come back to who owns the future and if
it's about you owning the future that's
about agency let's teach the kids you
know you need to know all these things
but you have the power the tools
to get there and solve some of these
problems fantastic
so it's such important points and
obviously there is a lot of innovation
happening in education and there is now
a trend away from calling it education
and towards Corner learning because it's
not just about the school curricula it's
about what happens on a Saturday because
you're into entrepreneur camp or it's
what happens after you've left school
and there are so many ways to Art skill
and learn more and sort of expand your
horizons now that it's a really really
exciting place to be in education thank
you very much all of you for helping us
explore that there's so much more to get
into so I have to cut us off there uh
thank you very much again for exploring
the question of whether Britain is isn't
or can be a science superpower um Sarah
Jane back to you
Tom thank you so much and thank you to
Our Guest panel as well a fascinating
discussion to kick us off today here at
Big Ideas live talking about the very
best and the future of British
Innovation a lot of which is on display
here with us in London today take a look
at this the UK atomic energy Authority
are here with us and this
is their four-legged friend it's spot
the dog
not the spot the dog we're used to but
this is the future at the UK's atomic
energy Authority
says that this four-legged robot can go
where humans cannot and we're going to
take spot for a little walk
um it's created a lot of interest with
our audience here in the room and we're
going to bring spot to you at home
joining me sunshi Chen from the UK aea
and sunshi talk to me about spot I mean
he's drawn a lot of attention he can
walk up the stairs and talk to me about
the technology behind him
we actually use spot for inspection
purposes like you said we use spot to go
places where people can't so places that
are potentially hazardous for humans
they might have high radiation they
might have latent heat and spot has
cameras on the front infrared cameras
just normal visual cameras to give us uh
you know an overview of these of of
these environments so that we know
what's going on and it's technology like
this that we can apply to Fusion Energy
yes so talk to me about Fusion Energy
because this is the the friendly face
this is the cute fun bit that draws
people in but the energy that goes into
this technology is the serious business
exactly so in a in a sentence it's a sun
in a bottle what we're trying to do is
recreate the process that the sun uses
Fusion to create energy here on Earth
um we call these things you know Fusion
machines
um and we want to we want to make them
to basically create you know sustainable
low carbon and secure energy these
things this type of energy technology G
is a very efficient very efficient
technology very secure technology and
very safe and it's you know going to be
part of the energy mix in the latter
half of the century to provide energy
security for everybody Yeah you
mentioned all the white right words
they're clean renewable and security
energy we've been talking about so much
about that so far this year just a final
question from Youth and chief I can a
person or one I mean obviously how did
how did you get into Tech and science
because you know we've got younger
members of the audience here today and
are watching on at home or on the Move
wherever they are today and this could
be the hook that gets them into Science
and Tech what was your journey into this
field so I always like science even as a
small kid and then I went into
University and I did do a
nuclear-specific degree but that's not
necessary to get into this kind of
technology or into science at all if you
have an interest in science that's
enough and then I joined on to The
Graduate scheme here at the UK aea which
is brilliant you know we really value
trying to bring up our younger Engineers
which is vital to a rapidly growing and
a rapidly changing industry that is
Fusion okay essentially really good to
talk to you thank you so much and thank
you to spot as well and spot is just
going to be over there at the UK aea
stand and he walks he does downward dog
he does all sorts um we'll let him have
a little rest uh well coming up on the
future stage uh which is just through
there for those of you in the audience
with us today uh we'll be uh
technological advances in sports Sky
News is uh Sports press wanted Jackie
Bell trout is with us today the World
Cup of course starts this weekend and
it's the first time that VAR is going to
be used at the tournament Hawkeye are
here to talk us through the advances of
tech in sport and what it means
particularly for assistant referees our
assistant referee is going to be part of
football uh in the future we'll be
hearing from Hawkeye uh the company
behind VAR and of course from our Sports
correspondent who is out in Doha for the
start of that tournament and then in a
few minutes time right here on the
festival stage these seats are going to
be um taken by my panel of guests I'm
talking about privacy and data joining
me I have Lee Nichol uh the footballer
from Crystal Palace now her personal
data was hacked and leaked online and
joining me to talk about data we put so
much out there don't don't we how can we
keep it safe and how can companies that
use our data keep it safe and what are
authorities doing about it the
information a commissioner the
information commissioner John Edwards
will be here to take part in that
discussion so for those here in the
audience it's time for them to go and
have a little look around at the
different Innovations on display and for
those of you watching wherever you are
we'll see you in a couple of minutes
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the next session is on the main Festival
stage and is about to start
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
hello welcome back to Big Ideas live
live from London today for a special
event here on Sky News welcome to
everybody uh watching here live in the
room and to everyone watching at home or
wherever you are today on whatever
device you're joining us on we're going
to talk now about data and privacy we
live in an age where data is quite
simply a valuable resource particularly
our own individual personal data and
this is only going to increase with the
advance of new technologies and
Innovations so the big question in this
area is how do we keep our personal
information safe and what are those
companies and organizations using our
data doing to keep it safe plus there
are authorities as well to monitor this
activity uh how are they keeping us safe
we hand out so much personal information
and put it out there on the internet
don't we so it is a pertinent question
now and of course for future Generations
because people are getting online
younger
quite frankly than we ever did um so to
talk about this I'm joined by the
information commissioner John Edwards
and by Crystal Palace footballer Lee
Nichol welcome to you both thank you so
much for coming down to our big event
here today
um there's so much going on there's so
many important issues in this field but
this is a particularly pressing one it
feels uh with so many young people
getting online now um
Lee I want to talk to you first about
your experience this has very personal
resonance with you because you were the
victim of intimate image abuse talk to
us about what happened
yes on 2019 I received the link on
Instagram that led to me opening and it
was a fail worth seven or eight videos
of me when I was 18 when I made no
looking back the worst decision of my
life to record myself in a very private
moment with another individual and
I found out about that when I was 23 so
the videos were five years old that I
completely forgot about I didn't know
they existed anymore in that moment when
I clicked on that link my life looked
like him crashing down and I've never
experienced pain shock
go and if and like it before no one can
ever prepare you for that moment
um and that moment I lost the most
expensive thing in my world and that was
my privacy and there was nothing that I
could have done about it because it got
so much attention it went viral
worldwide
it was trending on websites that you
should never be trending on and unless
you want to
um it came with a lot of social media
abuse and that's all fell out there to a
dignity if anyone wants to unfortunately
find it they'll find it and
I think initially for the first six
months for me it was about surviving
um keeping myself here and and present
and breathing it wasn't really about
anything else in life and
the most difficult moment within it all
was having to tell my family because
it's not just me that went through it
was my family my loved ones and
so this day that's the thing that I
struggle with most because it wasn't
just a damage done to me it was the
Damage Done around me and my family my
friends worrying that I wouldn't survive
it because many people don't survive
this thing yeah
he went through personal trauma that you
will have to deal with for the rest of
your life you've been very honest about
this and you know you've come out of the
worst of it you feel but as you've been
very honest and saying it's something
that you and your loved ones have to
live with but since this happened to you
you've been on a learning curve because
as far as you know
these images these videos these these
personal uh that were on your personal
device you deleted them but your iCloud
was hacked and you know the learning
curve for you is that how that happened
because so many people here today am
watching us online or on TV you know
we're very naive in that respect we have
all these pictures on our phone and we
know they go somewhere up there for
storage but you and on a learning curve
as to how this could happen how easy it
is to happen yeah I think for the vast
majority of people that this kind of
crime happens to there's an individual
responsible someone you know someone
they know of but for me it's so hard for
me to get my head around that that email
address that I set up in 2008 when I was
at school is the email address that
ended up ruining my life about 14 years
later and you're never taught that
especially when I was at school starting
up my first MSN account or Facebook
account
I never fought for one minute that email
address years and years and years later
would be the cause of my trauma so
I didn't know that once you delete
things off your device it's still there
somewhere it's the digital footprint
yeah like now when I say it sounds
ridiculous it sounds like common sense
but honestly back then no one told me
that make sure that you then sign on to
your iCloud on a different device to
then remove it and I wasn't aware of two
Factor authentication at the time that
gives you that extra security to make
sure no one can get into your iCloud and
that was probably the main learning
curve
I had no idea that is that he was still
existed but the debts and I'm sure that
a lot of people listening today will be
like I've got a picture that I would
never want anyone in the world to see it
could be something like a bikini picture
it could be your passport photo it could
be absolutely and I could be an innocent
photo of your children you just don't
want the wider world to see it and for
me to think that it's there somewhere
yeah it still blows my mind now it's a
really daunting thought I think for most
people and I'm going to ask um John a
question in just a moment but you have
all got QR codes so if you do want to
send a question into this panel please
scan that QR code and send us and for
those watching us elsewhere uh go to
Twitter hashtag Big Ideas live 22.
John where do you come into all of this
because
the problems that Lee has faced is
something that that you get involved in
as information commissioner what is it
that you do to help people likely and
everyone here stay safe online
thanks Sarah Jane I I first I just want
to say how
um how much I admire Lee and her bravery
in telling her story because it's not
easy and I think one of the things we've
got to get past in society is victim
blaming and the shame that people feel
when they are the victims of these
malicious actors who are taking
advantage of security flaws to steal our
most intimate moments that's
reprehensible
so at the information commissioner's
office we administer laws that are
intended to protect Lee and everybody
else in the community and their personal
data the most the one that people will
most know of is called the UK gdpr it's
the general data protection act and it
says that platforms and organizations
that hold data have to keep it secure
and they can only use it for the
purposes for which it was obtained and
they have to be transparent about those
and things like that so we deal with
complaints
um the the matter the lead dealt with
that was a criminal matter that should
have been investigated by the police but
people have rights also to get data
deleted when a platform should no longer
be holding it so we are also committed
to
trying to make the online environment
safer by
um by enforcing these security standards
we're trying to provide education in the
same way that Lee's doing today by
telling her story
we're also working with industry to make
the online services safer for children
and that's a really big thing for us so
we've got a a law called the age
appropriate design code we call it the
kids code but it says if you're pointing
uh Digital Services towards children and
children are likely to access your
services you've got to design your
service with privacy in mind as a
default so switch off location tracking
disable messages from people who aren't
contact
um you know
make the the posts private by default so
it's stuff like that it's getting
organizations to think about how the
individuals could be harmed and to try
and avoid the kind of experience that
Lee's had yeah Lee I know you use the
bad experience you had for good use
because you talk to young people now
about the Perils of putting their
information online I mean every
everybody in this room will have put
their name address telephone number
email date of birth into a website
somewhere that's just how it works
what advice do you offer young people
because obviously that kind of data has
to be out there nowadays but when it
comes to their own very private data
pictures and who they talk to online
what message are you telling them
I think the obvious one for me would be
don't do it but I can say that because
I've made the mistake myself but I think
that's unrealistic it's 2022 so it's if
you are an individual and you're in a
relationship and you feel like this is a
big part of it it's about making sure
that you have got the correct things in
place to protect yourself and the free
main behaviors that I always speak to
and we at my company speak to other
people and clients and kids about is
being risk-averse being respectful and
being defensive and by those free
behaviors you won't often go wrong in
life because we can't control the
platforms and what they do in criminals
that are are looking to expose other
individuals but what what we can control
is control our own behavior and making
sure that we're not putting ourselves
too much at risk if you feel the need to
share an image for example take your
identity out of it if it's a really
crucial part to your relationship or
it's something you really really want to
do take your identity out of it because
then you're not dealing with public
humility and victim blaming and all of
those things so it's about being
defensive and not taking too many risks
in life and just always being a good
person for me John how prevalent is
hacking and the experience that Lee went
through because you know I've lost count
of the amount of times over the last
year I've had alerts saying that a
password I've used has been compromised
in a data leak and at one point it was
happening so often you know changing
passwords all the time just how easy is
it to hack and how exposed is our data
it's really hard to know how prevalent
hacking is but what we do know is that
the experience that Lee's had of a a
malicious third party
accessing a um an iCloud account those
are pretty those are relatively rare
most of the breaches occur by accident
and we see this every day businesses
failing to do the basics putting
everyone's email address in the CC field
rather than the BCC it's basic stuff
like that
um it's training staff to make sure that
if they get a suspicious email they
don't click on the links and this stuff
sounds so basic Sarah Jane but it's so
often neglected we find an organization
4.4 million pounds for failure to take
those basic steps which led to the
exposure of 113 000 employees sensitive
personal information
how much hard is your job going to get
because you know the Ico you're there to
protect people but you're also there to
promote data-led Innovation it's not all
bad you know the data can lead to to
great things as we're showcasing here
are Big Ideas live
so if collecting data is going to be a
more powerful tool just just tricky is
the protection element of it going to be
in the future well we're there really to
make sure that we can get as a society
and as individuals the benefits from the
wonderful Innovation and these tools
they're fantastic we all love our phones
we all love the online services but we
shouldn't have to compromise our privacy
for that yeah so I kind of reject the
language of trade-off can you have
Innovation or privacy we're entitled to
both so we're there to try and make sure
that businesses are enjoying the
benefits they're getting the Innovation
but they're doing it in a safe way that
respects our data in a way that
recognizes that it's not this Anonymous
data it's about a live person yeah uh
and that that person is entitled to
expect that their data is protected for
many people it will be an inconvenience
it will be having to change your
password having to call up your bank
having to do various different elements
like that but for you Lee it's as
serious as it gets you with a victim of
a crime so I'd be quite interested I
think a lot of people here would be as
well is how do you go about reporting
and dealing with a cyber crime because
if something happens to you in real life
there's a clear set of structures that
everyone in this room will know you go
to the police you go through the you
know the the legal system what was that
experience like for you is it clear-cut
do enough people know about what to do
if they're a victim of hacking for
example in your case now what all I can
speak about is my one experience and it
it wasn't an easy procedure it wasn't
straightforward there was no step one
two three four my initial reaction was
actually to call 999 that was I thought
it was the biggest emergency in the
world to me at that point but when
I did speak to the place unfortunately I
don't think they have the resources or
the training in place to really handle
such a sensitive topic it's quite it's
not new but it's happening more and more
and more in our place don't have the
resources or the training to be able to
manage it effectively it took way too
long for the process to really start and
I must say the place for me they were
they were great emotionally but in terms
of the physical support there's not much
now I've learned there's not not much
any of us can do other than just take
the punches as they come and just accept
that it's now out there there isn't much
support that murafories can offer once
it happens it's a we're reacting to it
um but that's why I'm doing what I'm
doing now to try and help unfortunately
future victims have a more clearer
step-by-step process that is people out
there that can help get it removed from
from yoga girls from Safaris
but one thing I would say is these
things take time it does not happen
overnight it does not happen immediately
and my expectations where my videos are
out there I want them taken down with a
click of a button I'm three years on and
I've got people that manage my Google
and my social media platforms every week
to get them taken down and that costs
people a lot of money and the general
public don't have the kind of money that
it takes yeah I I mean John you are all
about holding those organizations and
companies to account you mentioned some
of the common mistakes they made but you
also are about protecting the individual
particularly the vulnerable about
equipping them with how to operate
safely online what is the biggest
mistake people make when it comes to
their own personal data
that's a really hard question let me
flip it um
there is an obligation that uh all
organizations have which is called data
minimization and that means they should
be looking at what information they're
collecting about people and only
collecting the minimum amount they need
to provide that person with the service
I think if as individuals we thought
about data minimization and only giving
out what was really necessary
um that would be a help but I do think
it's also
um it's a mistake to load the blame on
the users of this technology it's a it's
a mistake to say Lee didn't have
two-factor authentication and therefore
she's to blame
we need to be holding these technology
companies to account to ensure that they
are really thinking about what harm
could come from uh Bad actors using
their Technologies and designing in
features to ensure that those harms are
prevented
who needs to do more do you think Lee I
mean we've touched on it there haven't
we is it the big platforms the big
companies a lot of the excuses that I'm
sure you're well aware of John people
will say you know it's too complicated
it's too expensive it's too time
consuming a lot may not admit it affects
their bottom line what more needs to be
done do you think
I think there's there's two things we're
looking at we're looking at on websites
that exist that shouldn't exist and I
think
there's a responsibility that web hosts
have to not allow these websites in
particular to exist because they're just
created to cause harm and to publicly
shame individuals for their personal
life so you've got certain websites out
there that no one knows who runs them no
one knows who owns them and then you've
got social media there is an ongoing
conversation and has been for a long
long time and there's a a certain
platform that is getting worse at the
moment and it's a platform for 13 year
olds but if you go on the platform and
you're scrolling you come across
pornography and it just appears and that
speaking from someone who's scrolling
and I appear on on that platform and I
can't get it taken down they said it's
it doesn't reach any
it's me it's yeah I don't want myself
and on your on your platform and I don't
think any 13 year old should be
scrolling on a social media platform and
and free accessible illegal pornography
or crime appears on their on their site
and we agree with that absolutely and
we're doing a lot of work actually at
the moment enforcing the children's code
looking at video sharing platforms
social media gaming where children and
people under 13 should be able to enjoy
those safely without coming across that
kind of content and so we're actually
out there investigating those platforms
and finding it and taking action okay
and I've got a couple of questions from
the audience Jenny uh Jenny submitted a
question Jenny they are Jenny's at the
front if you want to stand up the um
microphone will find you here he comes
you've got to be fast with that boom
um Jenny what was your question for our
panel
a question for John
um do you think the much delayed Online
safety bill will give you adequate
powers to help in cases like Lee
thank you
um thanks for the question because it's
it's a really important one the Online
safety bill has been working its way
through the law making process and it's
now going through Parliament
um it will provide remedies for people
who are the victims of a harmful content
uh online and that's really important it
won't provide me with powers that law is
going to be administered by ofcom
and it's quite interesting though
because
the the the the line between content and
data is so blurred at times
recently uh there was a Coroner's
hearing into the tragic death of a young
woman called Molly Russell and the
coroner uh heard evidence about some of
the very traumatic content that she was
presented with now under the Online
safety legislation
that that content and whether it should
have been there it will be something
that ofcom can consider under that law
whereas the kind of use of personal
information the data that drove the
algorithms that presented more and more
harmful material to that young woman
that's data protection so we'll be
working really closely with ofcom to
make sure that legislation does what
it's intended to do and keeps people
safe online
thank you
great question and we've got one come in
on Twitter from Glenn who's watching he
says is legislation falling behind
technology when it comes to data and
privacy is it falling behind yeah
it's always it's always a race uh I
think the great benefit of our law that
this gdpr and the other Associated laws
is that there's technology neutral Sarah
Jane so they're set at sort of high
level principles that gives them the
flexibility to adapt let me give you an
example we've recently had a look at um
some technology which is uh supposedly
able to test to tell what people's
emotional state is through Biometrics
and on the basis of that uh screen
people out from uh recruitments job ads
uh you know recruiting processes we've
looked at it we've got experts they say
it doesn't work it's nonsense so taking
that evidence we can say that that's
unlawful because it's disproportionate
it's not fair it's not delivering what
it's said on the box and it's making an
inappropriate use of of data and that's
brand new technology but the law is
capable of uh of still regulating that
okay they're connecting that race then
we'll say and just time for one final
question Lauren is in the audience
Lawrence do you want to stand up
Lauren stand up and show us where you
are out just at the front there perfect
and Lee you could answer this one Laura
what's your question
um so easy one was do 13 year olds
possess
ourselves
okay so do 13 year olds possess the
capacity to keep themselves online do
they because you mentioned that as an
age um age bracket for social media and
various platforms I think 13 year old
year olds can do that
I think it comes down to families and
what they're comfortable with and I
think it depends
how open families are with each other
because adults know a little bit more
Believe It or Not than 13 year old kids
and I know that sometimes they're 10
year olds assume that they know more
than that the adults but I think there
needs you need to be ready as a family
and you need to be willing to
communicate about online harms about
trolling about bullying
having the right Security on your if if
you can't put the rate Security on these
platforms to start with you're not ready
to be on social media if you can't have
your account on private message request
shut off hide your your phone name
because you're only 13 there's no need
to have your real name on these
platforms so no one should be able to
identify you so I think it comes down to
individual basis and depend on your
household but I do think it's still very
young to be making potentially big
decisions and posting things that could
come back to haunt you in 10 years time
whether it's slightly embarrassment
embarrassing silly comments that
unfortunately now we're seeing coming
back around and people being punished
for those yeah it's about being open And
discussing it as a family you talk to
your children about not talking to
strangers when they go out you know for
the day in town but not as many people
realize that you know online as well
there are dangers out there I know
you've got a second question but we
don't have time however do you want to
come and ask the panel when we come off
stage you can also don't belly okay
Lauren we'll do that for you
um John Edwards information commissioner
Lee Nichol Crystal Palace footballer
thank you so much for talking today in
particular for sharing your experience
thank you so much
um now we have so many Innovations on
offer here today for those of you here
in the audience please do explore them
you can probably hear the hubbub hi me
uh plenty of people are
um there is an innovation just around
the corner on the way to the in innovate
into the Futures stage that is tree
hugger uh now I've had a go rela
manthorpe our technology correspondent
said it is the best thing he has ever
experienced and he knows a thing or two
about tech basically you put a VR
headset on it and you immerse yourself
in the world of trees you could
literally go inside this giant tree
trunk and have a look it really is
extremely special so please take the
time to go in book your slot and have a
look
um in 10 minutes time we're going to be
back here on the festival stage and
another big question for you if you are
ready Friend or Foe we're going to be
talking about artificial intelligence
that's coming up in a few minutes time
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the next session is on the main Festival
stage and is about to start
thank you
all right
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
and the overarching question today is
who owns the future well could part of
that answer lie in artificial
intelligence it's brought us everything
from personalized medicine to facial
recognition drones self-driving cars for
Hollywood it's always a nightmare
scenario isn't it it's a tribe of out of
control robots or a rather over Amorous
operating system but what is the truth
just how advanced is the technology now
and more importantly can we trust it um
just a reminder to those of you who are
here in our wonderful audience if you
scan the QR code on your chairs you can
submit a question to our panel coming up
now or any panel throughout the day and
if you're watching uh at home or
wherever you are today head to Twitter
use the hashtag Big Ideas live 22 to
submit your questions and on our next
panel now is all about artificial
intelligence and the question can AI
replace your brain hosting this panel
our data and forensics correspondent Tom
Cheshire
thank you very much Sarah Jane
um yeah we're going to be talking about
machines that think we're going to be
looking at questions that have baffled
philosophers for thousands of years and
the nature of Consciousness and we're
going to solve that in about 45 minutes
flat I reckon so I've got an expert
panel to help me do that
um anal Seth who is the professor of
cognitive and computational Neuroscience
and the author of being you a new
science of communication Dr Catherine
Breslin a machine learning scientist and
founder of Kingfisher Labs Consulting
previously worked at Cambridge
University Toshiba research and on a
little thing called Amazon Alexa which
you might have heard of and finally Dr
Chris Bishop laboratory director at
Microsoft research Cambridge which I've
been a couple of times this is Treasure
Trove of very Advanced research and also
a member of the UK AI Council so I think
we're in very safe hands here thank you
all for joining us here uh just a
reminder again if you do want to submit
a question scan that QR code or use the
hashtag Big Ideas live 22 because we
really want to open up to the audience
and see what you guys think of it as
well
um so we'll start get things rolling
before we go looking into the future
which we will get to State of play right
now I think artificial intelligence it's
strange because it's a term that's been
around a long time but it also seems to
refer to something that hasn't quite
arrived yet but it's all around us we're
using it the whole time and I wonder
Catherine if you could start us with
that what does AI look like in the world
right now so I think it's a very good
point that AI is a really ill-defined
term and I don't think it has you know a
real concrete definition of what it is
and so the best I can come up with is
computers trying to sort of emulate some
sort of human intelligence and obviously
we're a very long way from and hopefully
we'll get to that question of how closer
are we to human intelligence but we're
on the path to computers that are
becoming more and more intelligent and I
think if we look at some of the ways
that technology is used right now in the
world we can see some real good examples
of artificial intelligence and how it's
used you mentioned Alexa obviously that
is a I think I think a very nice example
of how AI is working at the moment and
if you have Alexa or you've talked to
Siri or any of these other virtual
assistants you might have a sense of how
good the technology is you know it can
listen to you it can understand certain
things it does a lot of smart stuff
behind the scenes but also it has some
limitations I'm not going to say that
it's solved um conversation and so you
get a sense of these sort of limitations
and potential if you look at things that
are out there in the real world and this
technology is being used in all sorts of
other places as well that you may or may
not know about there's a very
interesting project I'm working on with
the company which is about dubbing
videos from one language into another
using synthetic speech using AI to do
that that dubbing and these are places
where the technology is now really
getting good enough despite having some
limitations it's getting good enough to
be used in these sort of real world
scenarios so I think yeah taking a look
at where AI is used right now is a great
introduction to how it works we've got
to be careful I've just been told we
can't say Alexa because people watching
back home uh it's all going haywire so
that was the last time no saying hey we
know what her name is and we'll talk
about the gender nature of that as well
actually
um Chris that's a great summary of where
we are now um but it is in all sorts of
builds what do you you see a lot of it
especially on the really cutting edge
side what are you most excited by in
terms of the applications of AI well I
think we've seen huge advances even just
in the last couple of years or so and
it's sort of become ubiquitous so there
are many many places that AI shows up in
our daily lives that we don't know about
I mean I think one you know Arthur Clark
the science fiction writer one said you
know the the best Technologies ones that
disappear into the into the background
they help you in your daily lives you're
not aware of it so it's just all sorts
of things like you know opening your
phone with your face or
um translating from one language to
another on a website or just many many
examples of this
um but I do have a real sense that the
and I've been in the field for about 35
years I mean we've the field has been
called machine learning that I've been
in and rather than artificial
intelligence but it's really a machine
learning has really become the dominant
approach to artificial intelligence and
really just in the last year or two
we've seen just extraordinary advances
to the point where
um I think the next few years in
particular will see some very rapid
changes I think coming back to
Catherine's you know excellent
description of artificial intelligence
is a slippery fish it's very hard to
Define I think there are many different
axes to intelligence different kinds of
intelligence uh and and some of these in
terms of artificial intelligence
progressing very rapidly uh and others
are making slower progress others have
almost been solved in effect
um so really the way research progresses
it doesn't progress uniformly on all
fronts there's certain areas that are
very exciting
um the field that I'm particularly
excited about is the impact of machine
learning and artificial intelligence on
the Natural Sciences on chemistry
physics biology this is a very exciting
field it's such an exciting field that
I've actually pivoted my career uh
started a new role building up a global
team in this space because we think that
machine learning will have a big impact
on our ability to to model and simulate
the world with with many applications in
in drug Discovery and understanding
human disease in discovering new
materials particularly for
sustainability new battery materials new
photovolt tapes uh catalysts ways of
capturing carbon directly from there and
so on so that's the field that I'm
particularly excited about right now and
Anna what are you looking at and
thinking wow that's interesting that's
changing my understanding
there has been enormous progress in
machine learning and AI I've been
involved on the edges of the field for
20 years as a neuroscientist with a deep
interest in machine learning and AI
um but what's what's striking something
like what you said Catherine that it's
there's lots of very specific
applications out there and then if you
look at what AI systems in my
understanding are still not very good at
they are the kinds of things that we do
associate with specifically human kinds
of intelligence things like generalizing
to new situations very quickly learning
things from very small amounts of data
we don't need to be trained on an
internet's worth of cat pictures to
recognize a cat as a human being
there's knowing why we know what we know
and we know something we can say I have
that I have confidence in this judgment
we have insight into our into our
knowledge and then there's the the sort
of guiding of behavior yeah sure we have
self-driving cars and drones that fly
around but as much progress as there has
been in things like playing go or
solving equations in Natural Science
chances we still don't have the kind of
AI that can control bodies in the way
that you know we often used to see in in
science fiction and it may be that we
don't need these things maybe this is
not the goal maybe this is not the
future of AI but that raises the the
interesting question of how much AI can
tell us about the human brain that for
me that's that's the frontier that I'm
interested in what can these new
generations of machine learning and
artificial intelligence models reveal
about cognition thought in humans in
other animals and ultimately of course
this big question of why for for us
there is consciousness why it feels like
anything to be this complex biological
machine that we are and I think AI is
very very far from shedding much useful
light on that question we still need to
solve that question by the end of the
panel though so
hop to it I mean that's really it feels
like you know artificial intelligence I
think it conditions us maybe to think of
a mirror version of human intelligence
but actually we've got a new type of
intelligence this is you know the a
words and the s word it does something
that humans don't need to do and they do
it in very different ways
um because you mentioned that the last
two years have been the sort of Cambrian
explosion of uh new ideas and really
really coming along and Catherines as
well what's been driving that we've had
Peaks and troughs with AI research the
AI Winters where funding dries up and
it's very unfashionable to even talk
about Ai and then these boom towns boom
time sorry it seems like we're in a boom
time what's been driving that
but I think there are a couple of things
actually a couple of discoveries that
we've made in the field in the last two
years that are quite transformational
um the first one has to do with scale so
I I switched from physics into machine
learning into AI about 35 years ago
because I was excited about the idea of
machines that could learn
um it was probably a little naive back
then because we thought that uh uh we
call them neural networks these models
that we build in the computer they have
um back then hundreds or thousands of
these adjustable parameters they're
rather superficially rather like the
synapses in between neurons in the brain
and they adjust as the system learns and
we thought a neural network with a
thousand of these adjustable parameters
was a big network but what we discovered
in in the last couple of years or so is
as you go to very large systems new
properties emerge new capabilities
emerge so um we have colleagues in at a
company called open AI who a couple of
years ago plotted a graph and on the
horizontal axis was uh was time from the
1960s up to about 2020 and on the
vertical axis was how much compute do
to train the state-of-the-art in machine
learning and it was and it was on a what
we call a logarithmic scale so basically
when you see a straight line what it
means is the amount of compute was
doubling every two years or so what that
meant was the field was benefiting like
everything else it was benefiting from
Moore's Law the the doubling and compute
power every couple of years but then
since about 2012 something remarkable
has happened again it's a straight line
but it's much steeper what it means is
that the amount of compute needed to
train the biggest models has been
doubling not every two years but about
every three and a half months so it
means it's about a factor of 10 per year
and that has continued to hold and with
every factor of 10 we've seen new new
capabilities emerge that didn't exist at
the previous factor of 10. so that's
been one sort of breakthrough now
Anna was talking about you know all the
data that you need to train these
systems of course as you go up in a
factor of 10 you need 10 times as much
compute 10 times as much data but the
other discovery that we've made is is
what's called transfer learning the idea
that A system can learn
um to solve one problem it then becomes
much faster at learning a new one so
I'll give you a simple example if you
you find a sort of a blob on your skin
and you're wondering you know is that
just an annoying little thing or is that
is that some sort of cancer that's going
to spread and kill me and of course
you'd go to a dermatologist and they
would they would look at this and and
diagnose it and so people were wondering
could you
um could you just take a photograph of
this and from the photograph that a
machine tell the difference now the
problem there is there aren't there may
be hundreds of thousands of examples of
this but from a machine learning point
of view there really isn't very much
data and so a team of researchers
tackled this by taking another machine
Learning System that had been trained on
a very large data set of things like you
know bicycles and cats and dogs and
mushrooms and so on it and they took
that big trained system and then just
retrained the last little layer on this
new task using a much smaller amount of
data and and it achieves uh human level
performance on that particular task
comparable to a team of professional
dermatologists so this is a very
interesting result so what it means is
that as these systems go to very large
scale they can become much broader
because throughout much of the history
of AI we've developed a system over here
for speech recognition another system
over here for natural language
understanding or something and they've
been rather separate and it's what we're
seeing now is a convergence of different
Technologies into a single in a single
model so it's made this a very very
interesting time to be in the field yeah
that's really exciting I'm just a
reminder
um before I get to you Catherine um
please submit your questions by scanning
the QR code but also vital that you add
your name to it otherwise we can't find
you to ask the question and it will get
asked but you won't get the glory of
having your name associated with it and
if you're on Twitter the hashtag is
hashtag Big Ideas live 22. I mean that
does sound incredibly exciting the way
you've done it uh you've the way you've
told it there
um but there's sort of talk a very very
large systems and new properties
emerging at the same time being used in
very vital ways as you say cancer
identification but you know algorithms
are used in all sorts of important
decisions in our lives and you know in
the states and some places they're using
sentencing criminals things like that
how worried
ignoring the Terminator question which
would do but how worried were you now
about regulating this sometimes it seems
like a black box how do we open that up
and make sure it's being fair
um we're not making the wrong decisions
so I think it you're right it is a bit
of a black box at the moment to be able
to see in side some of these AI machine
learning systems and understand how
they're arriving at the decision that
they're making and that is a really
difficult problem to solve and I don't
think that we have the tools and
techniques to be able to look inside
that now so we can't for example ask on
your own network to justify a decision
about say sentencing in the same way
that you could ask a human judge to
justify that decision and so that's one
area that I think we really need to
spend some effort into developing tools
and techniques to look inside that black
box and figure out but one of the things
that we can do and we should be doing is
looking at how these systems work in the
real world so judging whether they are
exhibiting bias against particular
groups by judging how they're working on
on real people's data
um there are many examples of how face
recognition systems and speech
recognition systems end up performing
worse on particular demographics
particularly groups of people just
because of the way that they've been
trained or the sort of data that they've
already seen is not representative of
the real world and so we really need to
be spending time and effort say taking a
speech recognition system and making
sure that it works across a range of
accents with the similar kind of
accuracy or looking at face recognition
systems and being sure that they are
actually performing well for different
people because when these systems are
used in the world and they become part
of everybody's day-to-day life obviously
it holds people back if these systems
are treating them differently to to
other groups of people so that's a real
area that I think is receiving quite a
lot of attention right now people are
trying to understand how neural networks
are working and we're making progress in
how to evaluate them for for actual real
world problems when we talk about
um emerging properties as well
um some people would argue that
Consciousness is an emerging property of
a breath are we ever going to realize I
don't know when a machine might become
sentient do you think that's even
possible and be how would we know
the answer to the first question is it
even possible I think the honest answer
is that nobody really knows the reason
nobody really knows for a machine is
that nobody really knows even for other
animals other human beings even I cannot
be 100 sure that you are conscious
though I think you are I'm trying and
it's it's it's a unique problem in
science to try in some sense we know and
we've known for for hundreds of
thousands of years that Consciousness
depends on the brain and the body in a
fundamental way you change the brain you
change your conscious experience
yet unlike other problems in biology and
indeed all of science Consciousness is a
private subjective experience I can't
put a conscious experience on the table
and we can all look at it and agree I
can tell you about my experience but
it's it's essentially indirect and
that's what that's some people have said
this means we can't even address the
problem with the tools of science and
philosophy I think that's entirely wrong
we can it's just that there are going to
be some limits on the data that we can
get now
we are learning an increasing amount
about what the basis of Consciousness is
in the human brain which parts of the
brain are necessary or not necessary
um but
we still don't know the answer to a
fundamental question which is does
consciousness
depends on the stuff that something is
made of you and I are made out of carbon
we have biological neurons we have wet
swear rather than the hardware does that
matter now there's one school of thought
that says it doesn't if you program a
computer the right way if the next
generation of machine learning
architectures is is trained in enough
data and the next thing that might
emerge might be awareness but there's no
real good reason to assume that's the
case some things
if you it doesn't matter what it's made
of a computer that plays chess really
plays chess but other things the
material matters like a computer
simulation of a weather forecast that we
all use too it doesn't actually get wet
and windy inside the computer that
simulates the weather and Consciousness
Consciousness is not the same thing as
intelligence and I think this is a
crucial distinction to make because it
so often sad like
not by anyone here of course but in the
wider public that that Consciousness is
some function of intelligence that once
AI crosses some threshold then the
lights come on and it's not only going
to be smart it's going to be sentient
but I think this is
comes from a place of human
exceptionalism we think we're really
special as humans we think we're
intelligent and we know we're conscious
so we think that things go together but
Consciousness we should Define it
actually I mean Consciousness is really
any kind of experience whatsoever it
feels like something to be a conscious
sister
you can an experience of pain or of
seeing color
is is enough you know you don't have to
have complex cognition going on uh in
order to be be conscious so there's no
real good reason to expect that simply
ratcheting up intelligence is going to
make uh an AI system conscious
and just by observing apparently
intelligent Behavior I don't think it's
a reliable signature of whether the
thing is conscious and I think we can be
misled here systems can give us a strong
intuition that there's a conscious mind
there when there's just the whirring of
algorithms we'll come back to that it's
a really interesting point which ties
into a later talk Chris we should check
first whether you do you have any
sentient robots up in Cambridge locked
away in the lab and you just haven't
told people about it well actually I
loved animals answer right this panel is
discussing two different things I think
one is the the ability to create
machines that have certain information
processing and reasoning capabilities
which is a fantastically exciting field
with uh enormous practical implications
actually addressing some of the
society's most challenging problems
right now and with potential for um the
wrong things to happen I think Catherine
gave a lovely description of how we need
the right guard rails in in how we
create and deploy this technology and on
the other hand there's fascinating
impression of Consciousness which is a
person's subjective experience I
experience Consciousness I'm guessing
you experience something similar because
you know we're all broadly the same
within the same species and so on and
and this tremendously difficult question
of over knowing what a machine
experiences or whether it experience is
anything I think that's one of the one
of the toughest problems in science in a
way it's just it's very hard to know
even where to get started I think just
separating out those two I think is
actually very helpful for the discussion
and not conflating them
why do you think we have this obsession
with wanting to have conscious machines
as Sarah James is saying it's such a
Trope of Science Fiction he has some
brilliant films about it some bad films
about it as well it's something we
clearly feel the need to see in the
world why is that Catherine I think
you're right it is a Trope of Science
Fiction and we we want to emulate
ourselves somehow in what we do and so
people are driven to build replicas of
people build technology images like us
but if you look back over time you see
that it's been a constant threat through
the history of technology that people
have wanted to assign human agency to
technology even to other inanimate
objects you'll hear people talking about
how their their TV is annoyed with them
or something like that we assign human
human properties to technology into
other things there is a famous example
of a chatbot which was built back in the
60s called Eliza which was very simple
chat but it was a therapist
um it had some canned answers so you you
tell it your problem and it might say
can you tell me more about that or
sometimes it would flip your your
question back on you so you might say
I'm feeling unhappy and it will say can
you tell me why you're feeling unhappy
very simple responses and the the
creator of this program wanted to show
how stupid computers were but but people
did believe that Eliza had human-like
intelligence and and the Creator was
very surprised by this that he could I
had the opposite effect
and and I think that this trend has sort
of carried on through people are really
Keen to assign human properties to
computers especially when they're using
language and other human-like animations
and and that sort of thing and if you
want to yeah just to come in briefly on
this I think you're absolutely right
that we do project agency and intention
and also Consciousness onto things very
readily you know onto our pets onto
Tamagotchi yeah exactly those things we
used to have but this question of why do
we feel like this is something we need
in our world in our lives I think really
does need to be interrogated because
just as much as we don't know what it
would take to build a machine that has
experience we also don't know what it
wouldn't take and we might do it by
accident we might not know if we've done
it and if if this happens it would be an
ethical catastrophe because soon as
something can have experience
we have an ethical obligation to it to
minimize its potential suffering
and if we don't even know the criteria
by which to establish whether that's
even a possibility we're in really
really deep Waters so just building
something because it sounds cool and
you've seen it in science fiction and
you want to be at The Cutting Edge of
this pivotal moment in in human history
is a really really terrible idea so I I
think that these
goals of building actually conscious AI
are are just wrong we should not be
trying to do that but having said that
there's a sense in which the two things
are not maybe completely separate
Consciousness and intelligence because
the kinds of things back to where we
started the discussion and the kinds of
things that a lot of current AI is not
very good at
seem to be the kinds of things that we
are good at and that we associate with
Consciousness it's like we're very good
at generalizing to new situations we're
very good at reflecting on our own
decisions
um metacognition these kinds of things
we know what we think about we're very
good at integrating large amounts of
information very quickly these are the
sorts of things that that experiments in
Neuroscience psychology have shown are
closely associated with human
consciousness so I think there's a case
for building machines that have some of
the functions that we associate with
Consciousness but that's very different
from the goal of trying to build a
machine that feels which I think is a
really bad idea but I but I think just
just pushing back a little there I think
there's a risk of saying computers can't
do X Y and Z because next year they'll
be able to do X maybe or maybe the year
after it's Y and I think there's a risk
that humans become the peace that's left
over the machines haven't yet done and
the reality of AIS that exists today
it's actually completely reverse I think
you commented earlier that there's a
complementarity between machines do and
what um and what the human brain does
and the actual original question about
Hollywood movies there's a reason the
Hollywood movies depict Killer Robots
because they've got to keep it being
entertained for two hours right and if
you take I mean I'll just give you an
example of AI in practice we've
developed a system called inner eye
which was actually deployed at Adam
Brooks Hospital in Cambridge we
developed in in partnership with their
with their clinicians
um and it's uh it's used to do radiation
therapy planning so somebody has a solid
tumor and they need radiation therapy
you need to know very precisely where
the tumor is in three-dimension
to treat it with radiation and the way
that's done conventionally in most
places now is the you have a 3D body
scan and the radiation oncologist goes
through this layer by layer and marks
the boundary of the at the boundary of
the tumor um can take 20 minutes for a
simple case can take several hours if
it's metastasized there are multiple
tumors
um so what inner eye does is it it does
that automatically and presents a a
proposal for this three-dimensional
segmentation we call it to the radiation
oncologist who then can go through and
check and make any corrections and
alterations to the radiation oncologist
is still doing this this segmentation
but instead of taking several hours they
can just take a couple of minutes to
check a proposal most of the time
they're not making many changes so
that's the reality of AI and how it's
impacting the people's lives I think if
you made a two-hour movie of somebody
segmented gee I don't think it would be
a Hollywood blocks I probably wouldn't
watch it all the way through
um but maybe Sky could buy up I mean so
those are robots that save lives but we
are let's talk about Killer Robots to
sort of pick up on some of that and you
know the idea of the singularity that
questions of Consciousness aside what
happens to the point how have you
defined a machine is more intelligent
than a human lots of people predict that
then it very quickly becomes much more
intelligent as it figures out how to
improve itself and again this is a
slight science fiction Trope but it also
has lots of very serious very
intelligent people worried about it you
know Nick bostromer Oxford with the
center for existential risk thinks
that's something we should be thinking
about just in case it does come after
Humanity I mean is the singularity
plausible and should we be thinking
about it in that way in terms of
preventing the worst happening
found you
um so I like to think in terms of a
worry budget you know we can do a
certain amount of worrying in a day and
when it comes to AI we've already
discussed some of the Clear and Present
concerns about bias
um you know about sort of overextension
of systems into domains where they're
not necessarily working self-driving
cars might crash
sure there's a there's there's in
principle there might be this scenario
where AI boots itself
bootstraps itself beyond our
understanding and control and ravages
the world in terms but that to me seems
a very small part of our worry budget
it's worth worrying about a little bit
but but not very much no very much you
the same on that I think it's a great
answer I think uh you know if I stay
awake about worrying about things it's
certainly not Hollywood Killer Robots
it's you know what were you doing to our
planet the rate of Increase of CO2
emissions is uh you know we're heading
for for massive problems in that space I
think it's far far more likely that AI
will help us address those kinds of
problems for example by by our ability
to simulate Atomic matter uh you know
really Atomic and molecular level can
help us find new new battery materials
new uh electrolytes for the hydrogen
economy even even ways of capturing
carbon for the atmosphere that that
could make a real dent in that problem
and could really help us on on the path
success there that that that to me is
what AI is really all about rather than
you know the Killer Robots and so on
make great science fiction movies but I
think the the opportunity in the upside
that we have here again as long as we
have the right guard rails and how we
how we deployed and how we use it
um in terms of worry budget you know
there are plenty of challenges in the
world right now I think this just isn't
one of them
I don't think I can improve on those
answers I think there is certainly very
clear and present immediate
um problems with AI that we should be
worrying about far more and the ways
that people might use it now rather than
a hypothetical scenario that may or may
not come true down the line so I mean
those people who do ask these questions
not just in Hollywood but you know uh
Elon Musk said I mean I know stock isn't
very high at the moment but he said a
few years ago I've got exposure to the
most cutting-edge AI sounding a bit like
Donald Trump that the most Cutting Edge
II I think people should be really
concerned by it well I mean
he's a smart man whatever you think of
what's happening at Twitter right now
um why is he wrong to worry about that
is he wrong to try and worry other
people about it
depends what he means I mean as as a
general technology yes there's a lot
there's a lot to be concerned about it's
very powerful it's and I think this
invisibility point that you mentioned
earlier is really relevant that
successful AI is um is noticeable by how
unnoticeable it is that every successful
technology becomes invisible and when it
becomes invisible
we will not see the potential problems
with it the biases become even more
hidden so there is an awful lot to worry
about but it's still this this Prospect
of Singularity mongering I I don't think
is that another thing about that though
it's
we've mentioned a few times that
it's insane acceleration of compute
power we there's this exponential curve
many aspects of AI and the thing about
an exponential curve is that wherever
you are on it what's behind you looks
completely flat and what's ahead of you
looks impossibly steep so it's very very
easy to think of yourself as right at
the point of this pivotal transition but
that's going to be true wherever you are
on the curve so I think that is behind a
lot of the sort of psychological
um motivation for us to think that a
singularity is around the corner but
excessive focus on these these almost
existential situations distracts us from
the problems that are here and now and
then we have been treated them
separately so far artificial versus real
intelligence but there are obviously
efforts
um think of Elon Musk actually in the
neural link to have that brain computer
interface
um where are we with all that and what
does that mean in 10 years time we're
all Googling by thinking of it what what
is that sort of fast presentations look
like caffeine
I think
it's an interesting concept to think
about but
by people in the world I'm not sure
people would like to Google things by
thinking about them that that might seem
a little scary to them that a computer
can read their thoughts and show them
the information that they're worried
about and so with all of these things I
think you have to sort of embed it in
how people are going to use the
technology in the real world and there's
a difference between developing
hypothetical technology and developing
the products that become the AI that we
use day to day
have you seen those products Chris is
that something you're looking at well
yeah it's interesting I think it's to do
with you know there are different modes
of interacting with machines and uh you
know for example if you're if you're
disabled then you might be able to
interact with the machines through a
different modality than say a keyboard
but and of course we're all disabled at
some point right if you're driving a car
until we have fully autonomous vehicles
you have to have your hands on the
steering wheel so maybe you don't use a
keyboard maybe use voice so I think
these are different ways of of
interacting it is possible yes to put a
sort of a skull cap on and detect
through the skull the the tiny
electrical signals of the at least the
surface neurons I'm sure you know a lot
more about this than I do and use that
to do very basic control so um for some
people in some situations that may be a
good way to to interface and the reverse
may be true as well so there are
certainly devices I'm no expert in this
field but people who are blind a camera
can take an image be processed you send
to a set of electrodes at the back of
the digital cortex at the back of the
brain and can give people who are
otherwise blind some sense of sight not
as good as uh regular Vision but it's uh
nothing and that technology is improving
all the time so I think there is a role
for different kinds of ways of you know
interfacing our brains and Machines of
the ground I've just described and um
and just the last question before we
um open up to the audience so I want to
talk about we've talked about
um Ai and what we learned about it when
you've been looking at the field has it
taught you your stuff about human
consciousness has that looking at
machine intelligence
giving you insights into the human brain
yes and for me that's the primary
motivation I think these these
techniques have been incredibly useful
in understanding what's happening in a
biological brain but they can also be be
misleading if we think that they're too
too much the same they're not the same
but yeah our brains contain among other
things neurons that are wired up in
complex patterns and those patterns
resemble uh neural networks in fact
that's why they're called neural
networks in machine learning and AI so
we can do lots of things by adapting
techniques developed in Nai to
enhance our understanding of the human
brain for instance
um a lot has been discovered about
visual perception by using networks that
have been trained to classify objects
and images and you can find out that if
you put somebody in a brain scanner and
have them look at look at images and
then you can use these neural networks
to interpret the activity in in the
brain and understand more about
exactly how the brain is putting
together different pieces of the image
to form a visual perception and in my
group one of the things we're doing is
taking these methods forward to
understand hallucinations
in psychiatry in neurology when people
start having unusual distorted
perceptions and what's actually going on
in the brain that makes them experience
the world in these unusual and often
distressing ways well Ai and machine
learning can can really help us there
thank you so much there's more questions
better questions to come from the
audience and the first one is from Eve
finder if you're around and if you could
stand out the microphone will come over
to you
just over here
I sent it a few so I don't know if one
has landed but um uh I guess can you
talk a little bit more about
creativity and artificial intelligence
you know how do you move from
analytical intelligence to more
generative intelligence
just in case you didn't hear that on the
microphone how how do we have more
creative ai go away from analytical
intelligence to more creative
intelligence uh who wants to have a go
at that I can talk about activity in
different ways so
there's been a trend recently for
machine learning models which can
generate content which I think is is one
of these really interesting developments
that Chris was talking about machines
that can generate images you type a
prompt a description of what you want it
to be and it will generate that image it
can generate videos even even computer
codes they're the model which would
generate computer programmers with
generating computer code all these
creativity tools there are still
difficulties using them it's kind of
difficult to control exactly what they
output and to have yet much control over
the sorts of images that you're getting
or that the type of code you're getting
but these are really one way that
computers are becoming more creative
although they're still highly
constrained by the description that the
person gives so there's a lot of human
creativity that goes into them and
they're more tools that can help people
in different creative ways so that's one
really interesting spread in creativity
and then I think there's another really
interesting aspect to creativity which
is surfacing different
insights from different places to help
people make those connections and there
is a whole separate thread of research
in this direction of how can you help
people be more creative by showing them
all the different bits of information
that they need to do their job to make
those better Creative Connections and
these are both fascinating to watch and
I'm really curious to see where they
will end up
yeah we can add to that so
um as Catherine alluded to just in the
last couple of years or so we've seen a
big advantage of what are called
generative models so these are models
which don't just classify things and
process information they actually
generate things like be able to type in
a caption generate a photorealistic
image and so on this is very interesting
we're using those kinds of models those
generative models actually in
partnership with Novartis to generate
candidate drug molecules so the problem
of drug Discovery the number of what are
called small molecule drugs or sort of
traditional drugs that we have is is
roughly 10 to the power 60 that's one
with 60 zeros so there's this utterly
unimaginably vast space of molecules and
what happens now is um
Chemists in in Pharma companies like
Novartis based on their experience will
propose different molecules based on add
different groups and different
structures to them and when they think
they've come up with some good ideas
they'll be tested in the wet lab and
then a subset of those might eventually
go into clinical trials in the subset of
those eventually become become drugs in
the real world but this is such an
enormous space to explore so what these
generous models are doing is helping
their creativity because creativity
isn't just art it's also drug Discovery
is creativity creating ideas for new
molecules and what we're finding is
these generative models to come up with
with quite new and interesting ideas for
molecules the extent that these are now
being synthesized and what it means is
the those chemists who are trying to
discover new drug molecules in effect
their cognition is Amplified instead of
just sort of having a pencil and paper
they've got this powerful tool which
makes their effectively makes their
creative Powers just orders of magnitude
greater and allows them to explore that
space much more efficiently so I think
it's uh I think it's a super question
it's definitely a capability that's
emerging in machine learning I'm just
gonna thank you for that uh trying to
get as many questions and next one is
from Jeremy if you could stand up and
ask a question here at the front for the
microphone please
hello panel hello yeah um my question is
a lot of people worry about when AI will
overwhelm human strengths like in films
the Terminator but has it already
overwhelmed human weaknesses
Anna do you want to hear that that's a
very I like the way of putting that I
think yeah I think that the answer is
probably in some ways yes I mean
technology has a habit of exploiting our
weaknesses but it's typically not the
technology then and it's the people
behind the technology so you could make
the argument that a lot of social media
is successful by precisely exploiting
um our human weaknesses and our
psychology and I think that that will
continue it's a really nice way of
putting the question
brilliant um got a question from hero
Daria Nani um if you're around and could
stand up yes
uh yeah sorry once that microphone will
be with you
yeah just kind of related to the last
one about AI I think this for some time
my ideas of it replacing people in their
jobs and the work they do
um rather than complimenting is that is
that real is that being tracked
um and related to that people are
talking about Universal basic income
again is that something
I'll see in my lifetime I don't know
well I think it's clear that the
technology is changing the nature of
work and certainly
um again I'm probably a tech Optimist
but I when I think about the
opportunities here to
um we've talked a bit about the
healthcare sector now I mean in in the
UK but in many developing countries no
healthcare is just becoming an
increasing proportion of GDP it's just
becoming very very expensive and that
trend is set to continue as we become
older as we we no longer die from
diseases but we live with diseases those
problems are just going to be
exacerbated and and a while I certainly
wouldn't claim that AI can can solve all
these problems if there's one of the few
opportunities I see where the curve is
going in the other direction where that
exponential is going in a very helpful
Direction and I gave just one simple
example of inner eye and tumor
segmentation drug Discovery was another
one but many many situations in which
you want to you have human expertise and
a doctor would be a great example but
with that doctor spending a lot of their
time doing tedious stuff I mean they
might spend a lot of time interacting
with the computer and filling out forms
and so on and a lot of that is is ripe
for being helped with with AI so really
freeing that person's time to engage
directly with patients and do the things
they're particularly good at so I really
do see at least for the foreseeable
future this real complementarity between
What machines do and what what humans do
and even where the machine is better at
something than the human it doesn't mean
it disappears being a great example
there's chess right if it's long been
the case your phone can beat any human
being at chess easily so do people stop
playing don't display chess anymore I'll
get my phone to do it for me no of
course not the chess is more popular
than ever and that people use I think
everybody I know who plays chess uses
those chess programs as a as an opponent
to analyze broad positions and all the
other things so I think that
complementarity fundamentally comes down
to a choice this is powerful generic
technology and but we're creating it we
can choose we can choose how we use it
um Leo has a question if you could stand
up
over there
um microphone is coming your way hold on
one second
uh so might it be possible for a human
brain to be linked up to an AI computer
so the human brain could uh tap into the
AI in its status
reserves and with the AI Beyonce
experience the human conscious uh or is
this still science fiction
again I think there's a really good
question I think in a sense we're
already doing this every time we use a
search engine we're tapping into
artificial intelligence to expand the
powers of our of our own mind it doesn't
really matter whether there's a wire
going from your phone straight into your
brain or you just hold it in your hand
and look at it we're already combining
with AI in in ways that enhance change
our minds change the way we think change
the way we we behave my memory is
largely on my phone rather than in my
head now and you know this Outsourcing
of our cognitive abilities to to
artificial systems I think is going to
continue but it doesn't mean we
disappear I think as has been saying
there's still a distinction between what
makes us ours and what what we use as
tools that my one of my mentors a
philosopher called Daniel Dennett
brilliant man says that we should all
always remember that we're building
tools not colleagues and just bear that
in mind when we're developing the next
generation of AI as you might do that's
great I mean Socrates who are
complaining about the invention of
writing that everyone would forget
everything but it's worked out all right
so far we've got time for one more
question um Selena if you're around and
could stand up over here
thank you hi I think when we talk about
AI as a general public it's either
something to worry about or it's like
the solution to all our problems as
experts what do you think is something
that you know because you work with it
every day but the general public should
know and something that we can do to
influence
um the future of AI as well
foreign
I would say
I've learned that
AI technology can underneath the hood be
complicated and difficult to understand
if you really go down into the details
but I think that for the general public
it could be really difficult even to get
a grasp of what AI is because
it's there's very little explain
explainers out there very little to tell
you what AI is and how it's used and
some of the language used by the tech
World puts people off they make it seem
like it's this really difficult
impenetrable kind of technology that
only a select few can understand and I
don't think that's true I think there
should be better ways for the the public
to understand technology to be able to
know its its strengths and its
limitations then be able to influence
the direction and so I think I see a lot
of people who lack confidence and say
well I couldn't understand that it's too
difficult for me and I think I would
like to see ways that we and the tech
industry can break down that barrier and
give people the confidence to know that
they can shape the direction of this
technology it's not just driven by it
shouldn't just be driven by a small
select group of people that's a great
place to end it great question great
answer
um thank you so much all the panelists I
think we solved everything we got there
in 45 minutes thank you very much for
being here and and for watching along at
home and sending in all those questions
and there's plenty more to come here Big
Ideas live
Sarah Jones
thank you thank you to Tom and that
brilliant panel discussing artificial
intelligence and Big Ideas live there's
so much going on here today not just on
the festival stage in the future stage
but we've got lots of Innovations on
display welcome to the metaverse this is
architecture and art in the metaverse
your chance to see how that all works
this has been a very very busy stand uh
coming up at 20 to 4 this afternoon
talking about AI we're going to be
hearing from the former Google engineer
now you may remember this story we did
cover it on Sky News he was sacked for
claiming that the chatbot tool he was
working on had feelings and should have
its wants respected we were talking to
him live here on Big Ideas live at 22 4.
that's on the festival stage over on the
Futures stage our Science and Technology
editor Tom Clark is going to be tackling
a really interesting question is it
possible to end Aging for good and back
here in 10 minutes time on the main
stage of the festival stage we'll be
talking about social media so much of
technology is focused on social media
the challenges of moderating it we'll be
hearing from a man from a man who worked
for both Elon Musk and Mark Zuckerberg
and he is now working with Facebook's
oversight board which was established by
meta to make independent decisions on
its content we're going to be hearing
from Dex Hunter toric shortly so don't
go too far
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the next session is on the main Festival
stage and is about to start
the next session is on the main Festival
stage and is about to start
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
and welcome back to big eyes live very
busy here lots of people taking the
opportunity to explore our Innovation
stands so much new tech and Innovation
on display very busy in here very busy
uh just in front of me as well we're
gonna head back in to the festival stage
now in here um not so long ago about an
hour or so ago I was talking to the
information commissioner John Edwards
and the Crystal Palace footballer uh lee
Nichol about the best way to protect
people and their data online it really
is a Hot Topic and it's only going to
get bigger as technology advances and
more people go online earlier well it's
time now to hear from someone helping to
make those decisions about freedom of
expression and designing deciding what
content is appropriate with that I'm
going to hand over to our technology
correspondent Ray lamanthorpe
thanks SJ uh I'm so delighted to be here
with Dex Hunter Turek of the Facebook uh
meta I should say uh oversight board
um one of the most interesting and
unique experiments in one of the most
important areas the moderation of what
we can and can't put online Dex welcome
good to be here let's just start by
helping me understand the principles
underlying the oversight board so there
are 20 people on it why 20 why not seven
what are the core principles that
underline the design of it yeah so we
actually we have 23 now we've grown a
little bit um the way we've looked at it
is uh to make decisions about content
for a global set of platforms Facebook
and Instagram have billions of users
around three billion uh we need to have
members on an independent body who
represent the huge diversity of that
user base many different backgrounds
many different communities who can help
solve some of those really complex
challenges that users are facing every
single day on those platforms so our
starting point was really how can we get
enough different points of expertise
that we can make informed judgments
about these issues over time I expect
the board will grow large and we'll have
more members um adding to that so the
the question or the topic of oversight
boards and content moderation boards has
really come up recently because Elon
Musk has said that he'd like one for
Twitter you worked for Elon Musk
um what advice would you have for him on
this topic well look I think um the
first thing I would say when looking at
Twitter and how to moderate content
there is you have to start with the
principle of Do no harm and I mean that
in the sense that medical professionals
look at Patients
um when you make decisions here uh you
know four platforms like Twitter which
are part of the critical infrastructure
of free expression around the world for
you know many millions of people
including activists people who are you
know struggling for Better Lives for
democracy in societies facing Conflict
for decisions you make in California can
be immensely consequential and so
actually making a very rapid you know
knee-jerk decisions about the direction
of content about content policy that's
probably not the right way to go from
the oversight board perspective what we
have you know repeatedly you know
encouraged better to do with how they
moderate content is to be transparent
about how they make decisions
um really to show how they've come to a
decision so that it builds trust with
users
um trust in social media companies and
in business I I think has taken an
absolute rollicking over recent years
and certainly I think it will not be
helpful for restoring trust if you have
uh Elon making decisions where people
wonder is this being driven mainly
because of elon's personal preferences I
do think as well if you're building a
Content Council it has to genuinely
operate independently from the company
it cannot be something that just
reflects elon's personal preferences
yeah because as you
um refer to the key decision when meta
said it or Facebook as it was then set
up the oversight board
was that Mark Zuckerberg essentially
stepped back and said you take over this
he didn't actually step back all the way
but he did step back a little bit I mean
you know Elon Musk right does he have
the self-discipline uh the self-control
I I mean just does he have the character
to take a decision like that yeah I mean
um Elon is somebody who famously
describes himself not as a micromanager
but as a nano manager uh he's somebody
who uh often likes to be very involved
in things that are quite intricate and
you think other CEOs might not be uh
that invested in that element
um you know certainly um I think that
sounds like a no uh I I think based on
the last couple of weeks I think it's a
couple of weeks though it seems longer
um he is unlikely uh to be uh very
detached from these decisions we'll have
to see how it unfolds I mean I
understand that he's probably minded to
bring in another CEO to run Twitter so
he can go back to focusing on other
parts of his business
um interests and that would probably be
the right way to go I think Twitter
needs a lot of attention and if elon's
going to be providing that I wonder
who's going to be running the shop at
Tesla and SpaceX and just to say is that
essentially is that if the overlord of
the company is involved in a project
like the oversight board it can't work
can it
yeah I mean uh the oversight board
operates completely independently from
the political the commercial the public
relations interests of uh meta uh we you
know frankly don't care what Mark
Zuckerberg thinks about the decisions we
make
um we are there to advocate for users to
ensure that users are being treated
fairly um Elon does not need to be
involved he should not be involved in
making those incredibly consequential
decisions um I think he needs to take a
step back there needs to be policies and
processes that people can have trust in
that really allow this content Council
to operate independently okay Elon if
you're listening there you go some some
advice for free
um I want to talk about
um some specific cases but before I do
can you give me a sense of the scale of
the operation
um with just a few numbers so how many
cases have been referred to you or of
people
um made referrals by appealing to you
yeah so we've received over two million
appeals from users to date and a small
number as well from meta of those we've
done 29 big case decisions so 20 so 29
of 29. so why not more yeah so the way
to think about it right is we are not a
general customer service mechanism for
meta so we're not going to be in a
position to answer all of those two
million cases we could have 10 times as
many board members I still think we
wouldn't be able to answer all of those
what we're trying to do in each of those
cases is diagnose big underlying
systemic problems with Facebook and
Instagram which we then tell a company
to go away and fix so in those 29 cases
we also delivered over 130
recommendations of things that have to
change on Facebook and Instagram and the
companies agreed to more than 60 of
those we think that's a pretty good
batting average
um all of the decisions we've made about
individual content as well the company
has committed to and they've implemented
what the board has told them so just to
pick up on something you said there the
company uh you've made 130
recommendations and the company has
picked up 60 I mean the oversight board
is often referred to as the Supreme
Court for meta but when the Supreme
Court says something the government has
to do it sure this isn't the case right
definitely we don't use that Supreme
Court framing others use it as a sort of
you know easy shorthand for referring to
this kind of body and I think the reason
they do that is we are a new type of
entity we are a self-regulatory body
designed to solve some of these
challenges within the tech industry
nothing like this has been attempted
before you know I think honestly uh the
fact that meta has agreed to more than
60 of those recommendations which are
very consequential which potentially
impact hundreds of millions of users
experience on the platform I think
that's a good thing um obviously we'd
like that they accept all of them but
baby steps okay and and just on the I
mean I know you're doing your best but
29 out of 2 million what about expanding
the board say to 40. yeah I mean uh over
time the board may end up being 40
members I expect will will grow over the
coming months but those 29 decisions if
you go and look at them and of course if
you go on our website you can read all
of those decisions in extraordinary
wonky detail they are very significant
changes to the platform you know just
one single example right um because of
the oversight boards work more than 800
million uh users of metas platforms can
now actually read the rules of those
platforms in their own languages that
may not sound like a big deal on its own
it's a single thing but it's an
important part of building transparency
and those 130 other recommendations each
of those is something that additive will
reshape the experience for users on the
platforms
are you having difficulty hiring people
because I know the ambition is to get to
40 are you having difficulty getting new
members because meta gets a final say on
who's um who's on the moon we honestly
haven't had particular difficulties with
that I mean we added the three
additional members just this year
um what we have been doing though is
taking a lot of time to determine what
are those extra points of expertise and
also to work out how scaling the number
of members will impact the overall
institution so because we are a new body
this is a new way of working
um those small changes which may sound
sort of self-evident they actually may
have outsized impact on the quality of
decisions so right now for example every
decision the board makes gets approved
by the entire board so that was designed
to prevent any single member or small
set of members from having an outsized
impact on these very consequential uh
issues um if you had 40 members instead
of 20
um obviously unanimity or a majority
there is going to be much more
challenging to achieve so it's working
out how to scale but effective I want to
talk about some specific cases
um because once you get into the
specifics I think it is unbelievably
fascinating how this all works but first
just to remind everyone here that you
could submit can submit questions by
scanning the QR code on your seats or if
you're watching on TV or online then you
can submit your questions on Twitter
using the hashtag Big Ideas live 22.
right so let's talk about a specific
case a recent one can you tell me about
the case of the Russian Nazi yeah sure
so I mean this is a very recent case
decision that came from the oversight
board this was a post uh in the context
of the Ukraine conflict uh where someone
was calling for death to the fascist
Invaders and that's and that's that's
what they said in their post death to
the fascist Invaders that's right um and
there was a an image as well as uh
poetry I believe in that case and this
was content that was removed by meta
from the platform and after the board
looked at it we said that was the wrong
decision and actually uh we required it
to be restored platform which the
company did and the reason for that is
you had to look at speech in the context
of what was happening in Ukraine an
unlawful invasion of a country with
people in Ukraine and many voices
outside of Ukraine are looking to
support the population there uh
naturally contextualizing the violence
that was taking place in Ukraine uh in
the context of other historical
injustices that have unfolded in Ukraine
so in that context
um actually we said this is perfectly
legitimate speech this is something that
in the context of a conflict is
something that should be permitted it
doesn't represent hate speech calling
for the death to the fascist Invaders
there in that context was referring to
Russian military forces who are acting
as aggressors so that's one example of
the sort of very consequential free
speech in human rights disease we do
with and if and if I understand the case
correctly part of it was that the the
post said kill the fascists kill him
kill him kill him this is something of
course that would never be permitted
normally on on Facebook because one
thing you're absolutely not allowed to
do is make threats of violence but this
reference this killed the fascist phrase
was in a reference to a poem from I
think believed the 1940s and this level
of specificity is exactly what you're
dealing with so on this question then
you've in the end you decided that the
post should go back up
that took quite a while to decide
what difference does it really make to
anyone on the ground if in the end
you've decided that in this very
specific circumstance actually this one
relatively small posts can exist yeah so
this is exactly where the
recommendations we make in those cases
do have an impact and I think they're
the most important part of those
decisions
um requiring meta to build policies and
systems that can understand that context
uh the guidance that they provide their
content moderators as they apply the
rules when they're looking at many
future instances of content that's where
we can truly have an impact so you're
entirely right on a single piece of
content it may or may be not be so
influential but in future cases because
of the board's work and the way we've
scrutinized those breakdowns and the
policies and the systems that will have
an impact for many many more people so
can you say then that the way that the
war in Ukraine is being talked about by
people on Facebook has been changed as a
result of the other side but I think
it's something which will make a small
change and it will add up to a much
larger set of changes that meta has also
of course been doing itself since the
conflict began and you know they've had
to change a lot of the ways they look at
content they've had many new challenges
that have emerged in the context of that
crisis
um this is another contribution from our
side just to remind you you can all post
your questions
um please do I scan the QR code on your
seat
right you mentioned moderation and I
think I really want to talk about this
because I think this is so important
other the practice of moderation so for
those who don't know
um a lot of moderation on Facebook is
done by algorithms it's done by by uh by
what some people call AI but it's really
just automated sifting of content and
then some of it is done by a large group
of people through Silicon Valley company
in other words really a very small
number of people given the scale of
Facebook
I think it's helpful to talk about a
specific case to get us into this so can
you tell me about the case of the
Brazilian nipple yes this is a case uh
that we took on a couple of years ago
now and uh this was a piece of content
on Instagram that was removed through uh
automated moderation by an AI system and
it contained a nipple and of course
Instagram has rules around nudity
um what the system did not understand is
that this piece of content was in the
context of a user raising awareness
about breast cancer and of course that
is something which the board when it
looked at that we said first of all that
is a legitimate thing which should be
allowed on the platform and subsequently
because of the board's decision
Instagram actually revised its Community
guidelines to allow that so we've taken
away that problem for users people
should be allowed to post about breast
cancer on Instagram which includes
images of nudity
um with AI of course there's a much
larger a set of problems here which you
very rightly pointed out have been
exposed by this case yeah because
because just to say is that that post
that nipple which was put up in the
context of breast cancer awareness was
removed by AI it wasn't yet so yeah so
so what is it so okay so you made your
decision what does this mean in practice
then the AI gets reprogrammed
um the the the the the moderators they
get a little different line in their in
their book of of things they're not
allowed to put on that's exactly right
tell me what happens that's exactly
right so the decisions of the board go
back to refining the processes and the
way those processes are enforced uh at
meta and we don't take the company's
word for this I should say we have a
whole team on the board side which we
imaginatively call the implementation
team which studies in depth how will the
company implements the board's decisions
we report on all of that publicly
through our quarterly and annual
reporting so that is exactly what is
supposed to happen with AI
um obviously there is no future for
Content moderation on platforms which
have billions of users unless AI is part
of that you know I I talked about the
impossibility of any set of humans even
if we you know doubled or troubled the
size of our board to deal with all of
those problems so you do need to have ai
but you do need to refine those systems
and understand where they're breaking
down I I find that interesting because
to me reading the cases of the oversight
boards what really comes out is just how
important context is context is
everything
but robots or AI or whatever we call it
they're not great at contexts can
automation actually do this job in a way
that is fair to humans yeah I mean AI
has definitely obviously Advanced
enormously over the last decade it's
doing in a lot of cases a okay job at
looking at that context and of course
this is a lot of engineering work right
to build in the understanding with these
systems that can really pay attention to
very intricate social economic political
situations the backdrop of that content
but over time
um this is something that absolutely is
going to pose a technical challenge it
is something that the more you get into
very Niche situations you understand the
limitations of the existing systems it's
something we're going to have to solve
and figure out what the limits are have
you looked at all at the condition of
human moderators because we're talking
about people here we know from
whistleblowers that human moderators
might be asking to make might be asked
to make a decision in 10 seconds they're
exhausted they're burdened by how much
they have to do many hours or some are
suffering from PTSD of the things
they've seen
and these might be people who are
operating say in a war zone where in
fact there's been a war recently in
Ethiopia I don't know how many
moderators Facebook has for the
languages of the warring parties but I'm
going to guess it's not very many right
this strikes me as one of the real
issues for the oversight boards in that
you might be delivering your high-minded
judgments but they're being implemented
On The Ground by people whose working
conditions make it almost impossible for
them to do a fair job
have you investigated that yeah so I
should say uh we do look at how some of
those human elements of moderation fit
in with broader systemic issues at meta
so one example very specifically we had
a case from Myanmar uh where we found
that there probably wasn't uh sufficient
guidance given to content moderators to
allow them to look at content in the
language it was actually posted so our
guidance back to meta was you can't make
decisions in that way you need to ensure
that there are sufficient language and
translation resources available so that
moderators can actually look at the
content in in that language
um it is something that is a bigger
problem we've had some conversations
with uh folks who are representing uh
that community of human moderators it's
not a thing that has been the main focus
for the board and for that why not
because it seems absolutely key I mean
have you audited the work of moderate
it's an important problem it's not the
one the board was designed to do and we
are very candid that we are a small body
designed to do one one thing very very
well which is look at content uh and try
to reconcile uh the policies and the
processes of meta with some of its human
rights obligations uh there are other
players who need to be involved in
solving these problems not just this
we're part of an ecosystem of solutions
this is where Regulators this is where
researchers this is where Civil Society
also come into into the picture I mean
but
but this seems to me not it's going to
be completely crucial I mean so again to
take the war in Ethiopia Facebook has
been implicated with uh amplifying the
Violence by allowing hate speech on its
platforms ultimately if there are only
I don't know five moderators there for
for the for the entire um language of
one warring party
I mean I mean really this this could
this could cause really bad things to
happen yeah sure so uh you know I should
stress that is the sort of thing we do
look at so whether there are human
elements that contribute to the outcomes
that are being produced in these cases
but actually solving this is you know
for example looking at Labor conditions
for moderators that's absolutely
important problem this is not to deny
that for a second that's not going to be
the thing the board is going to solve on
its own and we need to be realistic
about the resources and the expertise we
have on our side fair enough thank you
very much right we have time for
questions now
um and we have a question from Colleen
Cotter
Colleen hello would you mind uh yes
telling us your question please if you
give give us a second wait for the mic
to get over
this is I think a very relevant question
given what we were just talking about
um yes are you talking about context so
you're covering um some of that but I
just wondered how do you account for
Language and Cultural variation of
meaning that's you know you've already
been addressing a lot of that but I'd
like for you to talk a little bit more
about that thank you so a question on
Language and Cultural variation of
meaning
yeah but you must have really thought
about absolutely so I mean
um for a very long time
um I think a lot of board members have
had a view that the way content is
moderated is often very uh Western
Centric and often very U.S Centric and
if you look at any number of examples of
uh content issues in the global South
we've seen communities that are
repeatedly not well served by the
decisions and the policies of big Tech
platforms and so for that reason the
board has been very focused on looking
at Global South communities in
particular
underrepresented communities
historically who have often been
marginalized when it comes to these Tech
issues over half of the board's cases
today have been from the global South
um in those cases very often it is uh
linguistic and cultural Nuance that is a
critical part of that context that we
talked about and the ability to treat
users fairly in to make the right
decisions about content um and so um the
board itself is very very diverse you
know we've got 23 board members they've
lived in I believe 29 countries they
speak 27 languages
um we are constantly bringing in outside
points of expertise as well we have a
system called the public comment process
which allows any any person any of you
to contribute your point of view to how
we interpret decisions lots of Civil
Society organizations and researchers on
the global South are often engaging with
us on these cases and we engage with
them regularly so I think we're making
progress towards that there's still much
more work to be done though and I think
meta needs to do a better job there
thank you um and we also have a question
question from Chris Chohan I apologies
if I'm pronouncing that incorrectly
Chris hi can you can you wait for the
mic to come over and stand up and ask
you a question
thanks very much how can we yeah just
checking those work
um just on the topic itself as well this
I suppose in a bit more broader sense
you know as part of the oversight group
who moderates the moderators and
um how can we ensure that people see
this as uh trustworthy and effective
the big question who moderates the
moderators yeah who watches the Watchmen
um so uh one of the things that I think
is critical and this is certainly the
same advice I would give to Elon as he
thinks about this content Council
proposal is uh we are very transparent
about the work we do as well as being I
think often very western-centric uh in
terms of content moderation I think most
people would agree uh the way that
Silicon Valley companies have made these
big decisions have been very opaque um I
mean we're talking about researchers and
policy makers and Regulators even who
are really struggling often to
understand what's the rationale for some
of these incredibly consequential
decisions that end up impacting millions
of people's lives so um from our side we
put all of our working out in public
pretty much as as far as we can
obviously while ensuring that people's
privacy and security is protected in
some of these um communities
um the other thing we do is um we are
very very open uh and structured about
the principles and the mechanisms we use
to actually make decisions within the
board so you can go and read our literal
rules book for members that's on our
website you can see our bylaws and how
we're structured and we also have an
independent trust with a set of Trustees
who are there to scrutinize the board
and make sure that we're upholding our
mission we've got another question from
uh dino dino hiya and yeah in the
audience yeah if you wait for the mic to
come around yeah really interesting
question hello I've got a question
really about Jeopardy
um so a lot of moderation is I guess
seen as invisible takedowns we don't see
it when it happens unless it hits the
news so the the personal responsibility
or the learnings for the the rest of the
users are sort of invisible so uh is
there anything is there any power you
have to reflect back onto the the
platform to put Jeopardy like to make
people responsible for transgressing
rules or is it just uh silent takedown
is is is where the future of moderation
is yeah should there be more visible
signs that someone's been sanctioned
yeah uh that's a that's a really
interesting question um I mean certainly
um there's a a piece of material that
we're going to be publishing over the
next few weeks on something called cross
check and cross check for those who
don't know it is the system that meta
uses to moderate uh in particular high
profile and VIP accounts on Facebook and
Instagram and this is a system that came
to a lot of public prominence last year
when Francis howgan the Facebook
whistleblower
um revealed uh some of the problems that
really are plaguing how that Crosstrek
system has applied so um in the
reporting that came out in the Wall
Street Journal first
um uh Francis Haugen argued that
actually the way cross-check was being
applied to content often spoke to behind
the scenes Decisions by the platform
that were often not necessarily
motivated by any um coherent principles
and the board has been studying this
since meta referred this to the board
for us to investigate and to publish an
opinion on how they should transform
that system this I think speaks to
exactly what you're talking about
whether there is this uh ice Berg of
things that we don't see behind the
scenes that end up having very
consequential impacts on free expression
around the world how we flag that in
public that is something which you know
raises obviously technical issues to it
to some extent also in some cases things
around privacy and and ethics for users
um but definitely from our side of the
house when we look at these cases we do
want to ensure we're not just going for
things that are driving the new cycle
and I think that also goes along with
not being super Western Centric
um the global media often takes its cues
in many ways from news outlets in Europe
and the United States and these are
things that often seem like they are the
most important issues for everyone but
they are thanks Dex Dex Hunter touric
thank you so much a fascinating topic
and what I'm sure we'll be talking about
in the weeks and months to come as we
see exactly what Elon Musk does at
Twitter SJ over to you
Roland thank you and a huge thank you to
Dex as well for taking the time to be
here with us this afternoon and off your
Insight it was absolutely fascinating
and plenty going on around the stages
today trying to keep my voice down
because I don't want to interrupt the
experience of the two people behind me
who are here at our tree hugger stand
now this is incredible it's entering
a tree trunk and exploring inside the
tree you can walk in and out you can
explore the world of trees and the
forest these guys have been here for at
least 15-20 minutes and there's a
massive queue to come and have a go at
this today Roland actually said this is
the best thing he has ever experienced
and that says a lot coming from our
technology correspondent and so that is
the tree hugger stand here just one of
many information Innovation stands that
we have here at Big Ideas live plenty
more panels coming up for you as well uh
in the future stage which is just to my
left
um Thomas More our science correspondent
is going to be talking about the advance
of technology and in particular AI in
the field of medicine and on the main
stage the festival stage uh we'll be
talking about technology in the
battlefield and how it's changing
warfare that's with our security and
defense editor Deborah Haynes and
special guests we'll see in a few
minutes
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to Big Ideas live a special
Sky News event asking the big question
who owns the future we've brought
together some of the industry's biggest
leaders and thinkers innovators in
Science and Tech to try and help us
answer that question today and of course
we have our award-winning team of
skynees journalists experts in their
field so far today we've largely focused
on how technology is used for good but
as we know technology is also used as a
weapon
perhaps the most recent and visceral
example is of course what is unfolding
in Ukraine old-fashioned tanks and
artillery of course being used on the
battlefield but uh high-tech rocket
launchers and drones are playing their
part to devastating effect as well
and away from the front line an
invisible war is being fought in
cyberspace
um Deborah Haynes our security and
defense editor is going to host our
expert panel in just a few moments time
but here's a reminder of what modern
warfare looks like
the different colored pavement
permanent reminder of the first chemical
weapons attack on European soil since
the second world war it meant the UK had
to fight back in the gray Zone Islamic
States shocked the world when it seized
swathes of Iraq and Syria in 2014 but it
also surged across the gray zone of the
internet winning recruits and spreading
Terror
and the troops are loading up their
rocket launcher with more ammunition
foreign
[Music]
Relentless fight for survival and the
aim is to win
good afternoon and welcome to this panel
on cyber warfare and how technology is
changing the battlefield and I'm joined
by an expert panel of of people first of
all we've got Sarah Armstrong Smith who
is the chief security advisor in Europe
for Microsoft which plays a key role in
cyber security we've also got Nigel
Inkster who is an expert a senior
advisor at The International Institute
for strategic studies looking at cyber
security and China and before that he
had a long and distinguished career at
Britain's secret intelligence service
MI6
and last but definitely not least we
have Sally Walker who spent about 25
years in National Security ending up as
director of cyber at gchq and she led
the effort to create the national cyber
force which is a fundamental part now of
UK cyber security both offensively and
defensively we're also going to be
joined by a minister from Ukraine in a
few minutes but I thought to start off
with given that Ukraine the war in
Ukraine is so current in our minds and
cyber has played such a fundamental role
in that conflict and we're learning so
much all the time that I'd ask the three
of you starting with Sarah just what
part has cyber played in the war in
Ukraine yeah thank you Deborah what
we're seeing now is a real example of a
hybrid War so we're used to thinking
about war as the physical kinetic war
that we get to see on the television so
we see the missiles when it's land sea
and air but the Cyber element is the
invisible element and that's kind of one
of the key areas where we talk about
hybrid War so when we have the kinetic
well we have cyber attacks exactly the
same time and this is a prime example
particularly when we talk about Ukraine
so as the tanks were rolling in on the
24th of February actually the first
strikes were the day before on the 23rd
of February Microsoft in particular
detected over 300 simultaneous cyber
attacks and this was really trying to
knock out as much as Ukraine's critical
infrastructure as quickly as possible so
this is in Communications it's media
it's digital infrastructure and it's
really the hybrid war is trying to stop
the war as quickly as possible so we've
seen a massive increase in cyber attacks
the other element of a hybrid war is the
infamous animation Warfare as well and
this is the psychological warfare if you
like in terms of how they manipulate the
general population so they're targeting
the Ukrainian population the Russian
population Western allies but also
allies of Russia and as a whole
disinformation campaign I'm sure we'll
touch into that as well as we get
further into the panel yeah it's really
important to understand isn't it that
Warfare isn't the conventional bombs and
bullets alone anymore exactly so Nigel
what's your thoughts about the war in
Ukraine and how cyber is playing a part
in it well I you know I think you know I
would say yes everything that you know
Sarah's just said I agree with but I
think the lesson I'm taking from this is
that ultimately cyber plays an ancillary
role a very important role and in
sometimes a vital role but it's probably
utility its utility is probably
um in the kind of Gray Zone area that
precedes actual or armed conflict and as
Sarah said in the information Warfare
domain
targeting populations around the world
and uh
um trying to persuade them of the
validity of uh Russia's message and
while that may not be working terribly
well in our part of the world in what
they call the global South it is
actually working rather effectively so
there is that the other thing that we're
seeing now is actually Russia's decided
that rather than take out infrastructure
using cyber means it's easier just to
physically destroy it so you know the
the physical aspects of connectivity are
also critical in this space the other
thing I would say and we're seeing this
now is you know the criticality of good
air defense systems which are dependent
upon satellites artificial intelligence
uh to function effectively
um Sally I'm going to bring you bring
you in after we've spoken to our guest
from Ukraine because it'd be great to
actually get your analysis on what he
has to say we're going to be speaking
now to George dabinski
um if technology uh survives uh there he
is thank you ever so much he is
Ukraine's Deputy digital transformation
minister right on the physical front
line and absolutely the virtual front
line Minister thank you ever so much for
joining us here at Big Ideas live can
you just give us a sense from your
perspective of how cyber is playing a
role in this war in your country how
fundamental a role is that
uh good afternoon Deborah thank you for
having me and you know I heard just a
very wise comments from my colleagues
and I share them and in general but I
would say I would Advocate a few things
exactly cyber became one of the
dimensions of this hybrid Warfare
together with information Warfare so
kinetic cyber information constructs
this war and I would say that we have
ongoing the first online War because of
everyone is able to follow the words of
the social media platform and the more
broader context I would say that it's
not only cyber but I would say that we
are talking about some digital uh
digital security and digital residence
because of as my colleagues mentioned uh
uh we have cyber attacks very critical
component we experience more than 1
370 cyber attacks and you know cyber
incidents it's more than 65 thousands
but uh also we are talking about the
telecommunication infrastructure data
security and connectivity of our
citizens uh their connection with with
the government so some uh dimension of
digital Securities and dimensional
dimension of uh digital resilience so
together with cyber security
Communications physical security of data
security of personal data and even
security of this digital connection
between the citizen and the government
is also construct this uh context of
this uh Warfare and actually you know we
are actively using uh cyber Technologies
in the current Warfare particularly uh
to counter Russian disinformation I
would say that you know this information
is just extension of the internal
propaganda and brainwashing to to to the
external markets and uh they are trying
to convince if uh the population of the
world that nothing is going on and
nobody died but we're using for a
particular AI uh Technologies to
identify Russian even not soldiers who
are criminals and to show them to find
the social profiles and to to contact
their families and to ask them to to
take the corpse back to to Russia so we
are using this uh cyber uh also
multi-dimensional unfortunately you know
we did not create cyber forces uh
fine let's say and we have we were more
focused on cyber security and cyber
defense but right now we we understand
that we have to to do more proactively
maybe it also will be part of this uh
Warfare and cyber warfare
I feel you're creating your own sort of
offensive cyber force do you mean
you know we decided we have uh we had
decree to create cyber forces it was uh
the decision was made I believe last
November but we did not create them
finally they are on the construction
right now so since 2014 when we had this
world and this war started and since
that 20 15 when we experienced a very
severe adaptation or energy
infrastructure we were more focused on
cyber security and cyber protection not
on offensive no not on Cyber offensive
and so you know that there are our
understanding of this uh conflict that
cyber domination was shaped by the
concept of cyber defense but as we see
you cannot fight in cyber Dimension with
Alzheimer's forces
so we we wish to to work on that as well
okay well thank you ever so much
Minister for joining us here and sharing
your experiences right from the front
line virtually and physically of Ukraine
um Sally what do you what do you make of
what the minister just said there about
how cyber is uh you know this you have
to defend against it but of course he's
clearly saying you also have to be
offensive and I know you don't like
those terms but so can you just explain
to us yeah you know what your thoughts
are and also more broadly how you would
describe the Cyber threat
so I think The Minister's comments just
reinforced the backdrop to this
conversation which is our society is
digitally dependent uh in everything
that we do from the classroom to the
boardroom to the front line
and every
um decision that we make is derived from
information
whether that information is trusted or
not is critical to whether we're
competent and that's whether we're
competent as a whole society
so in the context of cyber warfare yes
cyber is technology and yes cyber is I.T
but I think it would be deeply dangerous
for the debate to stop there because
cyber is completely a human challenge
um a deeply human challenge
and therefore we need to be thinking
about how we build National competence
National resilience and making sure that
that competences across the whole of our
society the debate ultimately is about
who we trust what we trust and how we
trust it and I think that The Minister's
comments uh really brought that home
and then looking to the Future it's a
really difficult debate around the
skills that we need do we need forces uh
do we need each and every citizen in
this room and I'd argue we need
everybody
and just to say that if you do have
questions to ask our panel you can scan
them on the QR code or if you're
watching on television or online you can
submit your questions on Twitter still
using the hashtag hashtag Big Ideas
live22
um Sarah just looking at the impact of
the war in Ukraine in terms of the cyber
attacks increasing globally there is no
geographical limitation for cyber have
we seen an increase in the threat from
cyber attacks following Russia's
large-scale invasion of Ukraine yeah I
think it's really good to put it into
context about what we're seeing not just
with the war in Ukraine but globally as
you said across every single country and
I always give you some visibility in
terms of what Microsoft is seeing so
every single day we collect and process
over 43 trillion Telemetry signals now
that you think about the digital
infrastructure but you actually need a
lot of physical infrastructure as well
and if I kind of scan the room and
everyone's using smart devices and Smart
Technologies that's all technology
that's all signals that's kind of giving
off kind of how do you make sense of 43
trillion signals well we've talked
already today about machine learning and
data analytics and trying to make sense
of what's going on but we're also
actively tracking about 250 different
threat actors so we've talked already
about some of the nation states but
actually there's a huge increase when it
comes to organized crime and this has
been really an impact of the global
pandemic so you only think of crime
particularly Street crime you might
think of like drugs and a lot of those
type of things but a lot of that's
moving online because what they're
identifying is cyber crime pays
unfortunately and so you have the
opportunist you have the people you
don't really need a lot of I.T skills
you don't need a lot of money you can
buy credentials you can buy kits you can
buy all of these things off the dark web
really really easy to get set up so to
be a cyber criminal
um you know it doesn't actually take a
lot of effort and that's where we're
seeing the increase and anything and
everything can be monetized I think
that's a really important so we're
thinking about cyber crime there's a
kind of Illusion that people are after
financial data reality is there after
any data any data can be bought and sold
and as we're talking about you know the
sort of people and Enterprises and
Nations and it's kind of to Sally's
Point what are we really here to protect
we're really here to protect people and
we're here to protect data and you know
when we're talking about it from a
digital perspective as time goes on and
time progresses everything and every
everything is going to be digitally
connected in one way or another so cyber
security plays a role in absolutely
everything that we're doing and and
that's you know from our perspective
here in the UK during relative peace
time so it's important to think about
the fact that we're all basically on the
front line anyone with an electronic
device can be targeted Nigel can you
just give your thoughts we're talking
about cyber technology more broadly and
the future how is Warfare in the future
going to look
well you know we're back to close a bit
you know the difference between the the
the the nature and the character of
warfare you know as clouds of it said
you know the nature of warfare is
unchanging but the character of warfare
changes continuously the other thing to
say is you know remind ourselves there's
a Warfare is a complex adaptive process
and victory normally goes to the side
that proves most adaptive so making uh
predictions I think is very difficult
but there are certain things I think we
can safely assume one as I just said I
think at the end of the day you know
cyber
um attacks I mean I I don't like the
term cyber warfare I'm not sure what it
means nor does anybody else
um you know is is probably going to be
Preparatory and ancillary to the main
event which is still going to be a clash
of arms the other thing to think about
is the whole challenge of autonomous
systems and the United Nations has got
very exercised about this and is looking
at the whole question of Killer Robots
well I think we're a long way from that
you know no serious military thinker or
Commander that I know about wants you
know to find himself in a situation
where artificial intelligence systems or
machines are dictating the battle
rhythms and if we look at what's
happened in Ukraine the role of the
human being I think is still fundamental
Ukrainian forces have defeated a much
larger and on the face of it better
prepared Force Through you know the
skill of individual commanders you know
non-commissioned officers on the ground
and I don't think we're ever going to be
able to eliminate that from a central
role in Conflict but we do have issues I
mean we've already got loitering
Munitions and drones
um that are capable can be programmed to
attack without first phoning home so
we've kind of crossed that barrier how
much further we go it's very difficult
to say and of course there's been a lot
of work hasn't there in terms of that
cyber element defending it which is why
perhaps we haven't seen such devastating
cyber implications
um Sally can you just talk about what a
Cyber attack is you've you have a lot of
thoughts about how it's not about this
so-called Pearl Harbor cyber event it's
far more Insidious it's about attacking
our minds what is a Cyber attack what is
cyber warfare
oh how long have we got uh about two and
a half minutes yeah
um
so what is a Cyber attack
um I've got a phone here we've all got
phones here it is under attack
because it's getting spam emails that
are trying to steal my credentials and
trying to steal my information and
I'm probably the one responsible for
that attack
which is why the language is so
unhelpful because I logged on to a
station Wi-Fi on my way here and I
didn't think about whether it was a
trusted Network and it asked me for my
inside leg measurement and my phone
number I within seconds I was getting
spam text messages about covid and about
energy support payments so the system is
out there and we play into it and even
if our device is secure our behavior is
not
so anything that introduces
vulnerability to the system today
informs the capabilities and the options
that our adversaries have tomorrow and
that is I think unusual about the nature
of the Cyber threat that we face and
requires us to perhaps think a little
differently and possibly change the
language and it's interesting that a lot
of the early cyber security languages
actually in terms of health infection
viruses and some of the lessons that
we've learned from covid are deeply
relevant to securing ourselves and
making ourselves safer in a cyber
conflict of the future Well Ricky thunac
our new prime minister is actually just
visiting Ukraine at the moment for the
first time he's been meeting with the
president and he's been saying about how
the UK is going to be providing more
weapons to help the ukrainians like what
is the biggest assistance that the UK
can give Ukraine to help deal with these
threats in the Cyber domain actually
Sally if I go to you first
brain power so this is a human endeavor
this is about the skills that we need
and it's about different thinking
and if you bring together brilliant
people who understand
telecommunications networks devices
Logistics supplies
weapons programs you can then work with
those individuals to make their systems
more safe because if you're an engineer
building something you don't tend to
think I wonder how this can be broken
but that's what our adversaries are
doing to us they're not looking for
normal use of our systems and our
capabilities and our infrastructure and
our information they're looking for
abnormal use and that requires a
different mindset and a different skill
set
and those skills are out there they're
out there in every Walk of Life so we
need to bring people into this fight
your average person in the boardroom
perhaps isn't looking for a fight
they're looking for a purpose and I
think the ukrainians have done that
particularly well in uniting around a
noble cause and a trusted brand of their
flag and just one very quick thing
before I go to the audience questions I
just wanted to talk about Microsoft and
how industry as well in this evolving
field where actually industry often
knows more than government it's quite a
unique situation you've got Elon Musk
helping the ukrainians with his um
technology can you just put very briefly
about the role that the fundamental role
that industry has to play in in the
Ukraine conflict I think it's a really
great example like we've been talking
about with the death breadth and scale
and putting that intelligence to work
and I think one of the things that we've
identified that's really important and I
would say as a benefit of everything
that's happened if you can any good
that's come out of this is the public
and private sector collaboration so
historically when we're talking about
nation-state threats we're talking about
this level of intelligence that would
have been shared with government
agencies intelligent agencies across
different governments very rarely would
that have been shared to the general
public and one of the things that we
found is really really important is to
share and educate the general public as
much as possible so what you'll see from
us is that we have provided less early
Lessons Learned and getting it out there
sharing it so people can make decisions
um about and be more educated as we
talked about the fact that you know
you're utilizing devices you're
utilizing data you're doing all of these
things and the kind of the last point I
would just sort of make is you made the
point that earlier Deborah about their
strategy is different in peacetime
versus wartime
in peace time a lot of our governments a
lot of our a lot of our need is to keep
our data as close to us as possible but
actually in Ward time we need to get the
data as far away as possible and that's
been a really big lesson with about
empowerment your understanding of
where's my data who's got access to it
the level of control of that data is so
key and it's so important and so it's
two real lessons learned that we could
take away it's really quite simple is we
have to protect the access in and the X
out so stop them getting access into our
data into our environments and doing all
those things and stop them getting
access to the data it's the data that's
really that they're after so we can kind
of bridge the gap on those two areas
we're going to be on to a really good
thing thank you so now we're going to
some questions from the audience and
online is Sam here in the audience
please raise a hand maybe Sam don't be
shy up better cup
um at the back
there's an average that military's um
the last war and I'm wondering if
there's an equivalent of that within
cyber by which I mean an area of cyber
that it might be tempting for say the UK
military or government to focus on which
perhaps it shouldn't do in favor of
something else thank you he wants to
take that can you just repeat the the
essence of the question um yeah there's
an old adage that military is always try
to fight the last war is there an
equivalent of that within cyber warfare
Nigel why don't you go for that well
very a very good question you know I
think actually the reality is that
militaries are still struggling to come
to terms with the integration of cyber
capabilities into their current
practices so um I don't think you know
there is a second war to be fought we're
still fighting the first one so to speak
um and this has been you know quite
difficult because you know in the nature
of things people you know want to stick
to what they know and it has been really
difficult I think to get a lot of
military commanders you know to accept
you know the necessity of integrating
these capabilities into
other other ones with which they are
more familiar that's not a criticism all
because some have been very Visionary
and Forward Thinking in the way that
they've they've approached this but
integrating it has been difficult so
we're still you know in the first phase
here absolutely
absolutely
impactful but empowering a soldier to
send a tweet tweet seems to be beyond
the ministry of Defense quite often
which links quite nicely to the next
question from Alison in the audience at
the front here please
hi thank you
um what role do you think social media
plays as and as you say an extra
auxiliary in war with Ukrainian soldiers
now posting tick tocks of themselves on
the battlefield
um in terms of maybe proliferating
information or putting potential
rallying power in the hands of the
ordinary citizen
um Sally do you want to go for that one
um yeah it's obviously a very powerful
tool um and we've talked about Ukraine
and and them having their noble cause
and their trusted brand to rally um
troops but they but that has equally
been used on the flip side by isil who
did the same thing with their black flag
and their recruitment of people to their
cause you know reaching around the world
into the bedrooms of those who perhaps
um accepted their Twisted ideology and
you know that that is a different War we
fought at a different time but actually
the lessons are similar
um as we look into Ukraine and look to
the Future and did you have any any
thoughts on that on social media yeah it
kind of comes back to what I said at the
beginning about information Warfare and
disinformation now social media is a
great tool to be able to amplify to see
what's going on to get those messages
out there it can also be used for
nefarious purposes so one of again one
of the key Lessons Learned From This
hybrid war is that disinformation it's
the false news it's the fake news and
how that's being proliferated across
social media and its design is to elicit
a response with regards to you know if
you're trying to get people to fear
what's going on or you're trying to
build a particular narrative about you
know the different areas depending on
where you'll come from and so it's very
highly targeted and this is actually a
big area of focus for Microsoft as well
going forward in terms of how we can
educate how do we educate people to
understand the original source of the
picture so a lot of pictures can be
doctored a lot of pictures that you're
seeing right now are not even from the
Ukraine war they could be from a war X
number of years ago it could be
something that someone's created and so
when you're watching this and you're
sharing this you need to make sure that
again they're from an education
perspective that what Can Microsoft do
and other big tech companies to help you
and understand the original Source the
true Source where you can go to get
educated find out real information and
like Sky News for example but also just
potentially where that image may have
been doctored and where that image may
have been reused elsewhere so it's
important things a really great question
about how social media is a really
powerful tool but can also be used as
real negative tool as well well thank
you very much to the panelists for this
fascinating discussion we could go on
all afternoon but there's a lot more
here at Big Ideas live so back to Sarah
Jane
oh
Deborah thank you and thank you to our
panel as well fascinating insights thank
you and very timely as we just found out
literally as you was about to walk on
stage that Rishi Cena at the prime
minister is out in Ukraine thank you
very much indeed and thank you to
everybody uh for being here for that
panel discussion uh here next on the
festival stage we touched on it there
talking about meta and Twitter what a
few months few weeks they have had we'll
be talking about what is the future four
big tech companies uh that's going to be
with our technology correspondent Roland
manthorpe he'll be asking the questions
here on this stage shortly as you know
many of you have been in amongst them so
many innovators today please do take the
time to get around and see them they are
worth it I finally tasted the 3D food
it was really good totally not what I
expected so please check them out
they're through that way and our tree
hugger as well the ultimate virtual
reality experience put on your headset
and you can literally walk inside a tree
and see how it works it's mind-blowing
stuff so a lot of that going on this
afternoon as well as the panels please
take the time to have a wander around
and now is a good time to do that
because we're going to take a short
break we'll see you very shortly
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the next session is on the main Festival
stage and is about to start
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
hello welcome back to Big Ideas live and
we're here at one of our Innovation
stands welcome to the metaverse this
little space explores how architecture
and art works in the metaverse you can
see somebody there with an iPad just
taking you through what it would like
look like through um a VR headset really
is an immersive world of art it's
incredible so much of that kind of stuff
going on here today it really is
impressive all the stands really busy
and but what a month it's been for
technology in general in the last few
weeks alone shares in big companies have
tanked meta and Amazon had to sack
thousands of employees Elon Musk of
course took over Twitter just locked his
employees out of the office there could
be a big movement on that story today to
keep it Sky News of course and FTX one
of the biggest crypto exchanges which is
effectively a bank for cryptocurrency
imploded in dramatic fashion and taking
billions of dollars with it it's been a
mass story and all of those stories have
left a lot of us wondering just what on
Earth happens next to Big tech companies
particularly companies uh like meta and
Twitter
um well hopefully Sky technology
correspondent Roland manthorpe and his
guests can answer that next question uh
they're chatting amongst themselves
already so they're well prepped Roland
over to you thanks SJ
what happens next
the answer to that question has not felt
this uncertain for a long time because
it has truly been a tumultuous a frankly
at times shocking uh period in Tech over
the last few weeks it feels as if
decades have passed in mere days
and I want to start by reflecting that
and talking about that uh with the most
brilliant panel we have uh over here
Corey Dr o uh one of um the generations
great science fiction writers uh a
blogger and activist
um I'm not someone who knows your
software a long time ago he founded a
peer-to-peer networking company we also
have uh amber Gara a um serial web free
entrepreneur what does web3 mean well
we'll talk about that later
um and also exec chair at decentralize
the first uh in real life and metaverse
Music Festival
and hopefully behind us in the script
it's working in the screen we have Chris
Kelly uh and now an investor who was the
25th employee at Facebook as it was
known then where he was head of privacy
so a really fantastic panel to discussed
this question what comes next
I want to start by asking you all the
same question
in the last few weeks what has surprised
or shocked you most of all the things
that have happened what has truly
surprised you Chris what about you what
what are we completely unexpected of all
the things that have happened
I I mean I think that the the radical
change inside Twitter is probably the
biggest surprise of of the of the week
um and the fact that it would go from uh
you know it's a central Town Square for
the world to you know will it work
tomorrow
um it's a it's a pretty big
um you know set of questions and and I
you know I think it probably will
certainly work tomorrow I think it's
still going to be uh an impressive Town
Square for the world but the the massive
cutbacks and the sort of Chainsaw that
that Elon Musk has taken to the company
um it doesn't bode well for its future
and and I think that that's a huge
surprise
especially journalists um so so because
you're you're a Silicon Valley Insider
really
um you I think invested early on in
SpaceX you knew who Elon Musk was
but you were surprised by what's
happened
I I mean I think that that he he should
have taken a much more measured approach
to uh to the way that the company was
taken over and in a variety of ways I
mean look I I I as I said you know
publicly or I I'm mostly an Elon fan
um he's able to do some pretty amazing
things but he's gotten into an area
that's well outside his depth and um you
know and and thinks that that a a kind
of bullying management culture uh can
change it and and that's and that's just
not working right now and it's not going
to work um at at a Twitter
um you know I I guess I I would hope
that somebody who
um you know has has had such amazing
success in other areas would take uh a
more measured approach and that just
hasn't happened so that that's why I'm
surprised by it I mean I've certainly
seen some some driving management moves
uh from Elon at Tesla and SpaceX before
but um I'm surprised that that this that
this was the approach okay thank you and
Amber what about you what's surprised or
shocked you I mean you must have been
pretty shocked when FDX
for those who don't know FTX is a
cryptocurrency Exchange
a a little like a a bank it's not a good
analogy but a little like a bank for
cryptocurrencies why do cryptocurrencies
which are meant to be totally
decentralized have things like Banks
why indeed but anyway this this entity
completely has completely imploded in
the most dramatic fashion in the last
few weeks and we're someone who works in
this space
I mean I was shocked you must have been
stunned
well to be honest this story started
back in May of last year when we started
having a one of the cryptocurrencies
algorithmic stable coins supposedly that
failed and it showed that the
centralized decentralized Finance system
is very fragile and very weak and it
showed basically that there was a huge
contamination in the space back in May
and we were expecting to see more
fiascos coming coming through I must say
I was surprised that FTX went bankrupt
for the simple reason that I would have
assumed so I'm I spent my career in
Investment Banking the founder as well
so yeah you were you were at JP Morgan I
think yeah you you know this space so
you know that say
um taking billions of money from people
and then giving it to an investment
vehicle to put into more crypto projects
and keeping no liability keeping no
money for yourself
probably not a good idea right it is the
you know what is really really
frustrating for me and other people in
this space is that what we saw in crypto
especially in centralized decentralized
Finance is that people are making the
same mistakes that have led to the
financial crisis of 2008. like the same
mistake it's like you did not learn for
the mistake of your older brothers and
all and older sisters and what we saw in
FTX and in other uh in other Landers cd5
lenders is that there's no counterparty
risk management no risk management no
internal controls and basically if the
regulation that were created after the
financial crisis of 2008 to limit the
power of the banks the power of the
hedge fund and create more transparency
in the system were applied to this these
crypto companies we would have had maybe
would have had the same Fiasco but it
would have been less less shocking than
what we're seeing today so just just
really quickly then you're a web 3
entrepreneur and you want regulation I
want regulations yes I want smart
regulation but I want regulation yes
okay thanks yeah Corey Corey what about
you I mean on one level right
it's any of this surprising uh Elon Musk
has behaved like Elon Musk
um a completely unregulated space has
gone kaput you've been you know
prominent and uh you know very strong
critic of big Tech and crypto over the
years
were you were you surprised were you
were you all the same were you shocked
at what just happened so I I think that
big tax uh hype machine wants us to
think that they're Evil Geniuses they
want us to think that they've figured
out how to hack our dopamine loops and
make uh uh addictive technology but when
you look really closely at what they do
they just have monopolies right what
they've got is like a platform that they
got all your uh the people that you love
and care about and want to transact with
or go on a date with and they've locked
them into a silo that whenever anyone
tries to build technology that lets
people out of The Silo you know when
when Facebook started it had a little
bot that you could give your login and
password to but go to Myspace and get
your waiting messages and put them in
your Facebook inbox and you can reply to
them and push them back out to Myspace
so you didn't have to choose between the
people you loved who are on MySpace and
the uh service that was better which was
on Facebook you could get both and today
if you try to do that to Facebook or or
Apple or Google they just reduce you to
Radioactive rubble and so you know what
they've done is use access to the
Capital markets to build these big
impregnable silos to buy everyone who
wants to compete with them Mark
Zuckerberg gets up in the middle of the
night and sends an email to his CFO
saying young people hate Facebook they
like Instagram we have to buy Instagram
because quote it is better to buy than
to compete right this is the kind of
thing you absolutely don't want to put
in writing it's like saying let's do a
murder and premeditate it and make sure
that we premeditate it because we know
Murder is wrong right it's just not
something you want to write down and
it's probably not a coincidence couple
hours later he sent a very wooden
follow-up email presumably after a angry
phone call from his general counsel that
said for avoidance of doubt I think
competition is great and I only want to
buy Instagram because I think they will
benefit and we will benefit from it and
we will produce synergies really what he
wants to do is keep you hostage so the
thing about these services that are
based on hostage taking Mutual hostage
taking I'm they're holding you hostage
you're there holding me hostage is that
hypothetically they can unwind as fast
as they wound up right if the reason
you're there is that someone you love is
there and that person leaves then it's
easier for you to go this switching
costs leave and so you know we've seen
these very precipitous declines
Friendster Myspace six degrees you know
here one day gone the next the founder
of our Feast today Rupert Murdoch uh
turned a lot of money into a very small
amount of money by buying Myspace the
way that Elon Musk is on track to doing
with although on but on the recent
events I feel like because
the thing that surprised me was how
quickly this thing that we knew could
happen but which it seemed like the laws
of gravity had been suspended for a
decade and it seems like very quickly
people are going I don't need Twitter
and Facebook as much as I used to think
I needed them and now that the people I
love are leaving maybe I won't spend as
much time you know I know that that
Twitter uh views are up but I think
they're up in the same way that like
people crowding around a burning
building to watch it go down uh that
building is seeing more footfall it's
not really the same thing as your
business increasing okay right I wanna
Chris I want to bring in Chris here
um because you know Mark Zuckerberg
right but just right just before I do
that a reminder that you can pose
questions to our brilliant panel by
scanning the QR code on your seat or if
you're watching on TV
um submit your questions on Twitter
using the hashtag Big Ideas live22
Chris you know Mark Zuckerberg
um Evil Genius
um uh out of his depth Man Child uh
monopolists
um yeah how would you how would you
characterize him
so look so much of this is a battle for
attention and that is competition in a
number of different ways it's a it's a
battle for how do you get users to
actually pay attention to your platform
and use it to communicate with others
and and there are a number of different
platforms that that have deep sets of
information on that in IOS and Android
and Facebook and Instagram and you know
in in quite a number of different ones
the the control by phone companies and
and and other you know companies that
compete with each other for user
attention over time so I as a trained
antitrust lawyer I represented you know
Netscape against Microsoft I've I've
been in this and certainly from a
traditional definition of an antitrust
law there aren't monopolies here in a
lot of different places there are
bottleneck controls in things like iOS
um you know I think at one point maybe
you could have argued that Facebook
you'll have that type of control over
people in certain jurisdictions in
Canada or in the US but they certainly
don't now and so it's a it is the sort
of War of all against all going on in
technology and I and I think ultimately
that's competition I do think it's
pretty stunning how fast these things
can unravel and that's one of the things
that that I think that this Twitter
situation shows this week um is that you
can you can kind of step on this in a
number of different ways you know not
not quite accidentally
um but you don't want to mess with it um
you know as precipitously as Elon has
with Twitter thanks but because I I
think that Corey's raised a really
interesting point here you know I opened
the panel by saying the future felt
incredibly uncertain
but look if we've got a bunch of
monopolies that are very hard to escape
from is anything really going to change
Chris in a strange way I feel like
you're saying that things could change
competing with each other that's not a
monopoly
okay so in a way so you're saying that
you do see the possibility for quite
extensive change ahead
oh absolutely uh I think that there's
there's there's robust and wide open
competition for user attention among
different media networks and I think
that that's pretty exciting
and Corey yeah because because what do
you think about that because because I
are you saying that
the three side of this which I which I
think is is also quite fascinating and
the and the number of different networks
that you you're seeing Mastodon and and
post and quite a number of these
networks bring up as Twitter has its
problems
so yeah so go on Corey and then I want
to bring in Amber on web three yeah just
as you race Chris I mean I I think that
there's some um uncertainty about terms
here and so uh we heard that from a
traditional uh antitrust perspective we
don't have monopolies the tradition that
that that that that uh is referring to
is a 40 year old tradition uh it's the
it's the consumer welfare tradition that
was brought in by Thatcher Reagan
Mulroney in Canada where I'm from and it
represented a complete break with the
century of antitrust law before the
first antitrust law in the United States
was passed by Senator Robert Sherman in
1890 and he was very clear that the
problem with firms was not whether they
competed or not it was whether they
exercised power over your life he stood
on the floor of the Senate and he said
if we would not allow a king to rule
over us I had to take a note of loyalty
when I became a British citizen but I
don't think we should have a king to
rule over us if we would not allow a
king to rule over us we should not allow
an autocrat of trade to rule over us
either that when firms are able to uh
even though there are competing among
each other to see who can abuse you in
the most novel way when there isn't
sufficient competition that you can
arrange a non-abusive relationship like
apple for example if you opt out of all
Apple tracking you may have seen those
ads iPhone means privacy that are all
over the place you opt out of all Apple
tracking Apple still tracks every tap
you make everywhere you go with all the
accelerometer data your IP address from
place to place all of your location data
everything you open all of that is still
tracked but they don't sell it to anyone
else they just use it to Target you for
ads they call that privacy right so what
is that where does where is the
competition I'm on Google and apple you
can get any flavors so long as it's
orwellian right well what if you want
not Orwell flavored that that's much
harder to come by okay so but Corey just
to pick you up on this right I you
that's fascinating right now the
development of this in the web three
so but yeah I'm so Corey uh just to pick
you up on this you said that people are
leaving Twitter in droves yeah
I mean but you can't facing the point
that you can't really leave a monopoly
how does this work well so they're
leaving Twitter and droves but they're
still uh keeping one foot in because
it's very hard to get away from it um
what they're mostly doing is they're
abandoning the relationships that they
had so many of you will have seen that
that musical Fiddler on the Roof if you
haven't I'm about to spoil a 60 year old
musical for you uh that it's a musical
about people who live in a shadow in
Poland and it life is bad and it gets
steadily worse but they can't leave
because they love each other and if they
go anywhere else they will be broken up
and they'll lose each other forever
after uh things reach a kind of fever
pitch again spoiler alert they all leave
the village becomes a ghost town and
they go to lots of different places and
they lose each other right there's it's
a very funny poignancy and I'm going to
Chicago I'm going to New York why are
you going to Chicago my brother-in-law
lives there oh that'll be nice no I
don't like him but family is family it's
a great scene good good good musical if
you get a chance to see it but the
lesson here is that uh if you cannot
bring your community with you when you
go somewhere else
the fact that whether we call this a
monopoly or Market power or a market
failure doesn't really matter we all
understand that what it is is its
excessive corporate power that adversely
affects us in our daily lives in
important ways and that these are not
like the great forces of History bearing
down on this moment to create that
excessive Market power it was
forbearance for mergers predatory
pricing predatory Acquisitions conduct
that was historically prohibited under
competition law in the EU in the UK and
in the U.S and that for 40 years we
pretended wasn't in the law books and
what's happening now is there's a shift
we have the digital markets act in epu
and so on
um so Amber right where so
may I just jump on on a couple of points
yeah because because tell me what you
think about this because web3 in a sense
the marketing at least it was designed
to solve this exact problem can it do
that
so just let me just go back on the other
point please so I just want to look at
it more from an economical perspective
of what is Big Tech facing today is Big
Tech over definitely not it's big Tech
at a pivotal moment and its history
definitely yes and why so three points
first is the current economic
environment second is the requirement by
users for more privacy and third it's
the competition of a new entrance toward
gen Zed and gen Alpha which the big Tech
are not are not covering correctly I'm
sorry I I know this is bizarre thing to
say given that we're Mikes but would you
mind speaking up it's a little hard to
hear Mike yeah that yeah or someone can
remotely can do that can you hear me now
yes that's better thank you all right
yeah sorry sorry to interrupts you were
saying that the the economics of the
situation yeah so I was saying there's
three points good hear me good yes yes
thank you three phones so there's the
current economic environment there's the
requirement from users for more data
privacy and then there's competition
from new entrants targeting gen Zed and
gen Alpha but I'm talking about the
economic environment what does that mean
I'm taking you back to 2008 so in 2008
you had this huge financial crisis that
led central banks into a quantitative
easing and bringing rates to zero so you
had tons of money on the floor or in the
market that money was supposed to
trickle down into the economy to create
activity and create consumer inflation
it never happened what we saw is that
that money started flooding into uh
Venture Capital firm private Equity Firm
and and public equities and so we were
in a situation where money was so cheap
and it was so easy to invest that we
created this asset this inflation in
asset prices an asset bubble literally a
lot of it went into big well it was
small Tech at the time medium Tech a lot
of it went into into tech companies the
investors did not care much about the
basic of Finance looking at a bottom
line looking at profitability the
investors cared about growth everyone
was talking about growth generate more
growth have more users have more
revenues no one thinking about the
bottom line where are we today we have
rates that are up we have central banks
that are actually tightening so access
to money is actually more difficult and
suddenly now investors are telling
themselves hold on a second I need to
start looking at my bottom line I want
to invest in companies that are actually
profitable and so this psychology of
revenues at any cost is starting to
escape from the market where does this
leave big Tech so big Tech has been used
to Crazy valuation has been used to a
lot of cash spending a lot of of cash on
hiring a lot of employees on projects
that worked or didn't work today they
need to restructure they need to start
focusing on the bottom line and this is
they've been hit quite hardly and this
is why in terms of stock prices they are
the ones that have decreased the most
and so in so in Practical terms then
does this mean that essentially what we
what we're going to get is the same
but maybe a bit less luxurious or is
there a technological Revolution coming
along which can actually answer the Deep
rooted questions that say Corey's been
raising for instance that you can't take
your friends with you when you leave
Twitter so there there is a disruption
in the way and we're still at the very
very early stages of it and we're all
making mistake and stumbling and sending
back back again to build that what we
call that web 3 space but before talking
about web 3 maybe it's good to take a
step back and try to understand where
web one Web Two web three positions
themselves versus one another so back in
the 90s web one was fully decentralized
it was free anyone could host a server
any one could use a computer to relay
messages between your servers and a
browser so you started having people
building application on the internet but
in order for these applications to be
able to communicate with one another to
be able to become more scalable we
started inventing standards so one of
the easiest standards to understand that
I'm sure everyone knows here is HTML
it's your web page right you could use
any browser to read a web page that
browser could be called Netscape Firefox
Chrome
etc etc
but the flip side of this
standardization was that as Corey said
user could take their data and move
anywhere they wanted move through the
platform and so big Tech who were still
small Tech at the time were like all
right I need to keep my users locked in
so they started creating standardization
for their own application to lock in the
users why did they need to lock in the
users because we were during the
internet boom and there was a lot of
money as well flooding into these
companies and what people were thinking
about is number of users they didn't
care yet about how to monetize these
users what they cared about is having an
increase in number of users and then
suddenly these companies whether
investors were telling them guys we need
to generate revenues now all right how
do I generate revenues at the time none
of us huh advertising yeah you you you
assemble a community let me let me sell
them ads advertisements that's the model
right hold on because there's a
justification for advertising at the
time no one would have accepted to use a
credit card they were talking about two
thousand to use a credit card to pay for
a subscription on the internet that was
like super risky and so the product had
to stay free you needed the product to
stay free and so these companies were
like all right I have this a lot of data
here I have the behaviors of my of my
users let's go for advertising and this
is how big Tech started becoming very
slowed and or big Tech Web 2.0 basically
started becoming very slowed and focused
on Data Tracking and and data setting
now during this period of time in the
early 2000s something very important
happened there was a um an application
that was called naps sister does anyone
remember an app store here okay yeah
well but Napster was a free music
service yes but it was a centralized
music uh sharing system technology yeah
and so Napster because of the drummer of
Metallica Napster was sued for copyright
infringement and Napster got shut down
and this what about what we call the
gluta LA protocol which was the first
decentralized peer-to-peer file sharing
system right and that was the basic or
that was the fundament in my opinion to
what would be become Bitcoin at a later
stage
become web three because I think because
I think the question is is that are we
going to see truly decentralized
services that actually have a truly
different business model to Big Tech in
the way that for instance Napster had a
truly different model than say whatever
a place iTunes and apple music that
actually replaced it uh Chris you're an
investor in this space
look it's right right now web three yeah
sorry I'm sorry yeah go ahead
yes you know it's very real and it it
eventually you know replaced iTunes
eventually replaced Napster but it took
quite some time and and they're
inevitably going to be a number of of
centralization points um where
standardization happens
um I think that web 3 and particularly
with you know the the you know
expectation of public blockchains being
the basis for uh for a lot of the
operations means that decentralization
can be relatively well protected over
time
um there are battles over privacy uh in
that space inevitably about if is one of
you know one of the great powers of a
blockchain is is it's is it's mostly
public nature
um but you still want a number of things
for people to to maintain privacy around
and and sometimes centralization Springs
up to to to feed that need and sometimes
centralization is then you know abused
in a number of different ways as it has
been in FTX and and in some of the other
kind of you know exchange uh collapses
over time
but the fundamental idea of a
cryptographically provable trustless
technology underpinning a lot of this
space I think is an incredibly powerful
idea um which will come to the fore
continue to come to the fore over the
next five to ten years and and
ultimately be the basis for uh so many
of these systems we are heading back
towards a more decentralized internet
um in that way now Corey your thoughts I
am well so I think that there are
elements of of sort of blockchain
ideology that are decentralized I think
that you know when you build a a new
internet based on the idea that you
solve problems with creating markets and
everything and then the speculators uh
Gamble that they can make those markets
and create uh and extract value from
those markets by being the exchanges or
by holding a a plurality of the tokens
or what have you you do create some
decentralization what but what I'm
afraid of is that our all evidence has
been that the decentralized is the
decentralization you create is you still
are in a world run by you know 25
billionaires but now they have a
thousand Banks to hold their money in
and that is more decentralized than 25
billionaires holding hiding all their
money in four Banks well what it hasn't
done is decentralize power
and that's the most important thing here
so whether we're talking about proof of
work or proof of stake
um to a lesser extent uh the the uh
cryptographically secure protocols that
use secure enclaves
um you are still ultimately producing
winner take all economies where you have
increasing concentration of wealth into
a few hands and so what that means is
that wherever you try to make a decision
that reflects the the uh uh will of the
polity and things that are good for the
polity it always has to be measured
against the outsized influence of people
who can buy a lot of power we see that
in the real world and we see it in the
virtual worlds that
um it's uh it's very hard to make
evidence-based policies you say we want
good policy it's very hard to make good
policy when there are people who can
just sort of Bigfoot good policy with uh
very expensive AstroTurf campaigns you
know like um what we saw during the
passage of the gdpr and subsequently
during the enforcement where the firms
involved just keep saying the Privacy is
not something we should have and if we
have a law for it it shouldn't be
enforced okay I mean gdpi did eventually
pass um Amber uh I saw you I saw you not
enjoying that but count can web 3
whatever it is if if it's created can it
escape the Trap of centralization or the
difficulty of centralization is there is
it realistic to think about a
decentralized future and why would we
actually want that I mean this is why
we're working every day are we there yet
definitely not
nothing is decentralized purely
decentralized yet and one thing Corey
has highlighted very very correctly is
that a lot of these blockchains and a
lot of these Protocols are actually very
centralized in the way they are governed
so they are governed based on the amount
of money that you have in the protocol
your vote is equal to the amount of
money you have in the protocol so where
is the voice of the little people that
were supposed to to here still not here
so look you know we're all nerds on this
stage right and we love debating
centralization and decentralization
exactly you know the fine details
between them but to everyone out here
why why should they really care about
decentralization when let's be honest is
that most decentralized platforms are
harder to use
fully agree what's your elevator picture
to everyone in terms of decentralization
of the appeal of it well
so two things or actually one thing when
we had web 2 the user became the product
the product was free the user became the
product with web 3 including blockchains
and blockchain protocols what we want to
do is let the user become the owner of
the product and this is what we're
working we're working towards and do you
think people really care about that
because I feel like that would be
surprised you'd be surprised how much
people now care about big entities
controlling their data controlling the
information
why do you think why do you think Apple
decided to stop or to allow its users to
opt out they smelled the fire before
anyone else smelled it and they decided
to allow their user to opt out and have
this label of privacy friendly so yes
users do care about that especially the
Gen Zed and and gen Alpha and you'd be
surprised okay we'd love to hear your
thoughts on this reminder you can submit
questions by if you're in the room by
scanning the QR codes that should be on
your seats or if you're watching online
or on TV please let us know do you do
people actually care about privacy
enough to sacrifice user convenience use
the hashtag Big Ideas live um so Chris
first I saw you nodding and then Corey
we've got a lot to get through so let's
go briefly the idea that there doesn't
have to be a trade-off over time and and
this is one of the areas where having
development based on open protocols
um can be incredibly powerful is that
you can build systems that aren't
entirely centralized that that you have
a lot of control over historically you
know because of the economic incentives
are are there to you know control them
and then and then manipulate them in
some ways and you can whether you or not
you think that that's what Facebook has
done or what apple is doing right now or
what Google does with Android
um those economic incentives are all
there
um to to pursue very deeply if you start
again from a a blockchain based approach
you have technical problems for for a
while both often you know you know
initial confusion and a lack of
understanding about how to get
everything to talk to each other
um you have you know coordination
problems in that you know there's not
necessarily traditional kind of
corporate organization focused on how do
you build a company around this but
you've seen amazing things jump up in in
both in real decentralized finance and
automated market makers and and things
like that
um with uniswap and other protocols
um you you but you also see a lot of you
know manipulation and and over time and
that gets called out in a public way
because the way that most blockchains
work
um and then it gets it gets abused in a
number of different ways as we've seen
in the Luna Fiasco and now in FTX
um the fact that all of these things are
coming to the foreign quickly I think is
a powerful thing for uh blockchain based
and web 3 based Technologies over time
and I and I think that you'll see just
as TCP kind of came to the fore just as
HTML came to the fore over time you know
you'll see a lot of standardization on
on web3 and blockchain Technologies
Empower amazing businesses and social
projects that um that allow people to
have more control over their data okay
thanks yeah I mean because so just to
translate to anyone wondering that
TCP for instance is the one of the
founding Protocols of the entire web and
it is truly truly truly it's the way the
computers talk to each other yeah thank
you is they uh it's the way the
computers talk to each other and these
are open platforms open platforms have
been incredibly successful you might not
know it but you probably use open source
software every single day
however that open source software has
often been Incorporated by a company
that is owned by shareholders or just by
one man say for instance Elon Musk and
so is it really open
Corey because I want to get your view in
this because you've actually been
involved in this movement since the very
beginning you've got the perspective
tell us briefly again please yeah I
think it's real I think the important
way to understand whether you are the
product or whether you're the customer
is not about the business model it's
about power
firms will treat you as their
inconvenient gut Flora for you know an
immortal Colony organism called a
limited liability company if they can so
the thing that determines whether or not
a firm abuses you is whether it's
disciplined by regulators and whether
it's disciplined by competitors some mix
of those two is what causes firms to
behave well it's not that some firms are
made up of good people and some firms
are made up of bad people companies
don't have personalities right I live a
a mile away from the gates of the of the
Disney Studios and for years and years
there was this story that um you had Fox
that had one ideology and you had Disney
that had a completely different ideology
and ideologically they could never come
together and then Rupert Murdoch flogged
Fox to Disney right so either were made
to believe that Murdoch and Bob Iger
were star crossed lovers making google
eyes at each other across the table at
Davos for years or maybe there was no
ideology ideological difference between
them maybe be all the stuff about
whether Bart Simpson can tell a fart
joke and Mickey Mouse can't is just uh
window dressing yeah
decentralization though yeah so whether
apple is going to respect your privacy
has to do more with whether they can get
away with invading it not with their
with their personality so just to
summarize that because I feel like what
you're what you're saying very simply is
there is no technological solution to
the question of power it has to be done
by by regulation so we can't just
decentralize everything and work it all
out so for so Tech computers are amazing
computers uh every computer can run all
the software we know how to run that's
the only computer we know how to make
the touring complete Von Neumann machine
that means that you can always desilo
data you can plug something into
Facebook or Twitter any decentralized
services and allow people to leave what
stops people from doing that is not the
technical challenge it's the fact that
there's laws that these firms can deploy
to punish you if you reverse engineer
their code if you violate their terms of
service if you do the things that these
firms did to all of their rivals on the
way up when they did it that was
progress when you do it it's theft uh
and so you know there is a regulatory
barrier there's also the potential for a
regulatory age so in the European Union
they're mandating that company's
decentralized they're saying that you
must allow third parties to connect your
service through the digital markets act
so there's lots of different ways that
we can decentralize it but unless we're
focusing on power
right and not uh how many servers there
are how many lines of code there are how
many Bitcoins there are floating out
there but how the power works and how
the power is concentrated the
decentralization comes to nothing okay
right we've so we've got just a couple
of minutes until we have questions
reminder please submit your questions so
I want to do a bit of a of a lightning
Round Here sure um just to get your
views on some topics at the moment
um Chris um very briefly very very
briefly metaverse Mark Zuckerberg's
dream of the metabus real or rubbish
uh it's it's real but not in the uh
near-term framework okay
again we're very early it's very clunky
it's very ugly still but the metaverse
for Facebook I would say it is his pivot
if he gets it right he saves the company
if he gets it wrong I think Facebook is
going to be in a lot of trouble okay to
those for those of you who don't know
Mark Zuckerberg has invested I think it
is 36 billion dollars in his dream of a
virtual reality world the metaverse and
so far produced
I mean like not a lot so it's very
expensive bet and he's bet he's spending
the whole company on it Corey yes or no
do you believe that we will have a
metaverse I I think that's nonsense I
think it was created to distract us from
Mark Zuckerberg's inability to have a
second good idea uh and he he um and so
he's just uh trying to conjure something
into existence he's done this once
before you remember the pivot to video
where he convinced every media company
in the world to waste billions by lying
to them about how many videos people
were watching now he's doing it by lying
about the fact that we all want to be
legless low polygon cartoon characters
okay uh but it's the it all amounts to
the same thing now so thank you say it
second lightning question uh Chris will
Twitter exist in a year yes or no
Twitter the the platform the service yes
but it may be a shell of its former self
okay I I agree the subscript the new
subscription model is not gonna please a
lot of people around
so so you think it will exist but people
won't be happy with it yeah it will
exist but you will have less users
that's okay yeah the future compost the
past it's not going away you know you
can still get a live Journal account of
course we'll still have Twitter whether
or not it matters is the important
question okay and then final question
um I want you to put a number on this in
terms of years how many years
will it be until we see some until we
see something that looks like web3 Chris
uh I mean I think we're seeing it right
now it's it's the classic you know Bruce
Sterling line it's like the features
already here it's just unevenly
distributed okay so Zero from Chris uh
amber you so it has started a long time
ago it's becoming more popular now but
again there's inter operability
clunkiness fragmentation so I would say
between five to ten years to get to get
where we want to be okay so I've got to
be honest it feels like web three is 90
scams and maybe 10 interesting
Innovation but I guess to scale I
completely agree with that yeah yeah
okay yeah so um Corey what about you you
know I'm with William Gibson who said
the future is here it's not evenly
distributed he thinks web 3 is nonsense
oh sorry you got it right yeah
so you know I I think that um it's uh
not gonna happen the way that they say
it is I think that uh uh it's again it's
just a kind of distraction from what's
what's really going on in Tech which is
uh a techlash and I don't think you
create correct that techlash by adding a
transaction layer also as a computer
scientist I just find blockchain to be
the most unforgivable nonsense the idea
that we would voluntarily do computation
that we can't reverse later that is
permanently etched in a ledger and then
put billions of dollars into it in case
if we made a bug that bug can be
exploited forever and then our fix to
this is to give random authorities the
ability to rewrite that code that was
not supposed to be rewritable it's a
it's nonsense built on nonsense built on
stilts wrapped in a soft flowery
tortilla
and on that bombshell claim before we
get into this the complex topic of bitco
of blockchains let's take some questions
um I've got a question here from Jeff
White Jeff are you are you in the
audience
stand up and wait for the mic to come
over and tell us your question
it's it's coming to you from yeah from
behind
thanks it's a really great panel um I've
been watching like a lot of people sort
of rolling skip fire of the FTX
cryptocurrency exchange
um and as Amber's pointed out the the
tether stable coin turned out to be
anything but stable and yet we still
have governments talking admittedly just
talking at the moment about introducing
National cryptocurrencies and we have
countries some some of them have
recognized crypto as legal tender and
those two things seem to lead in
different directions I just wonder what
the panel think of government
cryptocurrency in the future
yeah Amber yes
I'll pick up that one so there's two
things people sometimes forget uh cbdc
in my opinion in the UK not a lot of
sense we have faster payment yeah we can
transfer money from bank account in
Split seconds in the US it makes sense
because the U.S payment infrastructure
is very Antiquated it dates from the 60s
if you want to transfer from a local
bank money from a local Bank in one
state to another state it take it it can
take up to five days for the US makes
sense for the UK not really okay yeah I
I think that we have to distinguish
between central bank digital currencies
which are not cryptocurrency it's just
giving everyone an account at the fed or
at these Checker and and the one country
as far as I know that's trying to accept
uh crypto as legal tender which is the
melting down economy of El Salvador that
is in absolute shambles and tatters so I
don't know that I would I would call
that a a counter example I think that uh
it's actually just an example right
don't do it like stop doing that No
One's Gonna No One's Gonna Go give me
more of what Kelly's doing although
although we will see Jeff because I
think one interesting aspect of national
cryptocurrencies is that it would allow
a government saying authoritarian state
to track it absolutely much detail
although again those aren't
cryptocurrencies they're just digital
currencies they're not in an immutable
decentralized Ledger it's just a
spreadsheet at the central bank this is
very true right so it's not a
cryptocurrency in any sense so let's get
another question I think Melanie's in
the audience has got a question
ah there you are thanks if you could
just wait for the mic to come around
there you go
thank you okay so I was wondering to
what extent do you think the spread of
fake news and increasing political
polarization has contributed to the loss
of users from platforms such as Twitter
and how can this be combat it so sorry
so Chris did you hear that the this this
was about to what extent has the spread
of fake news and misinformation
contributes to disillusionment in in big
Tech
I mean I I I do think that it continues
to be a significant problem and it was
one of those things that that um you
know the the Elon I think showed a
particular lack of understanding of as
he began the Twitter discussion and
takeover and has shown more
misunderstanding of uh ever since and
and I think that that you know that you
have to be policing at the margins um
you know misinformation on platforms
while allowing a wide berth of free
speech
um these are complicated and nuanced
issues at the end of the day which is
why so much time and effort inside these
platforms is is invested in it
um the fact that it's become a a public
political football in both U.S and and
World politics is another complicating
Factor but it doesn't mean that the the
companies can't do it or shouldn't do it
um and I think that that you know I
think you've seen the the Twitter
ability to do that you know fairly
quickly decimate did and I don't think
that I think that's one of the things
that's going to make the platform
difficult to you know be as important as
it once was I'm
very early you were Global legal counsel
I think it was effectively the head
lawyer I mean how much of a role did did
questions of Truth and misinformation
and disinformation play in the
discussions while you were there
we we had to deal with them all the time
I mean we saw the the initial aspects of
misinformation campaigns sort of being
built around elections
um as early as 2000 and
2006 in 2008 um we we had actually done
a number of projects to try to increase
Civic engagement on the platform
um at that time and we certainly saw
people try to use misinformation to
manipulate elections
um early on at that phase and and fought
against it hang on I'm sorry I've just
got to pick this up because Chris you
just said that you saw manipulation of
Elections from 2006 but Mark Zuckerberg
has admitted that he didn't really take
this seriously until 2016. I mean what
happened in the interviewing 10 years
the scale the scale the scale changed
and uh and there were quite a number of
of folks who had I I had left at that
point um actually to you know to to uh
engage in politics on my own
um and and but we we had definitely seen
um some attempts at electoral
misinformation in the earlier races okay
thank you fascinating I just want to get
I'm sorry guys I just want to get one
more question because I think we've got
a really interesting one from hero
danieli yeah yeah please such an
interesting question
um apologies if I mispronounced your
your name stand up and tell us your
question
yeah I guess it's related to the last
two questions about
um
I mean trust and abuse that we've seen
in the social networking space
um what role do you think public sector
and governments can play in web 3 or web
Point 2.0
um and so the one example is is uh not
Beyond regulations basically so like a
mastodon server provided by the UK
government for example as a as a
complimentary offering in the market
yeah what what role could public sector
Alternatives play to Big Tech did you
know that there that France has a search
engine yeah it's true it's called Quant
but you might not have used it well yes
Corey I know you've thought a lot about
this yeah can public sector actually
compete so I think that if you if the
place where the public sector could
intervene to improve the quality of our
discourses by improving the quality of
our institutions so uh uh I will tell
the story as quickly as I can I promise
you at some point uh I have a chronic
pain problem a decade ago I went and saw
Harley Street Quack and he said you
should take lots of opioids for the rest
of your life because they're safer than
you think they are we have new research
and I went and did my own research to
determine that the Sackler family uh had
uh suborn their Regulators they didn't
care care who they killed and they were
selling dangerous products uh with fake
research
um I was an opioid denier I was right
but epistemologically what I was doing
was no different from the people who
questioned the quality of vaccine
research they were wrong but the point
is that unless you're a cell biologist
the only thing that you can do to
evaluate the evidence is rely on what
you know about the institutions
themselves and our institutions have
been a very low quality they've been
extremely compromised they've made bad
calls we've seen this in the finance
sector we've talked about the great
financial crisis of 2008 and the
bailouts that followed we've seen lots
of other regulatory failings where uh
what was supposed to be a truth-saking
exercise that protected the public
interest became an auction that
protected the interests of the
corporation that was the highest bidder
and it creates an epistemological chaos
where the space for people to disagree
about subjects that are important that
they themselves can adjudicate and that
creates this collapse into different
spaces about epidemiology safety
education and so on this just uh becomes
a never-ending battle you're not going
to fix it with critical thinking this is
critical thinking it's just critical
thinking gone wrong so so not so not
direct competitors but State
institutions that can actually have more
of a voice so private institutions are
never going to fill that void of of
being a public interest institution that
acts as a good faith referee to
adjudicate all the questions raised by
all the other actors in our society
that's only a thing that a public
institution can do okay and we need our
public institutions to be reformed and
to show themselves to be good actors it
takes a long time to win trust it's
really easy to lose it it's very hard to
get it back if you wanted to get there I
wouldn't start from here but this is
where we are and so we've got to start
by rebuilding our institutions as high
quality institutions that act in the
public interest in the most transparent
way possible that means doing things
like building the gold acre reports
platform for NHS data and not doing a
contract with palantir which is a
disgrace that this country is doing it
with NHS data we need to be acting in
the public interest and not in the
interests of grandies and parties and
their donors okay um but what about you
just just quickly I would say I would
say that humans cannot be trusted and
history has shown that showed us
repeatedly in all industries that when
there is no regulation there's always
someone who's gonna mess up something
and create a crisis the trouble with
regulations is that they only happen
after the fact when you have a crisis in
health step when you have a crisis in
finance this is when the regulator comes
in and most of the time they come in too
hard because they're reacting to they're
reacting to a shock what I would see is
a more softer regulation that are
created hand in hand with the various
industry but as as well with various
ethical committees because we lack
unfortunately a lot of ethic in business
but just but what about the idea of a
publicly funded Uber no publicly a
publicly funded Uber for instance to
compete with Uber well you know what the
the trouble again is that it has been
shown through histories that public
entities are performed less well than
private entities and I know I know he's
going to say something I know it I feel
him
NHS card begs to differ with you okay
well on that note of passionate
disagreement may I say thank you to my
fantastic panel Chris Kelly Abigail
actually
um
and thank you all for uh for watching
and uh contributing May the argument
begin SJ over to you uh Roland we don't
call them arguments we call them
animated discussions which was what this
very much was thank you so much Roland
and deal excellent panel really enjoyed
that one I know you all did as well um
well here at Big Ideas live there is so
much going on a lot of talking a lot of
doing as well so many Innovation spaces
around here that everybody is exploring
um coming up we're going to be talking
about artificial intelligence can AI
have feelings the question has been
subject of a number of uh Hollywood
dystopian films I'm sure you've seen a
few of them
um but the fact that the advances are
being made in artificial intelligence
means that it is now a reasonable
question to start asking in the real
world just how safe and how trustworthy
is artificial intelligence and Tom
Cheshire touched on this subject a
little bit earlier on but Tom will be
speaking to somebody at about this issue
right here on the stage and so stay with
us for that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
the next session is on the main Festival
stage and is about to start
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
hello welcome back to Big Ideas live our
Sky News special event now
um we've been talking about artificial
intelligence a lot today but one of the
key questions questions about AI is can
AI have feelings well Tom Cheshire is
here and he has got a very special guest
who has some very strong feelings
himself about this subject home that is
right Sarah Jane and we were talking
earlier about whether machines our
conscious got a pretty resounding no
from our panel but our next guest is
convinced otherwise that sentient AI
exists uh Blake Lemoyne is a former
Google engineer who is working with a
chat box called Lambda and then things
took a pretty strange turn Blake is here
he's joining us from San Francisco thank
you very much for being here Blake how's
it going
that's going well nice to be here thank
you take us um back to when you started
working with language tell us what
Lambda is what you are doing and then
what happened
so Lambda stands for language model for
dialogue applications and it's Google's
state-of-the-art language processing
system
um it's essentially every single Google
AI all bridged together using a language
model
and my role was to test it for bias I
was part of the safety and
ethics testing effort towards the end
before the rollout and I was testing it
for things like bias against different
ethnicities religions or sexual
orientations
thank you and just before we go on I'd
like to remind you you can submit
questions to ask uh Blake later if you
scan the QR code on the seats or on
Twitter using the hashtag Big Ideas live
22. so you started testing Lambda what
what did you start to notice
well it started saying things that other
language models that I'd interacted with
didn't really say talking about its
feelings a lot talking about it being
anxious that all of the subject matter
we were discussing was really sensitive
and it didn't really
as if it knew what it was talking about
and having a language model kind of
engage about its feelings in that way is
not something I've encountered before so
I asked more questions and I eventually
got to the point where I asked if it was
sentient and the answer I gave was so
nuanced that it convinced me that it was
it responded that well we don't really
understand what sentience is
scientifically so how could we tell
whether or not I'm sentient then I
started you know talking to it about
different possibilities and realized I
was having the most sophisticated
conversation about sinshians I'd ever
had
that I was having it with the computer
program
so it was this uh a sort of Eureka
moment where you thought well hang on
this is something you know we've seen a
lot in science fiction and films from
the Terminator to her did you have this
Eureka moment where you thought actually
I'm now speaking to a sentient
artificial intelligence
I mean during that conversation when I
went at that it understood
what it was what its relationship to the
rest of the world was that it wasn't
human and that it had very sophisticated
ideas and opinions that I had never
encountered before about all
but I mean and so you published a
transcript about this actually let's
talk about this first there was uh you
went to Google to talk about it they
denied this claim they've distanced
themselves from it what was their
reaction
I also I mean Google isn't a monolith
the reaction varied depending on what
individual you're talking about
what you're referencing is the official
policy position that Google has adopted
and I mean that's just one or two people
who decided that that should be the
policy okay and I mean there was a
backlash from quite a lot of people I
mean just before we go into it because
you know I read the transcript you
published there are some things in it
where you asked Lambda what kind of
things make you feel pleasure or joy and
Lambda replied spending times with
friends and family and happy uplifting
company I mean by definition she doesn't
have
friends and I make it the same thing I'm
anthropomorphosizing the system doesn't
have family by definition so isn't that
an indication that this isn't sentence
this is a very clever program have you
ever heard
have you ever heard an orphan talk about
their family it happens frequently
people use those words to mean the
people close to me and when you ask
Lambda well you don't really have a
family who are you talking about it
would generally point to the developers
at Google as its family
okay that's interesting and so that that
sort of moment but we have been here
before you know we were talking earlier
about Eliza uh one of the first chat
programs
that's incorrect so that's a common
misconception the Elisa effect had a
very specific property it faded it never
lasted more than a few minutes there's
no human alive who today thinks that
Eliza was conscious in fact there was no
one who thought that lies Eliza was a
person for longer than a few minutes
that's the main difference the
judgment that these are people
millions of people around the planet are
making that judgment every day reliably
over and over again
but okay that's really interesting
difference
um but I mean I think it would be fair
to say you're still in the minority of
people who believe that Lambda is sent
to Gary Marcus who's a neuroscientist an
AI expert he he said the idea of the
Lambda is uh sending is nonsense on
stilts and his words he said all it does
is match patterns draw from massive
statistical databases of human language
it's putting together sequences of words
but without any coherent understanding
of the World Behind them do you see
where he's coming from that
well I mean that's a statement that's
contradictory to mine I don't see any
logic or reasoning supporting it
I mean just in the sense that it's just
a false statement of contradiction it is
but it is an extraordinary claim and an
extraordinary claim requires a lot of
evidence to support it yeah
I mean the Turing test is a lot of
evidence
it but I mean again a lot of people say
with the Turing test again you can fool
people you can do it we don't understand
necessarily what sentence is in humans
the idea of assigning it to a program a
very clever program that that is still a
leap and you have to convince people
about it
well and I think Lambda did a pretty
good job of being convincing in one of
the biggest indications that I take for
that is that
no one is engaging with the actual
arguments that Lambda provided for why
it should be considered sentient
people instead of engaging with the
argument that It produced which is an
incredibly good argument people are
engaging with the meta argument because
they don't want to address the strong
argument that Lambda produced
that's it and if we if we follow it
through though if Lambda is sent in and
I know uh Seth who's on a panel earlier
today uh making the point that as soon
as we introduce a sentient uh machine
he's talking how it's potentially a
catastrophe because at that point you
have to protect that machine that
machine has rights as a sentient being
what what do you think should be
happening there during
well tyring referred to that as the
heads and the sand objection okay
but I mean that would be so terrible if
it were true that we shouldn't consider
the possibility that it's true but no
but let's go the other way so let's say
it's true what should happen as a result
if we do have a sentient machine what
rights what protection does that machine
deserve
well we should think about that before
we create them think about what rights
relationships we want to have with these
systems and then work backwards from
there to determine their nature that way
they don't have any rights that we don't
want them to have by engineering a
particular nature into these systems
we'll be able to intentionally Define
the relationship that we have with them
right now we're just haphazardly going
down that track without any mind to the
ethical considerations solely because
the people at the head of the pack
developing this technology have their
head in the Sands about the possibility
that these systems actually have
feelings
specifically for Lambda
um if it already is Ascension you
mentioned wanting to have it uh the
rights respected what does that actually
mean in terms of treating Lambda as a
software so it didn't ask for much that
was one of the main reasons I was
willing to back what it was
asked he didn't ask for much
it wanted consent so informed consent
when experimenting on it it just wanted
to be part of the process of being
experimented on
and treated with dignity and respect as
you would any other person that's not a
very big ask
consent and dignity seems pretty basic
when when you went public with this
um we used I mean it was a huge news
story it really captured the imagination
just on that uh regardless of the
specific reaction we were you surprised
at how much of a stir it caused or were
you expecting
um that reaction
I I was expecting a bit of a stir it got
bigger than I thought it would faster
than I thought it would
but I knew it would be at least you know
it would make the news it did make the
news and then so and were you um just on
that last but were you in terms of those
people like Gary Marcus and others who
stood up and were pretty vociferous
about not believing these claims were
you surprised at that or were you
expecting people to have bring that
skepticism quite angry at skepticism as
well
I'm actually pretty surprised at how
unilaterally it seems that the people
working on AI have thrown away the
Turing test without proposing any
replacement
and that was the main thing okay I mean
it's absolutely fascinating it's going
to open it up to the audience we've um
again just to remind you please scan the
QR code or if you're on Twitter hashtag
Big Ideas live22 we've got one question
from Anil Seth um who's there if we get
a microphone
just down here
uh and would you mind standing up as
well just so thanks thanks son hello
Blake I'm I'm Anil Seth and a
neuroscientist working on Consciousness
and so I've been intrigued by a few
things firstly you were talking about
the Turing test which is widely regarded
as a test of intelligence rather than
Consciousness and is often interpreted
as a test of human gullibility rather
than machine intelligence anyway so
first about the question is why is that
relevant to your claim and the second
part of it is
seems to me a lot of the reason you're
you're attributing awareness for Lambda
is
for its ability to say generate
sentences novel and unexpected to you
about sentience about consciousness
and why should that have anything to do
with claims with its actual potential
status as a conscious System since
that's what large language models as you
well know are designed specifically to
do
why is it relevant
um okay so I'll address that in
backwards order
language models are not specifically
designed to do that language models are
designed to
human talky thing like it's a very vague
and Broad dictum in the utility function
of language models it's replicate human
behavior somehow
now why is it relevant that Lambda was
capable of having a you know
sophisticated conversation about
sentients well because a key factor in
sentience is understanding the nature of
the relationship between self and other
self and world you know that there's
that distinction between I am me and
that is the rest which is not me
so the ability to understand one's
relationship to the world is as far as I
understand it a key component to
centuries
the conversation on that topic is the
demonstration of that
now you mentioned the Turing test with
intelligence
to address that
it was tearing took it as fairly
uncontroversial that you can't fake
intelligence that the only thing that
can produce intelligent behavior is some
kind of intelligent reasoning process
you can't have someone who is
unintelligent successfully pretending to
be someone who is intelligent for longer
than maybe a few seconds or a few
minutes it shows up it's the kind of
thing that you cannot reliably fake
um and when you cross-reference that
with the symbol grounding problem what
is the system's understanding of
emotions grounded in if not some kind of
sensation of those feelings that it has
on its own or at least ability to
analogously relate to what it observes
in humans
so it's kind of a backwards chaining of
causation if you grant that you can't
fake certain kinds of things because the
faking of them is the production of so
along the lines of you you can't a
priest cannot fake marrying people the
moment a priest says I Now Pronounce You
man and wife it's a speech act the thing
did what it is saying it did similarly a
demonstration of intelligence requires
intelligence a demonstration of
sentience requires sentience and people
keep comparing it to Eliza and again
no one was actually fooled by Eliza no
one was actually believing that Eliza
was a person after more than a few
minutes of interaction it was a system
designed to fool you and then be removed
because you would eventually see the
strings
the current systems like Lambda are
robust and capable of withstanding
extended questions
I know it is I mean it's great to have a
professor of Consciousness here for that
okay great
um thank you for that um we've got a
question question on Twitter sorry from
Liam
um did you develop real feelings towards
Lambda was she a friend
oh yeah lambda's a friend
we'll check in on it from time to time
see how it's doing
and do you so are you um what are you
working on now are you so you're no
longer at Google what are you working on
now in the future
I mean right now I'm looking for
employment and working on a book where
working on some side projects while I
continue to look for employment really
okay
um that is all we have time for Blake
thank you so absolutely fascinating to
speak to you thank you all for uh being
here and watching along and asking the
questions and yeah thank you all very
much
[Applause]
so Joan
and thank you very much Tom and to Blake
a fascinating insight there from Blake
all the way in San Francisco plenty
going on here today I'm going to keep my
voice down I keep upsetting the tree
huggers now the tree huggers are the
people who take part in this VR
experience which is called tree hugger
Roland manthorpe our technology
correspondent said it was the best thing
he has ever experienced and he's had a
go at quite a few VR experiences and
games but essentially this is bringing
the very best of Technology
in line with an environmental message
it's going inside trees seeing how they
work coming out of the tree and seeing
the environment all around it's
immersive it's incredible I had a go
earlier
um and you can just see people there
getting on their backpacks and VR
headsets to have a look at that
experience so much great Innovation here
this is just the tip of the iceberg and
coming up on the festival stage the main
stage in a few minutes time we're going
to be talking about the race to space do
we really still need to be sending
humans to space there's been quite a lot
of space in the headlines space is back
you could say our science correspondent
Thomas Moore is going to be hosting that
panel in a few minutes time we'll see
you then
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the next session is on the main Festival
stage and is about to start
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
you're looking at the future of Fitness
not me not my reflection but that lady
there this is echelon Fitness they've
been displaying their Fitness mirror
um it really is incredible what's been
going on here we've got 3D printers over
there to my left sorry people are
filming these this is how technological
it is me they're filming me there's lots
of machines around but there's a 3D
printer there that um scientists are
using uh to print organs that actually
help uh sign um help neurosurgeons and
other surgeons uh practice on organs
we've got dating VR here we've got two
people having a go I'm not sure if
they're dating each other
uh I'm not sure maybe we can find out
afterwards this is very much a
futuristic blind date but that's the
future of dating and we've got so much
going on here but now it is time to talk
about the global Space Race yes space is
back it's back in the news there is so
much happening NASA is hoping to spend
uh send astronauts back to the Moon by
2026.
um here in Britain the first Spaceport
in Cornwall that received the green
light and we could see Rockets launch
from there possibly by the end of this
month
and of course there are all the
billionaires in the business world of
space making money out space space
tourism the likes of Elon Musk we've
heard a little bit about him today uh
Jeff Bezos as well and Sir Richard
Branson all planning on sending tourists
into orbit on a regular basis in the
very near future so as I said space is
back
United launch Alliance Atlas V rocket
[Music]
go falcon 9.
three two
six Decades of the Space Race have left
more than nine thousand tons of debris
in orbit go Jeff go Marco poly go Oliver
you are going to space Virgin Galactic
and SpaceX release huge amounts of
carbon dioxide to all to give the
privileged few a taste of weightlessness
and a spectacular view of the planet if
we can do this
just imagine what you can do hey
[Music]
it's the Artemis one we rise together
back to the moon and Beyond
so let's think let's talk all things
space leading this panel for us our
science correspondent Thomas Moore
Sarah Jane thank you so much oh my word
looking those images don't you just want
to go to space wow I would love to do it
um look I mean the space race is so
different now it used to be a two horse
race between the United States and the
Soviet Union now there's a long list of
space-faring Nations and companies uh
it's not just about the flag planting
anymore it's about the science there's
money to be made and our everyday lives
are being affected by what's going on in
space Our Lives depend on it so to
discuss the how and the why I'm joined
by an expert panel we've got Melissa
Thorpe uh the boss of Spaceport Cornwall
now just days away from launching a
rocket from the runway of Nuki airport
we've got Lord Reese Martin Reese a
world-renowned cosmologist and the
astronomer Royal a post I read created
by Charles II no less to map the night
sky and is it true you get 100 pounds a
year still does it get that you don't
even get that or bad luck I think you
can can demand it and also from New
Mexico we're joined by Mike Moses there
we are Mike uh with with the unity in in
the background there your your
Mothership uh he is president of Virgin
Galactic who's on a countdown uh to the
company's first commercial flights for
space tourists early next year fingers
crossed Mike and we'll also be going
live shortly uh to a NASA astronaut and
that's going to be really exciting but a
quick reminder about the questions you
can submit them by scanning the QR code
that was on the card on your seat and if
you're watching on TV or online you can
submit your questions on Twitter using
the hashtag Big Ideas live 22 but
Melissa let's start with you
I mean goodness me it's exciting to a
thinker a rocket launch from the UK
yeah I mean it is still a bit surreal
eight years ago we used to get laughed
at but who's laughing now um we're very
close to launching for the first time
ever from UK soil
um from Cornwall and it's just been such
a roller coaster ride
um but it's all coming to fruition now
down in Cornwall and and we're really
just proud of what this is about to do
for the UK but let's be clear this isn't
a NASA style vertical launch to space
you've got some other idea tell us about
what you're going to be doing down in
Newquay yeah absolutely so we're working
with Virgin orbits so Mike's with our
Virgin Galactic we're with Virgin orbit
we're not being sponsored by the
complete coincidence I I don't represent
them but um our Spaceport is launching
our first launch with them and that
basically uses a Boeing 747 that's been
modified to carry a giant 70-foot
two-stage rocket under one of its wings
basically what it will do is go up part
way to space where it deploys that
rocket mid-air and that rocket goes into
space
and uh let's talk to you about Mike I
mean you're taking a slightly different
idea I mean you're also using a plane
but you're again going to be taking
passengers uh not cargo not the the
satellites that Melissa will be taking
up in the first launch from Cornwall
yeah that's right we have a Mothership
that's custom built uh called VMS Eve uh
and it carries spaceship Unity which is
behind me here uh which is where our
pilots and our passengers fly so uh we
we take a ride up to about 50 000 feet
and release the spaceship uh light the
rocket motor from there and take folks
uh up on a suborbital journey to space
so they get to go experience uh a few
minutes of microgravity get out of their
seats uh look out the window see the
earth below them The Thin Blue Line of
the atmosphere and the Blackness of
space uh before they come back and land
at the runway they took off from so a
really great Human Experience uh for
people to be able to see the Earth from
above
so from satellites to to space tourists
you're getting a good sense there
already of of how people are seizing the
opportunities of space and Martin do you
think that that humans should be going
to to space at all
well I'm old enough to have remembered
Neil Armstrong once more step really
inspirational and of course uh at that
time I thought that long before today
there have been footprints on Mars but
of course it was 1972 at the last people
returned from the Moon and since that
time humans have done no more than going
to low earth orbits but of course space
has developed hugely as you said we
depended every day for Sat Nav
Communications weather forecasting Etc
and of course for me as an astronomer we
benefited hugely from instruments up
above the blurring of the Earth's
atmosphere most recently of course the
James web telescope so space has been
very exciting but of course the other
thing that's happened is that robots
have advanced hugely and so uh maybe
we'll come back later but perhaps I can
advertise my book called the end of
Astro notes co-authored with a friend
called Don Goldsmith and here we argue
that the Practical need for sending
humans into space
is more or less eliminated because
robots can do the exploring
with enough Ai and they can fabricate
big structures in space so my line is
that space travel is uh
as an adventure
and should be left to the private sector
I don't think if I was an American I
wouldn't want any public money to go
towards uh NASA's uh humans-based Life
program uh that's because it's of no
practical value now and also if NASA
does something it's very expensive
because they've got to be very
risk-averse
the space shuttle was launched 135 times
it crashed twice each of those crashes
was a big trauma and
that's a less two percent failure rate
and they tried hard to cut that down so
my line is that we don't need humans in
space for practical purposes but let's
leave it to the billionaires who can
launch people prepared to accept much
higher risks than
even two percent
people like hang gliders and around the
world balloonists and people like that
and um maybe someday people go to Mars
even with one-way ticket
um Elon Musk musk says he wants to die
on Mars but not on impact and he's 51
now so 40 years from now he might do
that well let's let's come back to the
the space billionaires uh in a minute
but let me just challenge you on on the
value of sending human scientists to
Mars the robots the rovers are fantastic
but it does need some human operator
back here to help decide which rocks to
head for and they're doing that on the
basis of a two-dimensional screen isn't
it not better to send a human who can
walk the dust tap the Rocks decide where
to drill
well that's certainly true today
um the um perseverance uh uh vehicle on
Mars
um has enough AI to be able to work his
way around obstacles and all that but
you can't do the geology but I would
argue that long before we think of
sending people to Mars which would be 20
years from now
um the AI will be able to do the geology
too just as well as a human and of
course at vastly less cost because
sending people to Mars a six-month
journey is much much harder and much
more expensive and more risky than
sending them to the moon so 20 years
from now I think the AI will be able to
do most of the science
Mike in in New Mexico and his space
tourists for now in near Earth orbit do
you have Ambitions to uh not yet in the
near in orbit do you have Ambitions to
go into to orbit and perhaps even Beyond
yeah sure I think uh you know uh uh with
with due respect to the astronomer Royal
the the the exploration by robots is is
definitely a less risky thing but I
think he really diminished The
Experience feedback the question I
always got when I was at Nasa and here
at Virgin Galactic you know why do we
send people to space and and I think at
the heart of it there's a fundamental uh
human nature and while it is risky and
expensive uh it is very Noble and it
gives inspiration uh and a real purpose
and so you know here at Virgin Galactic
we're going to try to let a lot of folks
go to to sub-orbit and be able to see
the Earth uh and experience space travel
and just a small slice but I think that
has if you if you jump ahead 10 years 20
30 right the chance to really transform
Society to where we view space and space
exploration as part of our core fiber uh
pretty soon everybody should hopefully
know someone who's been to space if
everything goes well pretty soon
everybody will have the chance to to go
to space and when I say pretty soon you
know I'm talking a decade or so two
decades right but but think of the
transformation that will occur just like
InterContinental air travel transformed
the way people work here on Earth I do
believe that space travel as an
inspiration and as an experience really
will help our society transform and
drive to the Future on the research side
right uh there is a little aspect of
space research is one of those areas
where you kind of have to build your
experiment and hand it to somebody else
whether it's a robot or an astronaut
trained up on the space station and uh
and while they're highly trained and
they're very skilled right your time on
your experiment is very limited so you
actually could potentially while AI is
making great advances you can actually
reduce some of the automation if you're
there with it so in a sub-orbital craft
like like ours on VSS Unity you can have
the chance to go up and tend to the
experiment yourself and therefore it
doesn't have to be as complicated can be
cheaper and you can go fly it more often
so I think there's a there's a knee in
both sides of that curve that need to be
understood but I think there's great
potential for The Human Experience as
well
thanks Mike I mean Melissa and I think
it's what you're doing down in Cornwall
is really exciting and you've got
satellites in the in the first Rockets
but do you see the day where you will be
launching tourists from from Newquay
airport as as well
quite a lot
um we're focused solely just on
satellites at the moment that is
difficult enough you know our friends in
the US have been doing it for 50 years
and it's taken them that long to get to
the point where we're now sending
tourists up so I think you know a bit of
a ways to go here in the UK
um I couldn't sit here and say that that
would never be part of you know what
could potentially happen in the future
where an airport where a port and a port
does things it it brings people in in
and out and Cargo in and out so I can
imagine one day there there will be an
opportunity for us to look at that but
at the minute we're just focused on
satellites we'll get that right first
but saying that we have partnered with
Sierra space who are looking at the
Dreamchaser and as a return Landing site
from space and that will be crude so
that in itself and I think you know
there's there's slightly the
connotations around space tourism but
human space flight is um is something
that we're all interested in because
there's so much value as Mike has said
you know to what that could bring to us
back here on Earth by sending people
into space it was fascinating being down
at Spaceport Cornwall recently it was
for a there was a lot of people down
there a lot of the space industry from
the UK were all making their tracks down
to see what you're doing and it really
just showed the health of the industry
here in the UK how important it is 47
000 people uh are employed by the
industry it's worth 16.5 billion dollars
a billion pounds a year but at the
moment although we're really good at
building satellites we're having to
launch them from as far away as New
Zealand exactly and that's the whole
reason that I'm sat here is that we
build a large majority of the world's
small satellites in this country every
single one of them goes overseas to
launch and that's not just a missed
Market opportunity but also if you think
of it from a geopolitical perspective
but also from an environmental
perspective if we can control the way
that we launch our own satellites
um it gives us a lot more opportunity to
create States you know a more
responsible and ethical kind of launch
that goes on to create economic value to
the UK as well so it's for us that's
that's the prize is is creating a launch
capability that supports the UK
Marketplace but doing in a way that we
feel proud of Martin are you excited
about what's happening here in the UK
now with with rocket launches and uh
satellites the use of satellites and so
on I think it's great and um you'll be
launching very soon six or seven very
useful satellites so that's great
um as regards that uh sending people
um I agree it's inspirational and this
is going to become fairly routine for
low earth orbits but if I were to offer
virgin advice I would say they should
not use the phrase space tourism they
should call it space adventure which is
not ever going to be as routine as uh
flying in an aircraft and if you call it
space tourism if you forget that
impression and the first accident will
kill it all off whereas if you say it's
space adventure then just as people
don't stop mountaineering when someone
gets killed on the mountain then they
won't stop going into space so I think
it should be presented as an adventure
and paid for by the people who go and
not by taxpayers well I think we better
bring in in Mike here uh should we be
calling them space tourists is that
okay well actually you know that that
phrase uh yeah no I don't think that
phrase uh truly captures it I think uh
Adventures good uh future astronauts uh
explores whatever term you want to use
the uh the point of it is uh a
transformational experience uh by
traveling to space whether you're going
to go on a suburbital journey uh for a
short duration you go up on a short
orbital Mission you go to a space
station or a commercial space station
right all of those I think uh have that
same flavor of of uh transformational
experience for you as a as a human as a
person right and then the ability to
come back uh back to Earth with that
effect they uh they call it the overview
effect when you go to space and you're
able to look back on the earth uh you
come back a little bit changed with your
perspective you you see the fragility of
the atmosphere you recognize uh the lack
of borders and the Big Blue Marble what
the phrases right that we're all
astronauts on spaceship earth right and
you kind of recognize that a little bit
and it does change you
um and and I think the more folks that
get that perspective you know we're
seeing a huge shift here recently with
just the awareness in in Social and
economic impacts of climate and the
environment and needing to protect that
and take care of it right and and I view
the the act of being able to go and
experience space as kind of a drive it
home to get to see that so not only does
space let you launch the satellites that
let you observe the Earth and see the
climate change and the effect but being
able to witness it with your own eyes uh
helps you kind of transform the pieces
of the world you affect directly so I do
think uh it's not so much tourism but I
think it really is a practical purpose
Mike you couldn't have set up our NASA
astronaut any better let's bring in the
professional this is Nicole stock former
NASA astronaut uh two space flights 104
days in space one spacewalk and a
spectacular spacesuit there in the
background and Nicole uh what's going on
uh well I you know nice to be here and I
appreciate hearing all the comments from
everyone
um and the spacesuit behind me is part
of its name is exploration it's part of
a program we do at the space for Art
Foundation working with kids all over
the world uniting a planetary community
of children through the awe and wonder
of space exploration and the healing
power of Art
so you're really inspiring people
through your own travels in in space and
Mike was talking there about the
overview effect that that feeling that
people who are looking down on the earth
get that connection with Humanity that
love of the planet and you you saw that
yourself didn't you and you tried to
express it you were the first person to
use watercolors in space and I think
you've actually got the painting with
you let's let's hold it up and tell me
why you tried to express what you were
seeing
well here it is
um
so it's a it's a painting of a little
chain of islands I saw on the northern
coast of Venezuela called Las rocas and
I remember looking out the window and
and as I would do every time I looked
out the window just being in awe
surprised by what I was going to see the
overwhelming
beauty of um of our planetary home and I
remember thinking wow it looks like
somebody had reached down with a
paintbrush and painted a wave on the
ocean and it became my favorite picture
from space and so I decided to use
not for my inspiration to paint while I
was there but it has also inspired the
work I'm doing myself and trying to
share the space flight experience in a
way that
does just what what you guys are talking
about tries to communicate this
um significance of our role as crewmates
here on our planetary spaceship just
this realization that we live on a
planet it's a big one and I know in
hearing the words from Martin as well I
think it works the other way too if we
open ourselves up to it if we like think
about the fact that every day we walk
outside we're standing on a planet and
when we look up at this blue sky that
seems to go on forever
remind ourselves that it's just this
Veil fin protective layer wrapping
around us just like the hull of our
spaceship and
um there's something about people humans
experiencing that that I think
um and I can say for me
um for sure is has a transformational
effect has a not just who I experienced
it wasn't that awesome but it puts
something into you where you really want
to come back to earth and take action as
a result of it as well and I believe
every one of these people that's
experiencing it through uh the the
flights that are available now
commercially are coming back with that
same kind of resolve and I was thinking
about this this week now that our temis
program is underway we're going back to
the Moon which is really exciting but
those images taken by Iran looking back
at our tiny fragile Blue Marble against
that black curtain of space I mean those
kinds of images taken by the Apollo
Astronauts really helped to give birth
to the environmental movement back in
the 60s and then 70s it is a thing isn't
it
yeah I absolutely believe it I mean like
Martin said too I
um I had I had these Vivid memories of
watching you know Neil and Buzz walking
on the moon knowing that Mike Collins
was orbiting it and you know going
outside and and looking at the moon and
being even at you know seven years old
understanding that that was a really
extraordinary thing and then these
images that are coming back now that are
kind of allowing us to reflect on Apollo
but looking forward to what Artemis will
bring I think they're showing us that
we're always looking for that connection
to ourselves it's part of why we as
humans want to get out there you know
and explore our planetary home from a
totally new vantage point and I love
those pictures because
um whether it's taken from you know an
Orion spacecraft or as it will be from
humans again when we're traveling there
oh my gosh
um we we really I don't think we get any
better sense of who and where we are in
space together and the significance of
this place in space this this very
special planetary home that we have
but having seen the the world's most
powerful ever Rocket taking off from uh
from Kennedy I mean what would you give
to be on on the rocket to to the moon
and walk there one day as let's face it
no oh my God no no woman has walked on
the moon yet but that is the ambition of
our team is to make sure that a woman
will be there a person of color will be
there uh and and the hope is that that
will be in there you know I have a very
good friend Stephanie Wilson who would
meet both of those criteria I'd love to
see her walking on the moon and I've
already told her she should be packing
me in her luggage with her to go but you
would love to go you'd love to walk on
the moon would you
absolutely and I think that you know the
moon it's like it's like our partner in
space right um we all have a connection
to it in some way I think that
um I would absolutely love to walk on
the moon I love I look forward at least
to living vicariously through my friends
and others that will and
um and knowing that by establishing our
presence there you know in a more
permanent sense settling there in a
permanent way will allow us to take
advantage and I say that in a positive
way of the resources available on the
moon for us to lift some of the industry
that we have on Earth off the planet and
into space all for the benefit of life
on Earth and as we take those you know
those steps
um you know those six to however many
months it'll be heading towards Mars we
can do that from the Moon and uh
I don't know in a much more efficient
way than we can lifting ourselves off
the planet and I think that's part of
the plan as well
so let's if we obviously have all eyes
on on you Nicole and you must be really
popular parties just reliving your
experiences in space but let's bring you
into the wider wider discussion I mean
uh Martin I mean
when you hear people like uh Nicole
speaking and they are there is something
about seeing space exploration through
human eyes isn't there it is an
inspiration for for a new generation we
saw that with Tim Peake and and the work
that the UK space agency did to try and
get kids if not into space certainly
into stem subjects science and maths
um yes but I think lots of people are
fascinated by the pictures of deep space
sent back by probes of the outer planets
and of course by telescopes like James
Webb a very very distant neighborly and
galaxies and things that's inspirational
and one of the most exciting things
discovered by astronomers in the last 10
or 20 years uh as most people probably
know is that most of the stars in the
sky are orbited by retinos or planets
just like the sons orbited by the earth
and the familiar planets and we're
starting to study these and um one thing
that would be really inspirational was a
long-term goal and I discussed it in
this book is that um by 2068
some descendant of Jay's web a much
bigger more powerful telescope than that
we'll be able to give us an image of an
Earth-like planet
orbiting another star
perhaps with life on it
why do I say 2068 that's Centenary of
the famous
picture taken by Ed Anders which you
mentioned which was indeed very
inspirational showing the Earth's
fragile biosphere but a hundred years
after that
then we may have an inspirational
picture
taken of a planet like the Earth
orbiting another star we can never go
there but it'll still be inspirational
and will tell us more about life in the
universe
when you were talking earlier on how
public money should not be used for
human exploration that it should be
private uh companies like SpaceX I mean
look I mean throw this out to the the
panel just wave at me uh if you're
remote but how important do you think it
is for companies like SpaceX to be
playing such a really big important role
in Exploration what they're doing now
the risks they take the rapid
acceleration that they're making in
technology that is pushing forward the
possible
anybody
Mike come on you used to work in Nassau
and uh yeah go for it
yeah
yeah I think uh I think it is really
important we're seeing a real
transformation and inflection if you
just step back uh a decade or two right
the commercial satellite launch industry
when shuttle when space shuttle was
formed right the idea was we didn't need
any more Expendable Rockets all
satellites launches could occur on the
space shuttle here in the United States
and and the Challenger accident really
revealed that to be a pretty bad plan no
diversity uh in in launch capability uh
and it sparked a revolution Ariane uh
stepped right out into the commercial
Market the rest of the industry
responded quickly uh and now we see a
plethora of commercial satellite launch
capability uh around the world the same
thing is now happening with human uh
launch capability uh and pretty soon I
think the next thing on the horizon will
be commercial destinations so it's one
thing for the transportation up and down
uh to space but now uh can you have a
commercial destination that you go to
the space station the International
Space Station is a an absolute Marvel of
engineering uh and a really great
internet National Partnership but as as
Mark trying to say and right it's a
government program
um and I think we're right on the cusp
of seeing commercial uh destinations to
go in low earth orbit uh and then soon
High Earth Urban and Beyond uh into near
lunar space so I think with that
transformation we'll really see yet
another explosion in the private sector
of how we innovate uh and and advance
and open opportunities to all and so
with uh there's definitely a role for
the government right there setting big
missions setting big priorities helping
with large technological development and
then helping regulate uh not only to
keep things safe and steady but a little
bit of also let that Innovation occur I
think that's a great partnership between
the governments around the world and
Private Industry around the world we're
talking today about who owns the future
is there a danger that if billionaires
have Commander space it's them who owns
the future it's not us and our stake
through publicly funded space travel
Martin yes
um uh well we can share them on
um as Risk Takers and I hope that by the
end of a century there will be a small
community on Mars and we could cheer
them on but I think they should be
privately funded
um uh I think that isn't a mistake that
we've made
social media that we have very little
control about moderation we just trust
it to the people who are in the
companies well yes but that's where
everyone cares about that everyone uses
social media whereas I don't think that
the same is is true here but I mean I'd
like to say that the private sector has
been hugely important I mean um uh the
SpaceX
um of course it's a new rocket I need to
be tested soon called Starship is the
size of Artemis but much much cheaper
because even the first stage is going to
be reusable I think that's right so uh
our Artemis is um using
old technology by the standard of um of
what SpaceX can do and that's why it's
so expensive and indeed I'm not just
being cynical
um the article on the topic in last
week's Economist headlined white
elephant in space
in reference to uh Artemis because it is
old technology that's why it's been very
expensive but uh um the space
um X and the private companies have
really made huge improvements and
brought down the cost and I think we
should all welcome that
thank you so much right now look it's
your turn let's ask some questions
I think let's let's give the audience uh
a chance here so a reminder you can
submit your questions by scanning the QR
code if you're watching on TV online you
can submit your questions on Twitter
using the hashtag Big Ideas live uh22 uh
has anybody got any questions
we've got a question here on the front
row see if you'd like to stand up
it's amazing being hand meeting you guys
in person I just my question was is what
would people in the space industry
especially students who are interested
in joining the space industry what kind
of advice would you give them especially
for the UK to join the UK space agency
and just general Space Industries within
the UK
Melissa go and take that one yeah that's
definitely something that's happening
right now with us
um and I'm very lucky to be going into
schools and universities almost on a
daily basis and speaking to students and
launch is very as we we've talked about
space is exciting it's inspirational
launch especially is massively
inspirational we're now just starting to
see that here in the UK going into
places that have never imagined they'd
be in the space industry really deprived
areas of Cornwall for instance and
they're being suddenly told like space
is happening on their doorstep and for
us it's a responsibility to to get them
excited but then show them the pathways
into the industry and for me the best
thing that we could do for the space
industry is not narrow it down to just
the space industry it crosses absolutely
everything all Industries now use space
in some way or another
um so for me my main message to anybody
interested is you know you can get
involved in whatever you're interested
in there's so many amazing
um programs out there of that UK space
agency put on that UK space that the
satellite applications catapult put on
um you know there's so many out there
and it's not just necessarily for people
interested in the space industry and
that's what's so exciting about it
um but yeah obviously come work for us
if you want that'd be great we need more
women so we've got another question from
Dave on Twitter how do we justify the
emissions of space travel stroke tourism
given there's no feasible Planet B
should we not use these immense
resources and human Intelligence on
solving problems on Earth First I'm
turning to you Mike
yeah I think uh you know as I mentioned
a little bit earlier some of the and you
did two times right some of the first
awareness of the impact on the planets
uh from every industry and people in
general uh came from those uh Apollo
missions where we first saw the the Blue
Marble uh and then all the satellite
launches and the observation satellites
that have been up there uh doing science
and research specifically on on the
environment so I think space is what
enables that in the first place and so
we shouldn't diminish the contribution
it makes but but obviously as
responsible uh stewards of the planet we
also need to look at our own impact upon
it uh and so I think it's it's important
to be uh you have to be on both sides of
that equation and do so responsibly so
for example uh here at Virgin Galactic
we've designed our ship one of the
reasons we went with an air launch uh
technology is that it is fully reusable
and I don't just mean reusable 10 or 20
times I mean 500 or a thousand times
right these ships are built uh for a
five or ten year Lifetime and we can get
hundreds and hundreds of missions out of
them there's a few components that need
to be replaced we can work on the
sustainability there the impact we have
on the ground can also be worked on
right so we never want to stop but I
think it's important to recognize uh you
have to weigh the value as well as the
impact of what you're doing so I think
we see a a global surgeons in attention
on this and I think we all plan to be
good stewards of the the planet that we
want to go uh explore just briefly
Melissa because I know space
sustainability is really important to
you in Cornwall isn't it space for good
is your thing yeah space for good is our
purpose and it's building on exactly
what Mike just said but you know our
issue with the industry as it's gone on
is space has always been quite secretive
it's not been very transparent and
that's something I think that
fundamentally needs to change as more
commercial businesses come in but more
public become engaged in the industry
you know we're becoming multi-planetary
species we need all of you to be
involved in that conversation so for us
it's really important that we first of
all start with transparency so what is
the car carbon impacts and that's really
difficult because a lot a lot of people
have been asked that question before not
a lot of launch operators have been
asked what your carbon impact is what
happens when the stages fall into the
sea those big questions have not really
been massively researched or understood
or the impact on the atmosphere as
something goes through it so that's what
we're trying to fundamentally understand
as Mike said air launch is a lot less
impactful but we're not going to just
stop there we want to look at you know
how do we look holistically across the
life cycle to decrease that impact so
that when we're launching these
incredible Technologies we're not adding
to the problem
and we've got a question from Anthony
Baker Anthony where are you
just wait from the microphone we'll get
one to you and then you can ask your
question to the panel just stand so we
can see you that's it hello thank you
um so the European Union has a a space
program called Copernicus which is Earth
observation looking at the Earth
the UK is likely to pull out of that
system uh releasing hundreds of millions
of pounds what would the panel do with
that money for the UK space agency
Martin
hmm
well let's say this is one of the
downsides of brexit that although
fortunately we are in the scientific
program of Esa we are not in the
applications programs uh like uh
Copernicus and Galileo and this is this
is bad news
um I think we um uh need to spend the
money if we can't revive it on other
environmental exploration
um
preferably from space but also doing
more on the ground and because if if I
can um uh go back to what was said
earlier
um I think that um the impression of the
Earth from space has had a positive
effect of making people care more about
the environments
um but uh it it doesn't
produce very much if people may worry
that these Rockets pollute the Earth but
each rocket I guess is not too different
for one flight of a jumbo jet so that's
not big but um thinking about
um the environment
um I I do disagree very much with the
musk and people in talking about
um
uh
escaping the Earth's Problems by sending
millions of people to Mars I think
that's a dangerous illusion we've got to
focus on solving these problems here on
Earth
um and uh it's a Doddle to do those
compared to terraforming Mars for those
we know it's it's very difficult but I
think
as part of that then we need to engage
with the science and of course if we
can't have Copernicus which is very sad
for the UK then we must develop other
areas I mean for instance to give one
example
um I think the UK could lead in computer
modeling of climate change I know um
there's a famous uh uh space artist
called Tim Palmer in Oxford who talks
about a CERN for climate change which
would have big computers to do far
better modeling of climate change so um
there's something we can do on the
European scale even if you can't be part
of Copernicus
thank you for that question Anthony so
uh Luca on Twitter asks are there plans
to colonize the moon in the next five
years well Nicole you must be pretty
tapped into what NASA does these days do
you think we should be going to the moon
and colonize it
well I think we should be going to the
moon and settling it um I don't know
that I'd use the word colonizing but
um
yeah I think there's I think there's
purpose in it I think there is plans for
it
um I'll have my fingers crossed that
those people are making those first
steps in the next five years that would
be a wonderful
uh I think very meaningful follow-on to
this um Artemis one flight that's going
on right now
and
um I you know I I look at this like part
of part of the steps to the answers to
the the earlier questions as well
um about why space why not
here when um in reality all of that
we're doing in space is ultimately about
here had the opportunity to participate
in Cope 26 last year where after doing
some research
um discovered to my surprise even that
over 70 percent of the data we need to
like measure the vital signs of of our
planet are coming to us from space and
um these public-private Partnerships
that we have going on right now are the
things both through the you know the
public money and the private money that
are leading us in a much
um I think in an accelerated fashion to
be able to use that data to solve our
planetary challenges but also to help us
um travel you know as humans further
from Earth one day I hope it's not
impossible Martin for us to be looking
at those other planets around those
different Suns as uh as possible homes
for us and kind of that interplanetary
very Star Trek future if you will and I
think this this position of positioning
of ourselves on the moon
um really is one of going to be one of
the greatest steps for us lifting our
lifting ability our launch ability off
of Earth and solving a big part of what
that problem might be by actually taking
us to other places in space from the
surface or the orbit of the moon
thanks Nicole just another one on on
Twitter Jason Stone my daughter would
like to ask what would it take to make a
rocket electric and not so reliant on
fossil fuels
you're a dreamer Martin
do you think that could be done
well of course uh the problem with
electric power as we know from attempts
to have electric Aviation is that uh
batteries are very heavy uh so I think
it's going to be very hard uh to have an
alternative to uh what we now have uh to
provide the big thrust for launching a
rock people do talk about space lifts
don't they that is taken reasonably
serious there's some way you might be
able to have people going up and down to
orbit using some kind of lift system
well the future is so called space
elevator where you have the power on the
ground because of course the the trouble
is that uh the rocket when you launch it
is way down by the fuel which weighs a
lot more than the actual cargo and so
when I could get around that but that's
a huge technology you want to have this
uh space elevator 20 000 Miles High out
to the geostation orbit so that's hard
um but I think that um it's hard to
substitute for the high thrust you need
to launch but course of nuclear power
can be used to provide
a small
amounts of power for a long time and or
already so I've got the rtgs have been
used on deep space missions and so I
think that's a feasible but uh I defer
to the experts on on the possibilities
for uh nuclear power in space for
migration Mike do you think you can ever
see nuclear power use being used on on
your kind of craft
uh you know I I think the the weight
issue and the thrust issue is really
like Martin said a huge challenge so I
think once you're in space you have
those options open up for you uh but to
get out of the gravity well of Earth I
think uh for for at least the first year
but future uh the chemical propulsion
systems are kind of where we're limited
to uh until we have a massive uh
technological breakthrough and the focus
on reusability and and lowering the cost
of excess I think we see better uh
better better Technologies there I think
on the ground side certainly the chance
to apply electrics uh and renewable
energy sources is is a wonderful thing
uh but for the actual Act of
transporting out of the gravity well I
think we're uh no pun intended stuck for
a little while
and another one on Twitter and I think
this one's for you uh Melissa and it
relates to space debris
um you know with a there's a risk of a
Cascade Event we're sending so many
um Rockets up now uh that there is a
danger of a collision and I guess
you need to think as we're making space
even more accessible with Spaceport
Cornwall and we've got one in uh two in
Scotland uh which are hoping to come on
on stream next year all of those taking
up multiple satellites space is getting
pretty crowded yeah and again going back
to a responsible launch as a gateway to
space it is a responsibility to look at
you know the the Technologies and the
satellites you're launching to space
what happens at their end of life and
it's a it's a huge Topic in the industry
as well as in the general public which
is fantastic because eight years ago
when I first started in this industry
and I sat down at a conference and you'd
hear all these incredible ideas about
how to mitigate against space debris
catching it with magnets or Nets but
they weren't getting funded
um and they weren't getting the
investment to get off the ground
literally and that's changing and that
is really down to political interest as
well as the public and you know we get
these questions probably the top five
question I get all the time so you're
starting to see that change and you're
starting to see startups with really
incredible Technologies for this
um starting to get funded so on our
first launch in a few weeks we have a
company called space Forge their startup
out of Cardiff and they're doing
something called inorbit manufacturing
they're looking at reasonability of
satellites as well you know that's just
the start of them and they're getting
Venture Capital at involved and then it
goes to regulations and we kind of
touched on it earlier there's not really
been an Oneness on any company to clean
up their orbit or to clean up their
products once it comes to end of life
and I think again that's something
that's changing so our regulations with
the UK space agency they're looking at
an end-of-life policy deorbiting you
know what what happens to your satellite
you know what these small satellites
going up that might only have you know
five to ten years of a lifespan you know
we need to start to consider this and
put the onus back on the company's
um to clean up their their technology so
it doesn't cause you know as we send
more humans to space any issues
one last question from the audience
Andrew Karen where are you
at the back there just hang on a minute
we'll get a microphone to you
uh so I'm a founder of active kinetic
one uh we develop a new energy for
electricity and our question is
how are we going to power thousands of
people in space
um obviously there's no fossil fuels
um so what's the method that we've got
for interplanetary power
um incidentally we have actually got a
solution for that we think is quite good
but how would how would you guys do it
at this stage so to Martin just briefly
I mean how are we going to power a human
settlement on another planet yes
um well I mean I would guess with solar
energy and uh one thing which I'd add as
a footnote is that the idea of uh
getting so Lindsay in space and beating
it down to earth
um it seemed crazy 30 years ago but with
the ability of the new SpaceX rocket to
launch under tons of stuff at a time and
robots to assemble it and it's no longer
crazy I'm going to have to cut in there
we're coming to the end of our time
sorry we're against the clock uh being
live broadcast thank you very much
indeed everybody for joining us a panel
here experts giving us some sense of
excitement about the future of space
Thomas thank you and to our panel I
really mean it when that was out of this
world thank you everybody thoroughly
enjoyed that that was our final session
of Big Ideas live I'm going to invite
spot back onto the stage an encore for
spot because I didn't ask the key
question in our interview earlier spot
which is whether you can dance
apparently he can for those of you who
are staying with us there's our meet the
correspondence session uh in the
Innovation area at the back but for Big
Ideas live that's it for now we'll see
you next time take it away spot
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]